ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION FINANCE --
THIS MORNING WE HAVE THE HEARING
ON THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA --
BUDGET AND CERTAINLY WILL FOCUS
ON THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
TWENTY PROPOSAL WHAT'S IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
AS WELL WE WANT TO KNOW THAT AT
ABOUT TEN AM.
WE'RE WAITING FOR A FEW --
MEMBERS TO JOIN US INCLUDING OUR
BUDGET CHAIR AT SOMEONE MEMBER
TING WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THE
DISCUSSION ON THE ADMISSIONS --
UP SCANDAL AND SPECIFICALLY HOW
IT RELATES TO THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA SO WE'LL GET TO THAT
A LITTLE BIT BUT IT'S ONE OF
PRACTICE THAT WE KNOW IT'S MUCH.
BIGGER THAN THE UC BUT WE ARE --
DISCUSSING YOU SEE BUDGET TODAY
AND THERE ARE A COUPLE THE
DISTURBING EXAMPLES WITH A UC
PERSONAL INVOLVE SO WE'LL WE'LL
GET TO THAT A BIT LATER.
BUT A FOCUS OF THE AT THE AT THE
OUTSET ON THE OVERALL BUDGET SO.
THE GOVERNOR'S TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TONY BUDGET IS --
A GOOD START IN INVESTING IN THE
UNIVERSE CALIFORNIA.
ARE --
PREMIER RESEARCH UNIVERSITY HERE
WONDERING FORTY MILLION IN NEW
ONGOING FUNDING FOR CORE
SERVICES --
AND MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
ONE TIME --
FOR YOU SEE ALLOWING US TO DEAL
WITH COST INCREASES SOME
BUILDING MAINTENANCE --
AS WELL SOME IMPORTANT FUNDING
TO ADDRESS.
STUDENT ISSUES LIKE --
HOUSING AND SECURITY --
HUNGER AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET APPROACH AND
OUR STARTING OUT IN THE EARLY
STAGES OF THE OF THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET.
THERE ARE SOME ISSUES THAT ARE
THAT ARE ABSENT THAT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE ADDRESS ONE IS
ENROLLMENT GROWTH WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S A BIG DEMAND.
FOR A YOU SEE EDUCATION FROM OUR
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES MORE AND
MORE HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS ARE
GRADUATING.
AND TAKING THEIR REQUIRED YOU
SEE ELIGIBLE.
SELL ONE DISAPPOINTING NO IS
THERE ISN'T ANY MONEY --
FOR ANY ENROLLMENT GROWTH NOT
NOT NOT ONE NEW STUDENT IN THE
UC A BUDGET PROPOSAL THERE IS
MONEY TO FUND PRIOR YEARS
COMMITMENTS BUT NO --
A NEW ENROLLMENT SEEAND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE --
WE ADDRESS THAT WE'RE ALSO GOING
TO HEAR FROM THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT ON THE YEAR BUDGET
PRACTICE IS A FOLLOW UP ON THE
STATE AUDITOR'S ASSESSMENT AS
FAR AS HOW THE IMPLEMENTATION IS
GOING.
AND TO MAKE SURE THE OFFICE OF
THE PRESIDENT BUDGET IS ON TRACK.
AND THEN --
FINALLY WILL BE TALKING ABOUT
THE THE UC --
PATH ISSUE SO --
WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
AND KIND OF JUMP AROUND WE'RE
GONNA START WITH ISSUE NUMBER.
TWO ON UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
ENROLLMENT.
BUT WITH THAT WE DO HAVE FOR
HERE AND THAT WHEN WE TAKE ROLE
[inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
BRO --
MEDINA.
O'DONNELL.
FORM IS ESTABLISHED.
OKAY THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
GOOD MORNING JESS WALTER FROM A
FINANCE --
TO BEGIN A LIKE TO KNOW THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES INCLUDE
TEN MILLION ONGOING GENERAL FUND
SUPPORT ROMAN GROWTH CURRENTLY
PAY FOURTH ONE TIME FUNDS
PROVIDED IN THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BUDGET ACT --
TO DISCUSS THE RATIONALE BEHIND --
THE GOVERNOR'S THE TIRE PACKAGE
DEMONSTRATION SELECTED THE MOST
CRITICAL PIECES OF UC'S BUDGET
REQUEST ALREADY NEGOTIATED
SALARY INCREASES ENSURING
STUDENTS ARE FED AND HOUSED.
IN PROVIDING NEEDED MENTAL
HEALTH RESOURCES HOWEVER THE
ADMINISTRATION REMAINS OPENING --
TO FUNDING AROMA GROWTH WITHIN
THE ARCHITECTURE OF THE SEA
BUDGET THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY BRIEF.
ELIO DECENT CONCENTRATES.
THIS ITEM REALLY HAS TO ISSUES
BEFORE YOU THE FIRST IS AS THE
ADMINISTRATION NOTED --
ENROLLMENT GROWTH AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND THEN THE
SECOND ISSUE IS A MOMENT IN
TWENTY IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
AND AND IN FUTURE YEARS.
SO I WANT TO ADDRESS EACH ISSUE
ONE OF THE TIME.
REGARDING THE FIRST ISSUE AND
MOMENT IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THIS
ISSUE HAS SOME HAS A LOT OF
BACKSTORY THAT'S SICKLY THE
STATE PROVIDED SOME ONE TIME
FUNDING IN THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
BUDGET --
FOR ADDITIONAL ROMAN GROWTH --
BEYOND WHAT WAS EXPLICITLY
CALLED FOR IN THE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGET.
I THE ISSUE HERE IS THAT THE IN
PROVIDING THOSE FUNDS THIS
BUDGET DIDN'T SPECIFY THOUGH THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS THAT YOU SEE
WAS TO ENROLL.
AND IT DIDN'T ALSO SPECIFY HOW
YOU SEE WHAT'S A CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THAT GROWTH AFTER.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN ON COULD YOU
SEE CURRENTLY ESTIMATES THAT IT
IT WILL ENROLL ABOUT NINETEEN
HUNDRED MORE STUDENTS THAN --
WAS EXPLICITLY OF A BUDGET IN
THE AND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET
AND THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING TO
PROVIDE TEN MILLION DOLLARS.
WHICH WOULD SUPPORT A THOUSAND
STUDENTS SO LITTLE MORE THAN
HALF OF THAT THOSE ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS.
AND GIVEN THE OF THE BIG ISSUES
IN THE IN THE LANGUAGE WE THINK
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S APPROACHES
WITH ONE REASONABLE APPROACH.
APPROXIMATELY THE QUESTION
REALLY RESIDES WITH THIS
COMMITTEE IN THE LEGISLATURE
REST OF WHAT THE LEGISLATURE
INTENDED HOW MANY STUDENTS
LEGISLATURE INTENDED YOU SEE THE
TO SUPPORT AN ACT WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE'S INTENTIONS WERE
WITH.
PROVIDING ONE TIME FUNDING AND
HOW YOU SEE WOULD COVER THAT
COST IN FUTURE YEARS --
WITH REGARD TO THE SECOND ISSUE
ENROLLMENT GROWTH IN LATER YEARS
AS IT HAS BEEN REFERENCED THE
GOVERNOR ISN'T PROPOSING ISN'T
SETTING --
AND ROMAN TARGET FOR YOU SEE IN
NINETEEN TWENTY AND ALSO IS IN
PROVIDING ANY ADDITIONAL FUNDING
IN THE BUDGET FOR GROWTH --
BEYOND WHAT WAS AN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN WE DO RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE SET A TARGET --
IN OUR VIEW THAT'S ONE OF THE
KEY WAYS THE LEGISLATURE IS
MEETING ITS EXPECTATIONS. ONE
RECOMMENDATION OUR OFFICE DOES
HAVE THOUGH IS THAT YOU SAID
THAT TARGET FOR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE INSTEAD OF NINETEEN TWENTY
IN A REASONING THERE IS A BY THE
TIME YOU ENACT THE BUDGET.
ARE YOU SEE WILL HAVE MADE MOST
OF ITS FALL ADMISSION DECISIONS --
FOR I'D FALL TWENTY NINETEEN
FACT THEY'RE MAKING A LOT OF
THESE DECISIONS RIGHT NOW AS WE
SPEAK.
IN TERMS OF OUR WEATHER NOT THIS
TARGET SHOULD.
INCLUDE GROWTH OR NOT OR ARE HOW
MUCH GROWTH TO PROVIDE WE DO
OFFER SOME FACTORS FOR YOU TO
CONSIDER THIS COMMITTEE HAS
HEARD A LOT OF THESE FACTORS
BEFORE SO I'LL JUST GO THROUGH
THEM VERY QUICKLY.
ON THE ONE HAND AS AS WE'VE
NOTED IN THE PAST YOU SEE IS
LIKELY YOUR DRAWING FROM BEYOND
ITS A FRESHMAN ELIGIBILITY
ABILITY PAUL.
AND ADMINISTRATION PROJECTIONS
OF HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES --
THE THE PROJECT.
VERY SLIGHT DECLINES OF HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATES OVER THE NEXT
FEW YEARS AND SO THOSE TWO
FACTORS SUGGEST THAT ENROLLMENT
GROWTH.
MAY NOT BE AS HIGH OF A PRIORITY
ON THE OTHER HAND --
MANY STUDENTS ARE STILL
REDIRECTED --
TO MERCED ARE NOT ACCOMMODATED
TO THE FIRST COULD ALLOW THE
UNIVERSITY TO ACCOMMODATE MORE
STUDENTS TO THE FIRST CHOICE
CAMPUS AND THAT MIGHT BE A
PRIORITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TERM MCCARTY AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS SAY OF IT THEN AND I WILL BE
TALKING ON BEHALF OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TODAY
ON OUR OPERATING BUDGET.
I ALSO WANTED TO NOTE THAT WE
HAVE IN THE AUDIENCE ARE CHAIR
OF THE BOARD REGION --
GEORGE KEEFER WHO WILL BE
OBSERVING TODAY --
SINCE WE HAVE SOME NEW MEMBERS
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND IT'S
BEEN A WHILE SINCE I LAST
PRESENTED TO YOU I'M GOING TO
VERY BRIFLY GO OVER SOME VERY
HIGH LEVEL BASICS AND THE
SERGEANT HAS DISTRIBUTED TO HAND
OUT TO YOU.
THAT HAS THIS --
COLORFUL FRONT HERE --
ON SLIDE.
TO ON THE LEFT HAND SIDE YOU
WILL SEE A DONUT SHAPE PIE CHART
THAT IN CONTAINS THE ENTIRE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
OPERATING BUDGET --
FOR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THE TOTAL
YOU SEE BUDGET IS ESTIMATED AT
THIRTY SIX POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS.
YOU'LL NOTE THAT THE MEDICAL
CENTERS MAKE UP ROUGHLY ONE
THIRD OF THIS.
AND THE COMPONENT IN THE ORANGE
THERE ARE THE FOUR POINT FOUR
BILLION IS OUR GOVERNMENT
CONTRACTS AND GRANTS. FOR
BILLION OF THAT IS FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ARE GRANTS THAT UC
FACULTY BRING INTO THE STATE --
THAT THEN GETS DISTRIBUTED --
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY --
IN THE YELLOW YOU WILL SEE OUR
SALES AND SERVICES THOSE ARE THE
AUXILIARIES TO INCLUDE THINGS
LIKE OUR DORMITORIES.
THE FOOD SERVICES THE PARKING
ARE CONSIDERED --
SELF CONTAINED THE THE PAY FOR
THEMSELVES AND ON THE RIGHT HAND
SIDE OF THE PAGE WE HAVE THE
UC'S CORE FUNDS BUDGET THIS IS
ABOUT ONE FOURTH OF OUR TOTAL
OPERATING BUDGET.
BUT THIS IS THE COMPONENT OF THE
BUDGET THAT PAYS FOR THE CAMPUS
OPERATIONS AN INSTRUCTION THAT
WILL BE FOCUSING ON IN THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE.
THE TOTAL UC CORE FUNDS BUDGET
IS ABOUT NINE POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS AND ALL OF THAT
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED
FORTY MILLION GOES TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT.
YOU'LL BE HEARING ABOUT THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT BUDGET
LATER ON IN THIS PRESENTATION.
SEPARATELY --
FROM THE CORE FUNDS.
THE STATE PROVIDES APPROXIMATELY --
ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS.
FOR FOR UNIVERSITY OPERATIONS
AND STUDENT FEES --
THAT BEING TUITION AND STUDENT
SERVICES FEE PROVIDE ANOTHER
THREE POINT NINE BILLION DOLLARS.
FROM OUR NON RESIDENTS
SUPPLEMENTAL TUITION PAID BY OUR
NON RESIDENT STUDENTS TO
UNIVERSITY IS NOW GETTING. ONE
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY.
SO IT IS HAS BECOME A
SIGNIFICANT SOURCE OF REVENUE
FOR THE UNIVERSITY I ALSO WANT
TO NOTE THAT OUT OF OUR CORE
FUNDS WE HAVE CERTAIN
EXPENDITURES COME OUT THAT THE
UNIVERSITY HAS VERY LITTLE
CONTROL OVER.
THAT WE CANNOT RE DIRECT FOR
OTHER PURPOSES THESE INCLUDE OUR
GENERAL OBLIGATION BOND DEBT
SERVICE PAYMENTS --
THEY ALSO INCLUDE PAYMENTS FIRST
YOU HAVE CALIFORNIA RETIREMENT
PROGRAM WHICH IS A SELF
CONTAINED RETIREMENT PROGRAM FOR
YOU SEE EMPLOYEES.
AND IT ALSO WE INCLUDE OUR
STUDENT FINANCIAL AID AND THAT
BECAUSE WE WANT TO SUPPORT OUR
STUDENTS.
THOSE THREE COMPONENTS TOGETHER
AMOUNT TO ABOUT ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS THAT NEEDS TO BE
TAKEN OUT OF THAT NINE POINT
THREE BILLION DOLLAR FIGURE WHEN
WE DISCUSS HOW MUCH IS ACTUALLY
AVAILABLE FOR OPERATIONS.
NOW I'D LIKE TO DIRECT YOUR
ATTENTION TO SLIDE.
THREE THE REGION'S RECENTLY TOOK
ACTION.
ON A MULTI YEAR PLAN --
DO ESTABLISH A BROAD FRAMEWORK
OF A VISION FOR THE UNIVERSITY
UNTIL.
TWENTY THIRTY THE EMPHASIS OF
THIS VISION IS TO MOVE AWAY FROM
A YEAR TO YEAR ENROLLMENT
MANAGEMENT TO WORK AN OUTCOMES
BASED APPROACH PARTY UNIVERSITY.
AT THE HEART OF THIS VISION IS A
DEEP COMMITMENT TO THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM AND ENSURING
THAT.
YOU SEE BOTH MAINTAINS ACCESS
AND PROVIDES OPPORTUNITIES TO
SUCCEED FOR ALL OF OUR STUDENTS.
THIS VERSION INCLUDES AN
INVESTMENT IN OUR FACULTY WHO
MENTOR THE NEXT GENERATION OF
THOUGHT LEADERS AND GENERATE.
ECONOMIC GROWTH FOR CALIFORNIA
THROUGH THEIR INVENTIONS AND
GRANTS THAT THEY BRING INTO THE
STATE.
AND OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS THE
REGION'S MULTI YEAR PLAN WILL
INCREASE ENROLLMENT MODESTLY --
PRIMARILY FOCUS ON CLOSING
GRADUATION GAPS SHORTENING TIME
TO DEGREE AND BRINGING THOSE WHO
LEFT WITHOUT A DEGREE BACK FOR
COMPLETION.
ON THE NEXT SLIDE I WANTED TO
BRIEFLY SHOW.
WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY TEN
BUDGET INTRODUCTION PROVIDED
THAT THE UNIVERSITY?
AS THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ALREADY DISCUSSED THE UNIVERSITY
RECEIVED A TOTAL OF THREE
HUNDRED NINETY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS.
OF THIS ABOUT TWO OF OF THIS
AMOUNT TO HER I'M GOING FUNDING
FOR THE UNIVERSITY.
AND THIS WAS DIVIDED INTO THE
CATEGORIES YOU SEE LIST THAT
THERE ON THE PAGE BY BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE.
WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OF PERMANENTLY
ON DOES TO SO CALLED PROP FIFTY
SIX SWAP.
THAT WILL ALLOW YOU SEE TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THE PROP
FIFTY SIX FUNDS STATE WIDE AS
GRANTS OF FOR MEDICAL RESIDENTS.
ON SLIDE --
FIVE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
PROVIDED.
THE UNIVERSITY SOMEONE TIME
FUNDS.
A TOTAL OF HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS OF WHICH
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT MILLION
THIS FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
THESE ITEMS WILL BE DISCUSSED
LATER IN THE IN THE AGENDA SOLVE
NOT DWELL ON THEM RIGHT NOW.
ON SLIDE SIX I GO INTO.
THE UNIVERSITIES --
BUDGET REQUEST IN ADDITION TO
WHAT WAS IN YOUR GIRLS THE PAGE
NUMBERS --
TO YES LIKE SIX IS WHERE I AM
RIGHT NOW THE PAYCHECKS PAGE --
SIX THAT GOES INTO THE
UNIVERSITY'S BUDGET REQUEST IN
ADDITION TO WHAT WAS INCLUDED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S JAN TEN BUDGET.
I BROKEN DOWN THIS REQUEST IN
THE THREE PRIMARY CATEGORIES THE
NINETY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THAT
WE RECEIVED A ONE TIME IN THE
CURRENT YEAR.
THAT GOES AWAY ON JUNE THIRTIETH
IF WE'RE REQUESTING BE MADE
PERMANENT.
BECAUSE THIS WAS FUNDING IN LIEU
OF A TWO IT'S FUNDING TO SUPPORT
STUDENTS.
THERE'S ANOTHER SEVENTY TWO
POINT SIX MILLION TO GROW ACCESS
AND SUPPORT STUDENTS AND THIS IS
PRIMARILY WHERE ARE ENROLLMENT
FOR QUEST RECITES AND I'LL GO
INTO THAT VERY SHORTLY.
CAPITAL OUTLAY DEBT SERVICE THAT
ALSO WILL BE DISCUSSED LATER ON
IN THIS AGENDA.
SLIDE.
SEVEN INCLUDES THE VARIOUS
COMPONENTS OF OUR ENROLLMENT FOR
QUEST.
THE UNIVERSITY IS REQUESTING
FORTY POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR NEW ENROLLMENT
GROWTH THIS IS IN ADDITION TO
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
THIS INCLUDES TWO THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED NEW CALIFORNIA
UNDERGRADUATES AND ONE THOUSAND
NEW CALIPH NEW GRADUATE STUDENTS.
THIS IS AT THE NEW MARGINAL COST
OF INSTRUCTION.
IN ADDITION TO THIS NEW
ENROLLMENT GROWTH REQUEST
UNIVERSITIES REQUESTING FUNDING
FOR EXISTING ENROLLMENT WHICH WE
HAVE NOT RECEIVED THE MARGINAL
COST OF INSTRUCTION.
FOR THESE CURRENTLY ENROLLED
STUDENTS INCLUDED AND ROLL OVER
AND ROMAN IN THE FALL TWENTY
EIGHTEEN CLASS OF CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS STUDENTS BY NEARLY
NINETEEN HUNDRED STUDENTS.
ON TOP WITH THE TWO THOUSAND FOR
WHICH FUNDING WAS --
PROVIDED.
OR BUT FUNDING WAS IDENTIFIED
FOR THOSE STUDENTS.
ALSO THE PRIME GRADUATE MEDICAL
PROGRAM WHICH IS A SPECIAL
COMPONENT OF MOST UC MEDICAL
SCHOOLS WHERE STUDENTS PLEDGE TO
WORK AS PRIMARY CARE DOCTORS IN
MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED AREAS.
THAT PROGRAM CURRENTLY HAS TWO
HUNDRED FORTY SIX STUDENTS FOR
WHICH WE KNOW MARGINAL COST OF
INSTRUCTION IT'S BEING RECEIVED.
AND WE'RE REQUESTING THAT THOSE
STUDENTS BE FULLY STUDENT
MARGINAL COST OF INSTRUCTION
WHICH IS SLIGHTLY HIGHER AT
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND PER STUDENT.
NOT SHOWN ON THE SLIDE IS A TWO
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED CALIFORNIA
UNDERGRADUATES.
OF FOR WHOM YOU SEE RECEIVED ONE
TIME --
MARGINAL COST OF INSTRUCTION
FUNDS IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THOSE
ARE AND THE NINETY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR REQUEST --
ON SLIDE EIGHT THE NEXT PAGE --
PROVIDES THIS CHART SHOWING HOW
RAPIDLY UC'S RESIDENT
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS HAVE
GROWN OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS.
WE HAVE LET IN A LARGE NUMBER OF
RESIDENT UNDERGRADUATES.
AND THIS HAS BEEN EXTREMELY GOOD
FOR OUR STUDENTS.
BUT IT ALSO RESULTS IN SOME
FINANCIAL NEEDS WERE THE
UNIVERSITY DO STUDENTS NEED TO
BE FINANCIALLY SUPPORTED --
THEY NEED ADDITIONAL MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES THEY NEED
ADDITIONAL ACADEMIC COUNSELORS
AND OBVIOUSLY THEY NEED.
ADDITIONAL COURSES SO WE HAVE TO
HIRE DE UM INSTRUCTORS FOR THEM.
ON SLIDE.
NINE I GO INTO THE UNFUNDED
ENROLLMENT FOR THE UNIVERSITY
AND THIS HAS --
THIS ISSUE IS BECOMING QUITE
SERIOUS FOR US AT THIS POINT --
IF YOU LOOK AT THE CHART ON THE
LEFT HAND SIDE YOU WILL SEE BY.
THE ACADEMIC YEAR AND THE TOTAL
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
UNDERGRADUATES LISTED NEXT TO IT --
THE NEXT COLUMN SHOWS THE GROWTH
OR DECLINE FROM THE PRIOR YEAR
HOW THOSE NUMBER TOTAL NUMBER OF
RESIDENTS HAS FLUCTUATED IN THE
UNIVERSITY.
THE BUDGET ACT MANDATED GROWTH
WAS THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING WE
RECEIVED A NUMBER STUDENTS WE
RECEIVED FUNDING.
FOR IN THE BUDGET ACT THAT WAS
IDENTIFIED NOW.
I HAVE NOT DONE ANY SUBTRACTIONS
FOR PARTIAL MARGINAL COST OR FOR
YOU SEE --
P. FUNDING OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT
THIS IS THE AMOUNT OF STUDENTS
THAT WE WERE IDENTIFIED TOGETHER
IN OUR DISCUSSIONS IS BEING
FUNDED.
SO THE LAST COLUMN THERE IS THE
UNFUNDED F. T. A GROWTH AND WE
ARE NOW IT'S OVER FOUR THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED STUDENTS SYSTEM
WIDE. FOR WHOM WE HAVE NOT
RECEIVED ANY MARGINAL COST OF
INSTRUCTION FUNDING FROM THE
STATE.
THIS IS GRADING SEVERE PROBLEMS
ON OUR CAMPUSES.
WHERE BEHIND AND FACULTY HIRING?
UP WE ARE MORE LECTURES RATHER
THAN A LADDER RANK FACULTY --
STUDENTS ARE NOT ABLE TO ALWAYS
GET INTO THE COURSES THEY NEED
WE HAVE INCREASING PROBLEMS WITH
BOTTLENECK COURSES.
WE'RE BEHIND ON HIRING AT
ACADEMIC ADVISORS. TO HELP THE
STUDENTS GREAT THERE --
STEM PROGRAMS OF STUDY SO THAT
THEY CAN GET THROUGH AND IN A
TIMELY FASHION.
OF THESE STUDENTS TWO THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED WERE FUNDED ONE
TIME IN THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
BUDGET AND WE ARE VERY MUCH
REQUESTING THAT THOSE FUNDS BE
MADE PERMANENT.
SO WE CAN CONTINUE TO SERVE
THOSE STUDENTS WITH THE
EDUCATION THEY HAVE BEEN
PROMISED.
ON SLIDE --
TEN I GO INTO A LITTLE BIT WHO
ARE THE STUDENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
ADMITTED RECENTLY --
WE HAVE.
OVER THE EIGHT THE LAST EIGHTEEN
YEARS SEEN ARE A LITTLE BIT OF A
CHANGE IN THE MIX F OUR
STUDENTS --
ETHNICITY WISE --
THE STUDENTS WHO ARE LATINO AND
LATINA ARE THE FASTEST GROWING
UNDERGRADUATE --
GROUP WITH IN THE UC SYSTEM --
IN FACT THREE OF OUR NOW CAMPUS
OF THREE OF OUR UNDERGRADUATE
CAMPUSES ARE NOW LISTED AS
HISPANIC SERVING INSTITUTIONS.
THOSE ARE UC IRVINE UC RIVERSIDE
AND UC MERCED --
UC'S FACULTY HIRING --
IS ALSO IMPROVING BUT MORE WORK
NEEDS TO BE DONE --
WE ARE HEAD OF OUR OTHER
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITIES INSTITUTIONS BOTH A
A YOU IN UNIVERSITIES --
WE ARE AT 10% OF U. R. M.
FACULTY AND THAT'S UNDER
REPRESENTED MINORITY FACULTY
WELL AS OTHER PUBLIC SORRY 8% --
BUT STILL MORE MORE WORK NEEDS
TO BE DONE ALSO SEE OUR HIRING
OF AFRICAN AMERICAN FACULTY HAS
MORE THAN DOUBLED SINCE --
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT AND ARE
HIRING FOR HISPANIC AND LATINO
LATINA FACULTY HAS INCREASED BY
90% SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT SO WE ARE
MAKING PROGRESS.
BUT MORE WORK NEEDS TO BE DONE
AND FOR THE LAST PAST THREE
YEARS THE LEGISLATURE PROVIDED
YOU SEE WITH TWO MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY IN ONE TIME FUNDS FOR
FACULTY DIVERSITY EFFORTS.
AND THESE FUNDS HELPED
TREMENDOUSLY WE HAD PILOT
PROGRAMS ON EIGHT OF OUR
CAMPUSES AND WE LEARNED A LOT OF
VALUABLE LESSONS.
IN HOW TO ATTRACT MORE DIVERSE.
POOL OF CANDIDATES SO THAT WE
HAD EXTREMELY QUALIFIED
CANDIDATES WHO OFFERED
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT THAT THE
UNIVERSITY.
OF SOME OF THESE LESSONS WERE
REQUIRING FACULTY DIVERSITY
STATEMENTS FROM THE CANDIDATES --
REQUESTING THEM FOR INFORMATION
ON HOW THEY WOULD HELP THE
DIVERSE ENVIRONMENT OF THE
UNIVERSITY --
AND ALSO A DIFFERENT RECRUITMENT
PRACTICES AND WHERE TO ADVERTISE
AND SO FORTH THOSE ALL HELPED.
SO THAT'S A BRIEF LOOK AT WHO
OUR STUDENTS ARE AND WHAT WE'VE
BEEN DOING TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT
OUR UNIVERSITY'S FACULTY
REFLECTS OUR STUDENT BODY.
ON PAGE ELEVEN WE HAVE OUR
UNDERGRADUATE NON RESIDENT
ENROLLMENT GROWTH.
WHICH YOU HAVE YOU WILL SEE HAS
BEEN GROWING --
AFTER STATE FUNDING WAS BROUGH
BACK -- IN
FUNDING ARE NON RESIDENT NUMBERS
ALSO GREW --
YOU WILL SEE THE NON RESIDENTS
REPRESENTED BY TWO YELLOW BAR
HAVE BEEN INCREASING OVER THE
LAST DECADE.
ARE NON RESIDENT ROMAN HAS
BECOME A SIGNIFICANT SOURCE OF
CORE FUND REVENUES FOR TO
UNIVERSITY YOU WILL RECALL IN
THE EARLIER PAGE WHERE WE TALKED
ABOUT THE TOTAL COR FUNDS OF THE
UNIVERSITY.
THAT NON RESIDENT SUPPLEMENTAL
TUITION IS NOW AT ONE POINT
EIGHT WHAT SORRY.
MY APOLOGIES ONE POINT THREE
BILLION.
ANNUALLY.
IN REVENUES FOR THE UNIVERSITY --
THE REGION'S ON MARCH FOURTEENTH
DECIDED TO DELAY A VOTE TO
INCREASE NON RESIDENT
SUPPLEMENTAL TUITION BY TWO
POINT 6%.
AND THAT INCREASE WOULD HAVE
YIELDED --
ABOUT TWENTY NINE MILLION IN NEW
REVENUE FOR THE UNIVERSITY BUT
IT'S STILL BEING DEBATED.
ON THE NEXT SLIDE --
I WANTED TO SHOW YOU HOW OUR
CORE FANS HAVE SHOWN OVER THE
LAST EIGHTEEN YEARS.
ON THE FAR LEFT YOU'LL SEE THAT
INFLATION ADJUSTED DOLLARS THE
UNIVERSITY HAS GROWN IT'S
FUNDING BY ABOUT 8% SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND SIR TOTAL FUNDING
DOLLAR WISE HAS BEEN GOING UP --
INCLUDED IN THAT AMOUNT IS ARE
NON RESIDENT --
SUPPLEMENTAL TUITION --
AND THE SUBCOMMITTEE HAS BEEN
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE HAS BEEN A
SIGNIFICANT PARTNER IN
INCREASING THIS AMOUNT OF
FUNDING.
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS YOU
VOTED EACH YEAR TO PROVIDE TO
UNIVERSITY WITH MORE RESOURCES --
FOR OUR CORE MISSION AND WE'RE
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT.
IN THE MIDDLE CHARGE YOU WILL
SEE THE TOTAL NUMBER OF STUDENTS
IN THE UNIVERSITY.
AND YOU'LL SEE THAT OUR
ENROLLMENT HAS SKYROCKETED BY
ABOUT 59% SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND THAT'S A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN STUDENTS
ON OUR CAMPUSES.
THAT NUMBER INCLUDES NON
RESIDENTS AS DOES THE CORE FUNDS
BAR ON THE FAR LEFT INCLUDE THE
NON RESIDENT SUPPLEMENTAL
TUITION.
ONCE THIS DRAMATIC GROWTH IN
STUDENT SUCCESS ACCESS IS
ACCOUNTED FOR THE DOLLARS PER
STUDENT AVAILABLE TO THE
CAMPUSES FOR INSTRUCTIONS ON
OPERATIONS.
THE SO CALLED CORE FUNDS PURSED
DECREASED BY 32% SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND THIS IS.
OF FORCING OUR CAMPUSES TO WORK
SMARTER AND HARDER WHICH THEY
CERTAINLY HAVE DONE WE HAVE
MULTIPLE INITIATIVES TO SAVE
FUNDING --
FROM PROCUREMENT TO ENERGY TO
OUR OF SELF INSURANCE PROGRAM UP
AND ELIMINATING --
TUITION FINANCIAL AID FOR NON
RESIDENTS --
BUT CAMPUSES ARE STILL
STRUGGLING.
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE IMPACTS OF
THE SONS PAGE THIRTEEN YOU'LL
SEE THE STUDENT TO FACULTY RATIO
AT UC HAS CAUGHT BEEN THE
CLIMBING?
SO WE HAVE FEWER LETTERING
FACULTY AND FEWER LECTURES EVEN --
FIRST FOUR PER STUDENT STAND OUR
PUBLIC COMPARISON INSTITUTIONS.
WHAT THIS DOES IT HAS --
OVERALL NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON
QUALITY.
THE MOST IMMEDIATE TANGIBLE
IMPACT ON THE STUDENTS HAS BEEN
THAT THE AMOUNT OF TIME A LOT
AROUND FACULTY HAVE AVAILABLE TO
MENTOR AND PROVIDE INDIVIDUAL
ATTENTION TO STUDENTS.
BOTH GRADUATE AND UNDERGRADUATE
HAS DECREASED --
AN ON SLIDE FOURTEEN YOU'LL SEE
SOME OF THE IMPACTS AS REPORTED
BY THE STUDENTS THEMSELVES EVERY
TWO YEARS WE DO AN UNDERGRADUATE
EXPERIENCE SURVEY OF OUR
STUDENTS.
AND WE'VE BEEN NOTING SOME
TROUBLING TRENDS.
ON THE LEFT YOU'LL SEE A BAR
CHART OF STUDENT RESPONSES ON
WHETHER OR NOT THEY WOULD STILL
AND ROLL LIKE YOU SEE AFTER TO
EXPERIENCE --
THEIR EXPERIENCE AT THE CAMPUS.
WE HAVE SEEN A DROP FROM 33% OF
STUDENTS STRONGLY AGREEING THAT
THEY WOULD STILL AND ROLL TO NOW
18%.
OF AGREEING THAT'S BEEN IN THE
LAST TEN YEARS THAT WE'VE SEEN
THE STROP --
WHAT'S BEHIND THESE NUMBERS ARE
THE EVERYDAY EXPERIENCES THAT
STUDENTS HAVE OF OVERCROWDED
CLASSROOMS WAIT TIMES TO SPEAK
TO AN ADVISOR AND BUILDING
CONDITIONS OF MAINTENANCE FUNDS
HAVE BEEN CUT BACK.
ON THE RIGHT SIDE OF THE PAGE
YOU'LL SEE EVEN MORE TROUBLING
TRENDS.
I'M BACK IN 200063% OF STUDENTS
RESPONDED NOT BEING ABLE TO GET
INTO THE MAJOR OFF THEIR FIRST
CHOICE. TEN YEARS LATER IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN THIS NUMBER HAD
INCREASED 213% OF STUDENTS NOT
GETTING INTO THEIR FIRST MAJOR.
WHEN STUDENTS CAN STUDY THE
SUBJECT THAT THEY'RE PASSIONATE
ABOUT THERE'S A LOSS OF PERSONAL
POTENTIAL AND OF FRUSTRATION AT
A SITUATION THAT COULD BE BUT A
COULD BE FIXED BY HIRING MORE
FROM?
INSTRUCTORS.
OUR UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS ARE
ALSO FEELING LESS CONNECTED TO
THEIR FACULTY WITH A 14% DROP
OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS IN
STUDENTS WHO FEEL THEY KNOW
THEIR FACULTY MEMBER MEMBER WELL
ENOUGH TO ASK FOR A LETTER OF
RECOMMENDATION.
AT THE START OF THEIR
UNDERGRADUATE STUDIES 39% OF YOU
SEE STUDENTS EXPRESS AN INTENT
TO GO TO GRADUATE SCHOOL.
THOSE WHO COMPLETE GRADUATE
SCHOOL AND EARNINGS
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE MONEY
THROUGHOUT THEIR CAREERS THAN
THOSE WHO. TO HAVE A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE.
BUT WHEN STUDENTS CAN'T GET A
LETTER OF RECOMMENDATION THOSE
PLANS TO ATTEND GRADUATE SCHOOL
MAY BE PUT ON HOLD.
AS MIGHT BE OTHER ACTIVITIES
THAT REQUIRE LETTERS OF
RECOMMENDATION.
SUCH A STUDY ABROAD IN APPLYING
FOR EXTERNAL SCHOLARSHIPS.
AND THE FINAL SLIDE ON THE
ENROLLMENT SORRY THIS IS MY
LONGEST PRESENTATION AND TEN
TIRE.
AGAIN THIS IS JUST THE
ENROLLMENT ITEM THIS IS A JUST A
GENERAL MIDNIGHT ON THE GENOCIDE --
SO WHAT OUR PLANS OUR PLANS ARE
TO HIRE EXCELLENT FACULTY.
THE REGION'S AS PART OF THEIR
MULTI YEAR PLAN.
HAVE DEVELOPED A FOR YOUR HIRING
PLAN FOR BLATTER RANG FACULTY ON
TOP OF THE FACULTY NEEDED TO
SIMPLY REPLACE THOSE WHO ARE
LEAVING ON RETIRING.
WE WANT TO USE THE ENROLLMENT
FUNDING THAT I DISCUSSED EARLIER
THAT SEVENTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS
WE WANT TO USE IT TO HIRE TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN NEW FACULTY
FAR UC CAMPUSES.
IN ORDER TO TEACH COURSES AND
MENTOR GRADUATE STUDENTS MENTOR
UNDERGRADUATES AND BRING IN
ADDITIONAL GRANTS TO THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY AND THAT
CONCLUDES MY PRESENTATION ON
ENROLLMENT.
THANK YOU SIR OKAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ENTERTAIN QUESTIONS ON THE
ENROLLMENT --
AS GENDER ITEM.
ALL OF A FEW BUT WHICH TO MAKE
IT MAKE COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LAMONT THANK YOU.
THERE IS A LOT OF DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE ROLE THAT FACULTY
PLAYS AND I'M JUST CURIOUS IF.
YOU KNOW THAT THE THE HOW THE
ACADEMIC SENATE OVERALL FOR THE
SYSTEM IS RESPONDING TO SOME.
OF THE AND THE NOT SO GREAT
BENEFITS OF THE CHANGES IN
FUNDING --
AND SPECIFICALLY WHEN THEY'RE
NOT ABLE TO MENTOR WHEN THEY'RE
NOT ABLE TO KIND OF CULTIVATE
THE NEXT RESEARCHERS THE NEXT --
GRADUATE STUDENTS PER SE I KNOW
THAT WHEN I MEAN THAT SOME OF
THE WORK THAT I DID WHEN I
WORKED AT THE UC AND THAT WAS
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR FACULTY SO
I'M JUST CURIOUS HOW THEIR AT
THE PRACTICALITY OF HOW THEY'RE
RESPONDING TO THIS.
I MEAN WHAT ARE FACTORED I I'M
SURE THEY'RE NOT HAPPY BUT WHAT
ARE THEY TRYING TO DO --
GIVEN HOW.
I MEAN THEY'RE LIMITED
[inaudible]
RESOURCES --
FACULTY NEED TIME TO MENTOR
THEIR GRADUATE STUDENTS THE PHD
STUDENTS AND THAT'S WHERE
THEY'RE PUTTING THEIR ATTENTION --
TO WHICH IS WHY WE SEE THE DROP
IN UNDERGRADUATES HAVING.
ACCESS TO SOME OF THE FACULTY
IT'S A STE --
WHEN THE FACULTY DON'T HAVE ANY
TIME AND WHEN THEY HAVE TOO MANY
STUDENTS I THINK THAT'S ONE OF
THE REAL IMPACTS OF IT --
THE FACULTY ARE ALSO FORCED TO
SEEK MORE OF THEIR OWN GRANTS
BECAUSE THE UNIVERSITY CAN'T
HELP THEM WITH --
THE BASICS FOR RUNNING THEIR
LABS OR THE FUNDING FOR THEIR
GRADUATE STUDENT FACULTY ARE
HAVING TO PAY FOR THOSE GRADUATE
STUDENT RESEARCH ASSISTANTS FROM.
THEIR OWN GRANTS THEIR SALARY
AND THE FEE REMISSION FOR THOSE
GRADUATE STUDENTS COMES OUT OF
THE FACULTIES.
GRANTS SO THAT THERE'S MORE
PRESSURE ON THE FACULTY --
TO APPLY FOR GRANTS SOME OF THE
CAMPUSES ACTUALLY I THINK ALL OF
THEM -- AS
STATE BEEN EXPERIENCING COST
PRESSURES HAVE TRIED --
TO POOL STAFF BETWEEN MULTIPLE
DEPARTMENTS SO DEPARTMENTS NO
LONGER HAVE THEIR INDIVIDUAL
STAFF BUT THEY WILL FOR EXAMPLE
HIGHER ONE INDIVIDUAL FOR A
MULTITUDE OF DEPARTMENTS WHO
HELPS THE FACULTY.
WITH ADDED IN THERE GRANT
PROPOSALS AND MANAGING THEM
FINANCES A COMMON FOR THOSE
GRANTS SO INSTEAD OF BACK IN THE
DISTANT PAST THEY USED TO HAVE --
AND A LARGE APARTMENT WOULD HAVE
THEIR OWN PERSON TO HELP THE
FACULTY WITHOUT NOW THEY SHARE
THOSE PEOPLE ACROSS DEPARTMENTS
IF THEY CAN'T AFFORD A FULL
LEFTY ANYMORE.
THANK YOU I THINK THAT THOSE ARE
SOME REAL CONCERNS I MEAN ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT MAKES ANY
UNIVERSITIES REPUTATION --
SKYROCKET OR NOT IS THE LEVEL OF
RESEARCH AND FACULTY THERE I
MEAN THAT'S HOW IT'S DRIVEN AND
IT'S A TRICKLE EFFECT BECAUSE
THERE ARE FACULTY WHO ARE
SEEKING POSITIONS BASED ON AT
THEIR ABILITY TO WORK WITH
GRADUATE STUDENTS AND UNDERGRADS
AND WHAT THAT MEANS FOR THEIR
RESEARCH FOR THEIR LAB. FOR
THEIR POTENTIAL TO APPLY TO GROW.
AND I CERTAINLY HOPE THAT WE
THINK ABOUT THAT I THINK IT'S
SOMETIMES EASY TO REMOVE THE
STUDENT EXPERIENCE FROM THE
FACULTY EXPERIENCE BUT AT LEAST --
FROM THE WORK THAT I DID AT THE
UC IT'S I MEAN THERE THERE
REALLY TANGIBLE.
THEY GO HAND IN HAND --
AND I WOULD HATE TO SEE A WORLD
WHERE.
AT OTHER UNIVERSITIES ARE SO
MUCH MORE.
COMPETITIVE WITH US THAT WE
START TO LOSE --
THE ABILITY TO TRACK THE BEST
FACULTY WHICH ATTRACTS THE BEST
STUDENTS WHICH ATTRACTS I THINK
YOU KNOW INVESTMENTS --
BOTH FROM OUTSIDE THE UNIVERSITY
AND OUR INVESTMENTS I I JUST
WANT TO CAUTION US ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE AS SOMEONE WHO WORKED
VERY DIRECTLY WITH STUDENTS AND
FACULTIES AND BUILDING THAT
RESEARCH BRIDGE --
I FOUND IT PARTICULARLY HELPFUL --
NOT JUST FOR THE FACULTY MEMBER
OR THE INSTITUTION BUT THE
STUDENTS THEMSELVES IT OPENED UP
PROFESSIONAL CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS TO
HAVE THAT INTERACTION.
WITH FACULTY.
MAYBE TO FOLLOW UP ON MISLI MON
ON THE STUDENT EXPERIENCE I I
FIND --
SLIDE FOURTEEN VERY TROUBLING --
AS THE THE DECLINE IN
SATISFACTION FROM 200-062-2000 --
SIXTEEN PARTICULARLY THE THE THE
SECOND WHEN THEY'RE NOT BEING
ABLE TO TO OF MAJOR IN THEIR
FIRST CHOICE OF MAJOR. 13% --
YOU KNOW I IT SEEMS LIKE TO ME
THAT PEOPLE OF BEGIN COLLEGE
WITH AN IDEA THAT THIS IS WHAT
THEY WANT TO STUDY THIS IS WHAT
THEY WANT TO GET THEIR DEGREE
AND AND TO HAVE THAT HIGH OF A
PERCENTAGE.
OF STUDENTS NOT BEING ABLE --
TO GET THE MAJOR THAT THEY WANT.
IS IS A VERY TROUBLING I
UNDERSTAND.
THAT IS TIED TO FUNDING
[inaudible]
SO.
NOW I HAVE TO GO TO A DIFFERENT
MAJOR -- GET
ON THEY GO FROM WHAT.
IT --
BIOLOGY.
TO SOMETHING OUTSIDE IN A ANY
ANY ANY INPUT THAT YOU CAN GIVE
US.
WE WE DON'T KNOW WE DON'T HAVE
DATE ON WHICH MAJOR SONS
ACTUALLY DO END UP SELECTING WE
WOULD THINK OF PROBABLY WOULD BE
A MAJOR RELATIVELY CLOSE TO WHAT.
I WANT TO AND ORIGINALLY STUDY --
BUT IT'S CERTAINLY LEADS TO
PERSONAL FRUSTRATION THEY COME
TO THE UNIVERSITY THEY THINK
THEY'RE GOING TO BE.
SOMETHING THEY HAVE THEIR OWN
PERSONAL ASPIRATIONS AND THEN
THEY GOT TOLD THERE'S NO ROOM
FOR YOU AND WITHIN THIS MAJOR --
AND PERHAPS THEY MOVE FROM --
CHEMISTRY.
TO PHYSICS OR BIOLOGY OR
SOMETHING YOU KNOW I'VE I'M NOT
CERTAIN WHAT THE COMPARABLE
MAJOR WOULD BE IT WOULD BE AN
ACADEMIC ADVISER WHO WOULD BE IN
CHARGE OF HELPING THE STUDENTS
IDENTIFIER DIFFERENT MAJOR.
HOWEVER WE'RE SHORT ON ACADEMIC
ADVISORS AND THE WAIT LIST IS
VERY LONG SO SOME OF THE ACTUAL
IMPACTS FOR THE STUDENT MAY BE
THAT THEY TRY TO END UP.
TAKING COURSES THAT THEY TEND
DON'T NEED FOR THE MAJOR WHERE
THEY ACTUALLY END UP THEY END UP
TAKING MORE UNITS THAN THEY NEED
TO STAND UP STAYING LONGER WITH
THE UNIVERSITY.
AND AS A RESULT THEY MAY BE
TAKING ON MORE PERSONAL DEBT
[inaudible]
YEAH WELL.
CERTAINLY --
AS AS MISLI MON SAID YOU KNOW
THE STUDENT EXPERIENCE I THINK
IS PARAMOUNT.
AND WHEN WE'RE SEEING --
DECLINE IN IN SATISFACTION IT'S
IT'S IS VERY TROUBLING.
SOMEONE NUMBER O'DONNELL.
YES JUST A QUESTION ABOUT A
TUITION OR FEES WHATEVER WE
LABEL IT.
IN STATE IS ABOUT TWELVE PER
YEAR IF I'M CORRECT --
YES --
ELEVEN THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
SEVENTY DOLLARS OUT OF STATE IS
ABOUT.
FORTY ONE THAT'S CORRECT M. WHAT
A STUDENT PAY THAT ALL FOUR
YEARS COULD THEY GET REIDENCY
AFTER THE FIRST YEAR NO
UNDERGRADUATES CANNOT GET
RESIDENCY AT ALL OKAY.
AND THEN WHAT ABOUT
INTERNATIONAL STUDENTS TO THEY
PAY OUT OF STATERS ARE DIFFERENT
INTERNATIONAL STUDENTS PAY OUT
OF STATE TUITION.
THERE'S NO INTERNATIONAL.
THERE IS NO EXTRA INTERNATIONAL
FEED THE WE DO CHARGE FEES FOR
ANY VISA PROCESSING.
THAT OCCUR HAD THAT THE CAMPUS
MAY HAVE TO DO AND WE STE SOME
CAMPUSES CHARGE SOME.
FEES NOW THAT AFTER --
AFTER NINE ELEVEN THERE WERE
SOME LAWS PUT IN PLACE THAT WE
HAVE TO TRACK THAT THE STUDENT
IS ACTUALLY ENROLLED.
AND THE WE HAVE SOME THINGS THAT
WE HAVE TO CHECK STUDENT FOR SO
WE CHARGE A FEE FOR THAT.
DO YOU DO YOU KNOW --
I SEE THE THE OUT OF STATE THE
THE FIGURES ASSOCIATE WITH OUT
OF STATE.
WHAT WHAT'S DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY
ARE OUT OF STATE VERSUS OUT OF
COUNTRY --
LET'S SEE I HAVE JUST OUR MOST
RECENT FRESHMAN CLASS --
IT'S UP ABOUT ONE THIRD DOMESTIC
TWO THIRDS INTERNATIONAL FOOD
YOU OTHER UNIVERSITIES ACROSS
THE UNITED STATES CHARGING
INTERNATIONAL FEE AS OPPOSED TO
AN OUT OF STATE FEE.
THE EARLY IF THEY CHARGE I'M NOT
CERTAIN I THINK I BELIEVE MOST
OF THEM CHARGE THIS I'M NOT ON
HOLD TO THAT WE CAN FIND THAT
OUT LATER YEAH I GOT MIGHT GET
SO THAT AIM TO EXPLORE.
OR AT LEAST IF THE QUESTION I
I'D LIKE TO KNOW A LITTLE BIT
MORE INFORMATION --
AND THEN I'M I'M LOOKING AT
SLIDE --
FOURTEEN SIGNIFICANT DECLINE IN
STUDENTS STRONGLY AGREE THAT
THEY WOULD AND ROLL AGAIN --
ONE MORE STUDENTS CANNOT GET
THEIR MAJOR TWO STUDENTS ARE
LESS CONNECTED WITH THE FACULTY
SO WHAT WHAT IS THE UNIVERSITY.
DOING ABOUT THAT.
WE ARE REQUEST YOU CAN GET HAVE
INITIATIVES TO ADDRESS THIS THIS
DATA.
OF WE'RE REQUESTING THAT YOU
PROVIDE US WITH SEVENTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
IT CAN'T COME HERE AND SAY IT'S
IT'S YOUR PROBLEM IT'S OUR
PROBLEM AND THE ANSWER CAN'T
ONLY BE DOLLARS THERE MUST BE
SOME OTHER THINGS.
GOING ON IN THE UNIVERSITY TO IT.
THAT THAT THAT CREATES THIS
DYNAMIC.
YOU HAVE INITIATIVE TO ADDRESS
THIS DATA OR NO.
YOU KNOW.
WE ARE LOOKING AT STUDENT
SUCCESS INITIATIVES WHICH ARE
CREATING --
A MORE TIME FOR STUDENTS WITH
PIERRE COHORTS FOR EXAMPLE --
SO STUDENTS WOULD COME IN AND
TAKE A CERTAIN SET OF COURSES ON
THEIR FIRST YEAR WITH THEIR
PEERS SO THAT THEY DEVELOP
STRONG BONDS WITH OTHER STUDENTS --
SO THAT THEY CAN DO PEER TO PEER
MENTORING AND FEEL MORE
CONNECTED TO THE UNIVERSITY AS A
WHOLE -- WE
ARE LOOKING AT HIRING NEW
ADVISERS BUT FRANKLY SIR A LOT
OF THE THINGS WE WANT TO DO COST
A LOT OF MONEY I GET THAT AND
AND I MONEY MIGHT BE PART OF THE
ANSWER BUT IT CAN'T BE.
THE ONLY ANSWER SO I WOULD
SUGGEST THE UNIVERSITY TAKE A
LOOK WITHIN ITSELF AS WELL.
AND NOT JUST COME TO US AND SAY
WITH ANSWERS MORE MONEY MORE
MONEY THAT MIGHT BE PART OF THE
ANSWER I CAN SEE THAT OUT OF THE
GATE.
HOWEVER I AYE THIS DATA IS
TELLING YOU SOMETHING AND I
THINK YOU ARE LOOK AT YOURSELVES
AS A HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER I
COULDN'T JUST SAY HEY.
WELL I HAD MORE MONEY I COULD I
COULD I COULD FIX THESE PROBLEMS
WE HAD TO TO REBOOT.
HOW WE OPERATE A REBOOT HOW WE
ADDRESSED OUR MISSION WITHOUT
MORE DOLLARS OFTEN OFTEN IN
TIMES OF DECLINING DOLLARS?
SO I WOULD JUST HOPE YOU THE
UNIVERSITY WOULD TAKE THAT BACK
AND CONTEMPLATE THAT QUESTION
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR [inaudible]
OKAY.
OUR FEW QUESTIONS HERE I WON I
JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT ON THE
ACT WE CAN MAKE THIS POINT EVERY
EVERY YEAR OF US WHEN THE
CLARIFY THAT.
ON THE STATE FUNDING OVERALL
SURE CALIFORNIA WE'RE NOT
STEPPING UP TO FIND HIGHER ADD
LIKE THE ONE WE SHOULD BE.
OR TO LIKE WE DID --
DECADES BEFORE I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT NOTE THAT IN ADDITION
TO THE STATE GENERAL FUND THREE
POINT SEVEN BILLION.
OF THAT TUITION REVENUE --
I BELIEVE OVER A BILLION A STATE
MONEY THROUGH THE CALTRANS AND
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM.
SO THAT IS MONEY FROM THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM SO I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE --
I WANTED --
TO JUST MENTION.
JUST --
MAYBE ASK YOU OR REGION
PRESIDENT KEY FOR BEHIND YOU.
ON THE NON RESIDENT TUITION
INCREASE AS MR DONALD SAID IT'S
NON RESIDENT REGARDLESS OF OF IF
YOU'RE INTERNATIONAL OR AT YOU
KNOW WEALTHY OUT OF STATERS --
I WENT TO THERE IS ONE ISSUE
THAT CAME UP WITH THE REDUCE
MEETING WITH US A LITTLE
CONCERNING AND THAT'S THE THE
STUDENTS THAT ARE UNDOCUMENTED
THAT.
AB FIVE FORTY KIDS WHO SOMEHOW.
ARE JUST MISSING OUT SO I'M NOT
SURE IF WHEN THEY TALK ABOUT
THIS NOW BUT WE WE ARE
INTERESTED IF IF THE UC WANTS.
TO TALK WORK WITH US AND AND IF
NEEDS TO BE SOME CLARIFICATION
[inaudible] TO MAKE SOME OF
THOSE KIDS WHO ARE SLIPPING
THROUGH THE CRACKS AREN'T
BECAUSE THAT CERTAINLY WAS IS
NOT THE INTENT OF THE POLICY --
SIR WE'RE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
ARE UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS WE DO
HAVE -- SOME
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS.
FOR OF AT THE A LOAN PROGRAM FOR
THOSE WHO DON'T QUALIFY THE FOR
FOR THE AB FIVE FORTY WAIVER AND
WE'D BE VERY HAPPY TO WORK WITH
YOU TO TRY AND FIND SOLUTIONS.
YOUR CORRECT THERE'S A GROUP OF
STUDENTS WERE SLIPPING THROUGH
THE CRACKS.
OF THE DOCK A PROGRAM ADDRESSES
ONLY THOSE STUDENTS WHO CAME
HERE BEFORE THE AGE OF TWELVE
AND THE AB FIVE FORTY PROGRAM
COVERS ONLY THOSE WHO CRAFTED AT
LEAST THREE YEARS OF CALIFORNIA
HIGH SCHOOL.
SO THERE'S A VERY SMALL BAND OF
STUDENTS WHO CAME HERE AFTER --
TWELVE BUT THE OR WHO CAME HERE
AFTER THEY WERE OVER TWELVE
YEARS OLD AND DID NOT COMPLETE
THREE YEARS A CALIFORNIA HIGH
SCHOOL.
SO IF THEY COMPLETED THEIR
JUNIOR AND SENIOR YEAR IN HIGH
CALIFORNIA THEY WOULD NOT
QUALIFY FOR THAT AB FIVE FORTY
WAIVER YEAH WE CAN FOLLOW UP
WITH THAT JUST WANT TO KNOW ONE
THAT THE NUMBER.
AND THE FOLLOW UP WITH IT WITH
OUR STAFF.
AND THEN TO WHAT POLICIES WE
NEED TO ADDRESS BECAUSE
CERTAINLY THAT'S NOT THE THE THE
POPULATION WHERE WE'RE LOOKING --
TO CUT OUT WITH THE NON READ NON
RESIDENT --
TUITION INCREASES --
ARE SOMETHING THAT THE REGION'S
SHOULD CONSIDER --
I JUST I WANNA READ THE QUOTE
FROM.
THE PUBLICADO WHEN SHE TOLD THE
REGION SAID THAT THIRTY MILLION.
THAT WAS ON THE TABLE WOULD GO
FOR AND ROLLING MORE.
CALIFORNIA KIDS --
INCREASED FINANCIAL AID HIRE
MORE FACULTY AND STAFF AND
TEACHING ASSISTANTS SO THOSE ARE
ALL THINGS THAT. ONE ARE OUR
PRIORITIES THAT WE JUST SPENT.
YOUR SLIDESHOW TALKING ABOUT SO.
IF THIS DOESN'T GO THROUGH.
YOU KNOW WHERE IS A THIRTY
MILLION COME FROM I KNOW THAT
THE SOME OF THE REGION SAID THEY
WANT TO COME AND ASK FOR MORE
MONEY FROM THE LEGISLATURE WILL
TWO THINGS.
ONE THE MAY REVISED MAY NOT BE
AS ROSY WAS A THIS BUDGET PUT
EVERYTHING ON THE TABLE AS FAR
THE JACK THE JANUARY BUDGET SO
WE'RE NOT CERTAIN IF IT'S GOING
TO BE EXTRA MONEY IN MAY PLUS
THE ECONOMY ISN'T.
LIKE IT WAS LAST COUPLE YEARS
THAT BEING SAID IF THERE IS ANY
ADDITIONAL MONEY OUR PRIORITY IS
TO FOCUS ON ENROLLMENT GROWTH AS
WE TALKED ABOUT EARLIER THAT YOU
SEE.
ASKING FOR FORTY MILLION TO FUND
THE TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
ADDITIONAL CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
AND SO YOU KNOW THIS THIRTY
MILLION I WOULD LEAVE A HOLE.
FOR OTHER ISSUES THAT ARE
IMPORTANT TO TO CALIFORNIA SO.
I WANT TO KNOW THAT --
AND THEN I I ALSO WANT TO ASK AS
FAR AS THE THE UC'S PROJECTIONS
FOR OVERALL IN ENROLLMENT SO.
YOU KNOW WE WE KNOW WE'VE BEEN
TRYING REALLY HARD LAST YEAR'S
AND YOU SEE HAS STEPPED UP AND
IN ROLLED ABOUT FIFTEEN THOUSAND
NEW CALIFORNIANS IN THE LAST
ROUGHLY FIVE YEARS --
MAINLY WITH CALIFORNIA MONEY IN
THE BUDGET BUT THE UC HAS OVER
AND ROLLED.
HIS AND OF THE ENROLLMENTS NOT
NECESSARILY AT AT SCIENCE BUT
AND ART AT THIS THAT'S IT WOULD
YOU SAY --
HERE AND THERE.
BUT ON THE CHARTS.
THAT ON THE ARCH AGENDA ITEM
PAGE PAGE EIGHT FINE ART.
NOT NOT YOUR CHART OUR AGENDA
AND YEAH.
THE GOAL IS TO GROW BY TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED A YEAR.
THAT'S A WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT WITH.
THE PRESIDENT AND CHAIRMAN TING
AND I AND AND OTHERS AND THE FOR
THE FOUR YEAR GROWTH YOU HAVE
HERE.
IS IS.
THREE THOUSAND TOTAL OVER FOUR
YEARS SO.
HOW DOES THAT?
MATCH UPPER MORE POORLY IT
DOESN'T MATCH UP.
WE WENT TO GET TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED PER YEAR --
SO SERVE ONE OF THE THINGS
PULLING THIS --
TAKING THESE NUMBERS --
MAKING THEM LOOK A LITTLE
STRANGE IS A UC IRVINE WHICH IS
PROPOSING TO DECREASE ITS
ENROLLMENT THEY ARE SO SEVERELY
OVER AND ROLLED RIGHT NOW.
THAT THE STATES JUST CANNOT A
CALL GOING ON THEY HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO PROVIDE THEM WITH
CLASSES.
AND IT'S NOT --
IT'S NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR THEM TO
CONTINUE. TO TO HAVE THAT MUCH
ENROLLMENT SO THEY NEED TO DO
BUT EVEN IF YOU TOOK OUT THE
IRVINE I GET THAT GIVES STILL BE.
MUCH GREATER IF YOU DID TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED PER YEAR.
TIMES FOR YEARS.
YOU'RE CORRECT THAT WOULD BE
MORE --
WE'RE NOW SEEKING --
TO GROW OUR NUMBER OF DEGREES BY
CLOSING DEGREE GAPS --
AND POTENTIALLY BRINGING BACK
STUDENTS WHO PREVIOUSLY DROPPED
OUT WHO HAVE A HIGH NUMBER OF
UNITS WE CAN GET TO GRADUATE
WITH DEGREES SO WE WOULD STILL
HAVE GREATER DEGREE PRODUCTION.
BUT WE WOULD NOT NECESSARILY BE
GROWING OUR TOTAL ENROLLMENT.
AS MUCH AS BUT WE BUT WE WOULD
STILL GROW IT BY OVER THREE
HOUSE.
OKAY AND THEN LASTLY ON THAT THE
MARGINAL COST INCREASE.
THAT THE TRADITIONAL NUMBER
WE'VE.
WE'VE --
AGREED UPON AS TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN NET NON ESSAY AGREED
UPON THAT THAT WAS A STATE.
NUMBER BUT YOU SEE HAS
CONTINUALLY DISAGREED ON THAT
NUMBER IN THAT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE PUSHED BACK OVER THE
YEARS --
REALLY HARD SO WHEN ASKED APART --
COMMENTS ON THE REQUEST TO FIND
STUDENTS AT THE ELEVEN THOUSAND
AND SOME CHANGE OF ABOVE.
AND DOES THIS DOES THE
DOCUMENTATION WARRANT SUCH AN
AND AN INCREASE AND IF NOT WHY --
CHRIS FERGUSON WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I THINK
WE'RE STILL LOOKING AT THEIR
MARGINAL COST CALCULATION IT AND
HAS THAT METHODOLOGY REMAIN THE
SAME YEAR OVER YEAR OVER YEAR --
BUT CERTAINLY AT THIS TIME --
THE HIT THE PRACTICE THE THE
PAST FEW YEARS HAS CERTAINLY
BEEN TO A FUNDED ROMAN GROWTH AT
TEN THOUSAND PER ADDITIONAL
STUDENT.
I'M MORE HAPPY TO LOOK AT WHAT
YOU SEE IS PROVIDING --
AND CERTAINLY YOU KNOW WE WOULD
RETURN LATER --
YOU IF WE WERE TO PROPOSE
ENROLLMENT GROWTH WITH A AN
AMOUNT THAT IS SOMEWHERE --
EITHER --
RIGHT YOU ARE IF WE DISAGREE
WITH THE METHODOLOGY AT THAT TEN
THOUSAND DOLLAR RATE.
OKAY IT WOULD SEEM AT THE
MINIMUM THERE SHOULD IT SHOULD
BE A COLA.
A WEEK WE HAVEN'T HAD ANY OF
THAT SO YOU TO FOR DIDN'T AGREE
ON THAT THE HIGHER NUMBER SOME
TYPE OF A CALCULATION I KNOW.
THAT WE HAD WE'VE HAD THAT IN
OTHER.
EDUCATION --
MARKERS AS FAR AS THE MARGINAL
COSTS CORRECT YES CERTAINLY
HAPPY TO TO LOOK AT AT SOMETHING
LIKE --
APPLYING COLA --
CERTAINLY HAPPY TO LOOK AT THAT
AND WE HAVE GIVEN THE MARGINAL
COST COLIN CREASE FOR CSU OVER
THE YEARS CORRECT.
YET CSU HAS A VERY SPECIFIC
CALCULATION THAT LOOKS AT THE
COST OF INSTRUCTION --
AND THAT ACCOUNTS FOR AYE THOSE
COSTS HAS THEY'RE CHANGING OVER
TIME -- AND
IT'S IT'S BEEN A CONSISTENT
METHODOLOGY FROM CSU YEAR OVER
YEAR OVER.
OKAY THANK YOU DESERVE I JUST
HAVE A LOT MORE YAK BROWN ON THE
MARGINAL COST I MEAN I WE WE
STILL HAVE SOME QUESTIONS
ACTUALLY WAS.
LOOKING AT THE YEAR OVER YEAR
COMPARISON --
DID THIS MORNING AND I I HAVE
SOME COSTS ABOUT THE COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT THAT --
WE WOULD LIKE TO KNOW TOO IS
THAT THE MORE THE MARGINAL COST
WORKERS AS IF THERE'S A TOTAL
COST OF INSTRUCTION AND THEN
THERE'S A STATE AND A STUDENT
SHARE.
AND THE STUDENTS HERE DEPENDS ON
WHAT TO WHICH IT IS AND SO IF
TUITION.
DOESN'T INCREASE YEAR OVER YEAR
THAT THAT.
COST OVERALL COST INCREASES BORN
BY THE STATE'S SHARE AND SO IN
YOUR WERE TUITION IS INCREASING
THE THAT WAS STATE FOR WILL RISE
FASTER THAN THE TOTAL COST OF
THE TOTAL.
A MARGINAL COST AND SO THAT'S
PARTLY WHY YOU CO A LARGER SORT
OF INCREASE ON THE STAGE HERE
WHICH IS THAT 1-000-021-1000.
FIVE HUNDRED THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MURATSUCHI.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
I HAVE A QUESTION FOR A IS --
FOR VIRGIN YES YES --
FIRST AGO SOME PRELIMINARY
QUESTIONS OF THE DAY I I KNOW
THE MASTER PLAN --
CALLS FOR THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA TO DRAW FROM THE TOP
TWELVE POINT 5% OF CALIFORNIA
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES FOR
FRESHMAN ADMISSION.
HOW?
HOW ARE THOSE THE TWELVE POINT?
5% -- OF THE
GRADUATES IDENTIFIED I MEAN IS
IT STRICTLY GRADES AND AND GRADE
POINT AVERAGE OR OTHER ARE THERE
OTHER CONSIDERATIONS.
WILL IT WILL LOOK AT GRADES AND
GRADE POINT AVERAGE BUT WE ALSO
LOOK AT WE LOOK AT THESE THINGS
BY ZIP CODE SO --
IF IF THERE'S A LARGE NUMBER OF
WELL ACHIEVING HIGH SCHOOLS
WITHIN A PARTICULAR ZIP CODE.
THEY WOULD HAVE --
EVEN THOUGH THERE MAY BE WELL
ACHIEVING STUDENTS IN THAT.
IN THAT.
DISTRICT.
OF WE'RE LOOKING AT THE TWELVE
AND A HALF PERCENT WITHIN DOT
DISTRICT NOT STATE WIDE
NECESSARILY.
IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
UNIVERSE A CALIFORNIA ALSO HAS A
A POLICY OF ADMITTING THE TOP 9%
OF EVERY HIGH SCHOOL.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
THAT CORRECT.
THESE THESE QUESTIONS I HAVE --
I HAVE SOMEONE MISSIONS EXPERTS
HERE WHO OMIT THESE QUESTIONS
MAY BE.
THEY MAY BE ABLE TO ANSWER THESE
QUESTIONS MORE PRECISELY WOULD
YOU LIKE ME TO CALL THEM THE
TABLE.
VIA --
CHAIRS INDULGENCE JR
[inaudible]
YOU CAN.
I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE YOU TO OUR
SYSTEM WIDE PROVOST DOCTOR
MICHAEL BROWN.
SO YOUR QUESTION IS ABOUT THE
ELIGIBILITY IN A LOCAL CONTEXT
AND WE DO DEFINE PART OF OF THE
ELIGIBILITY POOL BASED ON RANK
IN THE LOCAL HIGH SCHOOL.
AND SO THE TOP 9% --
IS IS CONSIDERED AS PART OF
DEFINING THE ELIGIBILITY.
SO IT'S TAUGHT 9% OF EVERY
SINGLE HIGH SCHOOL IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA --
OF A REPUBLIC HI [inaudible]
YES.
EVERY PUBLIC HIGH SCHOOL IN IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND AND
AND SO HOW IS THAT RECONCILED
WITH THE MASTER PLAN --
GOAL OF THAT THE AT THE HIGHEST
TWELVE POINT 5% I SEEM TO TWELVE
HI IS TWELVE POINT 5% IS IS A
STATE WIDE.
YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE IN THE TOP
TWELVE POINT 5% STATE WIDE.
THEN.
IT'S A YEAR YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO
BE OR THE GOAL IS THAT YOU'RE
GUARANTEED A SPOT AT AT ONE OF
AT LEAST ONE OF THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA CAMPUS THAT'S
EXACTLY RIGHT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WE ARE WE ARE
TRYING AND A HALF PERCENT AS
BROADLY AS POSSIBLE BECAUSE THE
GOAL IS TO BROADLY REPRESENT
CALIFORNIANS IN THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND TO LOOK AT ALL OUR AND AS
BROADER RANGE OF ACHIEVEMENT
INDICATORS AS WE POSSIBLY CAN SO --
AND WE KNOW THAT GRADES AND TEST
SCORES ALONE.
I DO NOT DEFINE A PERSON'S MERIT
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA --
I DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
PERHAPS DISTINGUISH BETWEEN WHAT
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT AND HOW
BROADLY WERE LOOKING AT IT.
AND WHAT AND WHAT WE'RE ACTUALLY
AND NEGOTIATE WITH THE STATE TO
ENROLL AND THOSE ARE DIFFERENT
SO -- AND SO --
THAT -- THAT
TOP TWELVE AND A HALF PERCENT --
HOW MAY BE AN IMPORTANT GOAL FOR
THIS BODY --
BUT WE HAVE HEARD AND BELIEVE AT
THAT THIS BODY WANTS US TO LOOK
AS BROADLY ARE AT AT AT THE
EXCELLENCE THAT STUDENTS MAY
BRING.
AS POSSIBLE ARE AND THAT --
AND THAT ONCE WE DEFINE WHO IS
THE TOP --
THEN WE NEGOTIATE WITH THE STATE
THEY'RE SEPARATE ISSUES.
I MEAN I I I JUST ANY OF THAT
THE THE 9% GOAL OUT OF EVERY.
PUBLIC HIGH SCHOOL IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WAS --
A A REACTION TO PROPOSITION TWO
OR NINE TO TO TRY --
TO INSURER --
AT THAT DIVERSE COMMUNITIES --
A THAT --
STUDENTS FROM FROM ALL
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT SAID A
CALIFORNIA HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO IT.
IT'S IN THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IS THAT CORRECT --
HAVE I THINK IT WAS PART OF THE
MOTIVATOR OUR I THINK THE I AS
IS OFTEN THE CASE --
ARE BECAUSE WE ARE ALWAYS
LOOKING AT AND BY THE WAY I I
COME AT THIS FROM MANY MANY
ANGLES FOR YEARS ALSO CHAIRED
BY THE BOARD OF ADMISSIONS AND
RELATIONS ARM OF THE THE
UNIVERSITY OF THE FINE
[inaudible]
OUR GOAL IS --
TO TO REPRESENT AS BROADLY AS WE
POSSIBLY CAN.
PARTICULARLY GIVEN HOW SELECTIVE
THE UNIVERSITY IS HOW FEW SPACES
THERE ACTUALLY ARE GIVEN THE
DEMAND.
IS TO TO REPRESENT AS BROADLY AS
WE CAN --
THIS THIS STUDENTS OF OUR STATE
AND TO LOOK AT AS MANY OF THE OF
THE FACTORS THAT WOULD DEFINE
THAT EXCELLENCE AS WE POSSIBLY
CAN ONE OF THE BEST PREDICTORS
OF A STUDENT'S PERFORMANCE AT
THE UNIVERSITY.
IS ACTUALLY THEIR GPA AND AND
ACTUALLY AMONG THE BEST
PREDICTORS IS HOW A STUDENT
RANKS IN THEIR GPA.
AND THEIR LOCAL HIGH SCHOOL THE
REASON WHY THE LOCAL HIGH SCHOOL
IS EXAMINED IS BECAUSE THAT'S
THE EDUCATIONAL ACHIEVEMENT
CONTEXT IN WHICH STUDENTS ARE
PERFORMING.
AND IT IS REASONABLE --
TO LOOK AT HOW STUDENTS ARE
FARING IN THEIR LOCAL CONTEXT --
AGAINST THAT PARTICULAR CRITERIA
SO I MEAN DO WITH THE THE REASON
WHY I'M ASKING THESE QUESTIONS
IS BECAUSE YOU KNOW I A FOR
EXAMPLE I I WHICH IS.
IT HAD A TALKING TO A A
ACCORDING TO THE STUDENT TO HE
HE SCORED.
TO IN A TWENTY TWO HUNDRED ON
THE ON THE OLD SAT BUT WAS NOT
ABLE TO GAIN ADMISSION TO A
SINGLE.
UNIVERSE A CALIFORNIA CAMPUS ARE
I I DON'T KNOW IF HE IF HE
APPLIED. TO TO BE LESS IMPACTED
CAMPUSES MAY MAYBE HE TO SUPPLY.
TO TO TO THE IMPACT OF CAMPUSES
BUT YOU KNOW JUST ANECDOTALLY I
I HEAR SO MANY STORIES LIKE THIS --
IS SO THAT YOU KNOW WAIT WAIT
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO A YOU KNOW
STUDENTS FROM A A HIGH ACHIEVING
HIGH SCHOOL YOU KNOW.
IF IF THEY'RE YOU KNOW CONCERNED
THAT THERE ARE THERE ARE.
IN A THEIR IT'S HARDER TO GET
INTO THE UC CAMPUS OF THE CHOICE
AT A HIGH ACHIEVING HIGH SCHOOL
VERSES AT EIGHT LOWER ACHIEVING
HIGH SCHOOL.
I I HAD AS AN EXCELLENT QUESTION
I THINK ALL OF US ARE ACTUALLY
VERY CONCERNED --
ARE OUT I WAS JUST TALKING WHO
ARE BROUGHT WITH ME HAN ME YOU
MOVE.
AND FOR IT --
AND AND WHAT WE FIND IS WE HAVE
A TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THOUSAND APPLICATIONS.
OF FROM CALIFORNIA IS THE FROM
FROM CALIFORNIA STUDENTS TO
APPLY FOR ADMISSION AND TO USE
THE BEST TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THOUSAND AND AND MOST CAMPUSES
ARE MADE IN BETWEEN FOUR AND
FIVE THOUSAND LOOKING TO ENROLL.
BETWEEN FOUR AND FIVE THOUSAND
STUDENTS PER CAMPUS THAT'S NINE
CAMPUSES WHAT WE REALLY NEED ARE
MORE YOU SEE QUALITY SEATS.
OF AVAILABLE --
AND HI AND SOME OF OUR CAMPUSES --
THERE'S ACTUALLY PHYSICAL
LIMITATIONS IN TERMS OF THEIR
ABILITY TO GROW.
AND SO IF WE CAN ADDRESS THAT --
HI AND IF THE STATE WAS
COMFORTABLE WITH WITH ENROLLING
MORE STUDENTS --
AND I HAVE HEARD THAT AS A AS A
PARTICULAR AIM OF THIS BODY --
ODD THEN THEN THEN WE QUE --
BUT IT'S IT'S CREATING THOSE NEW
SEATS IT'S FUNDING THOSE NEW
SEATS --
ENABLING SOME OF OUR CAMPUSES TO
GROW THAT CAPACITY.
UNDERSTAND THAT ON SOME OF OUR
CAMPUSES THERE'S ACTUALLY.
THERE'S AN IMPOSSIBILITY TO GROW
ACTUALLY MORE SICK OKAY I MADE
IT I YEAH I I DON'T WANT TO
BELABOR THE POINT BUT THE I..
DOES THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
HAVE LIKE DATA ON WHO.
YOU KNOW QUALIFIES AMONG THE TOP
9% AT EVERY HIGH SCHOOL
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY.
AND AND DOES THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA HAVE DATA ON ON WHO
QUALIFIES WITHIN THE TOP TWELVE
WHAT. TWELVE POINT 5% STATE WHAT
WOULD WE HAVE THAT TOO WE DO WE
DETERMINE ELIGIBILITY OURSELVES --
SO IN THE E. L. C. PROCESS AS I
REMEMBER IT --
THE THE SCHOOL SUBMIT THE
CREDENTIALS OF THEIR STUDENTS --
ON THE EIGHT AT G. REQUIRED
COURSES THAT --
YOU SEE AND SEE ISSUE REQUIRE --
WE ACTUALLY PERFORMED THAT
RANKING OURSELVES --
TO ASSURE OURSELVES OF THE
INTEGRITY OF THAT PROCESS AND
THAT IT'S THAT THIS EQUIVALENTLY
APPLIED DROUGHT --
THROUGHOUT THAT THAT RANKING
PROCESS SO YOU HAVE RANKINGS --
BITE BY STUDENT NAME --
WHETHER THEY FALL WITHIN.
THE AT THE THE THE ADMISSION BAD
WITH.
THAT THAT EXIST SWORDS
DETERMINABLE WE ACTUALLY ALSO
FOR THOSE STUDENTS WHO ARE CLOSE
COULD REMEMBER THAT'S DONE IN
THEIR JUNIOR YEAR FOR STUDENTS
THAT ARE CLOSE --
I I BELIEVE IT'S PART OF THE
PRESIDENT'S --
PROCESS FACTUALLY SEND OUT A
LETTER THAT TO THOSE STUDENTS
THAT LOOK AT THAT THAT SIGNAL SO
THAT STUDENT YOU'RE PROJECTING --
ELIGIBILITY KEEP UP THE GOOD
WORK YOU COULD CONTINUE YOUR
PROGRESS AND AND YOU MAY END UP --
WE ACTUALLY USE THAT PROCESS AS
AN OUT REACH TOOL AS WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER TING.
I'M GOING TO FOLLOW UP ON MY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM --
DELAYS ARE.
QUESTIONS TO COULD COULD YOU GO
BACK TO PAGE ELEVEN OF YOUR
POWER POINT PRESENTATION.
AND THEN YOU HAVE THE WRONG
NUMBERS [inaudible]
BEHIND THAT.
I'M NOT IN FRONT OF ME BUT I CAN
PROVIDE THEM TO YOU DOES ANYBODY
HAVE AFFORDABLE.
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF YOU SEE IT
PEOPLE HERE.
ARE YOU LOOKING FOR NON RESIDENT
AS WELL I DON'T HAVE THE POWER
YES AND I WANT I WANT TO KNOW
THE NUMBERS BEHIND THE
PERCENTAGES.
I'M SORRY I I WE HAVE THE DATA
TO BUT NOT IN FRONT OF ME WE
HAVE THAT RESIDENTS BUT NOT THE
NON RESIDENTS --
SOME JUST GONNA KIND OF DULL
DOVE TAIL AND I THINK ONE OF THE
ONE OF OUR CONCERNS STEMMING
FROM THE SUBCOMMITTEE IN IN
MISTER MERCE CHEN I STARTED ON
THE SUBCOMMITTEE BOTH.
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN AND THIS IS
BEEN AN ONGOING ISSUE AND AS YOU
CAN SEE FROM THIRTEEN TWENTY
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN TO TODAY.
THE NON RESIDENT ROMA CONTINUES
TO SKYROCKET WHILE --
THIS COMMITTEE HAS BEEN THE
FRANKLY THE ONLY COMMITTEE
REALLY CHAMPIONING THE VERY
SMALL INCREMENTAL GROWTH IN IN
STATE ENROLLMENT SO I GUESS THE
CONCERN IS THAT THERE SEEMS TO
BE --
UNLIMITED ROOM FOR NON RESIDENTS --
INKED INCLUDING THIS YEAR WHERE
YOU HAD OVER IN ROME AND A
NUMBER OF CAMPUSES FOR NON
RESIDENTS YET.
AGAIN THE THE PEOPLE SEEM --
TO CONTINUE TO BE SORT OF CAPPED
AT A LIMIT SO I WONDER IF YOU
COULD COMMENT ON THAT AND HOW
YOU CAN ADDRESS.
THIS -- HOW
HOW HOW DOES THE THE UNIVERSITY
PLAN ON?
REALLY --
STOP BEING EACH CAMPUSES
INSATIABLE THIRST FOR NON
RESIDENT STUDENTS AT THE EXPENSE
OF CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
OF WELL SIR --
OUR BOARD OF REGENTS HAS ADOPTED
A POLICY TO CAP EACH OF THE
CAMPUS'S ON THEIR NON RESIDENT
INVOLVEMENT --
ALL OF OUR UNDERGRADUATE
CAMPUSES THEY DID NOT A BY BY
THIS AT THIS YEAR --
ADMITTING STUDENTS IS A VERY.
IT'S A VERY UP IMPRECISE PROCESS
IN SOME WAYS WE SET OUR RESIDENT
AND NON RESIDENT TARGET
SEPARATELY SO WE SET THE NUMBER
OF NON.
RESIDENTS THAT --
ARE UNDER THE CAP THAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO ADMIT TO SEPARATELY
FROM THE RESIDENT NUMBER SO --
THE AS THE THE CAMPUS IS KNOW
THAT THEY'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO
EXCEED DODD AND THE PRESIDENT
HAS TAKEN ACTION TO REMOVE ANY
POTENTIAL PROFIT FROM THOSE
CAMPUSES THAT EXCEEDED THE CAP.
I'M PROVIDED US BASIC NEEDS
SERVICES STAR NEEDIEST
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT STUDENTS I
DO HAVE THE LARGEST.
NUMBER OF THE YOU DO HAVE THE
NUMBER OF I FOUND THEM SO FOR
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE HEAD COUNT
WAS A CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
UNDERGRADUATES WITH
800-820-00700.
THIRTY THREE AND NON RESIDENT
UNDERGRAD.
SIXTY AND I DO WANT TO POINT OUT
I WENT OVER THERE NO WAY TO KNOW.
NINE I DON'T HAVE THAT I HAVE
TWENTY TEN SORRY MAJOR ONES
AREN'T ANY TEN TWENTY TEN WAS
ARE CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS WERE
HUNDRED AND 680-006-0020.
TWO AND TOTAL NON RESIDENTS WERE.
TEN THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED TWENTY
THREE TEN THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE HEAD COUNT SO YOU
ADDED --
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND NON
RESIDENTS AT THE TIME AND IT
LOOKS LIKE --
ABOUT FOURTEEN THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS.
THAT WHENEVER I'M HERE SIR
THAT'S CORRECT.
I THINK THERE THERE'S YOUR
ANSWER MR MERCER.
I WILL I WILL POINT OUT THAT WE
CURRENTLY GOV ONE POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS IN REVENUE FROM
THESE NON AND WE'LL WE'LL WEEK
FULLY UNDERSTAND THE REASON THAT
YOU'RE DOING THIS FOR THE MONEY
SO IT'S NOT THAT'S THAT'S BEEN
VERY CLEAR IN ALL THE TESTIMONY.
HELLO THIS IS.
YOU YOU WOULDN'T SAY THAT REALLY.
I'VE GOT THAT'S THAT'S SO YOU'RE
YOU'RE COUNTERING WHAT EVERY
EVERYBODY ELSE AS WHEN THEY COME
HERE SO.
PLEASE THE LIMóN.
WE ARE SAFE FROM AN FROM AN
ACADEMIC POINT OF VIEW --
THE VALUE OF INTERNATIONAL
STUDENTS IS NOT JUST FOR THE
MONEY SO THEN LET ME PUSH BACK
ON THAT BECAUSE IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT WHEN WHEN WAS THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA FOUND.
AT EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIFTY SIXTY SO
FOR THE FIRST. HUNDRED FIFTY
YEARS OF EXISTENCE.
BY PERCENT WAS ABOUT WHAT IT WAS
SO.
SO AFTER A HUNDRED FIFTY YEARS
UNIVERSES CITED THERE IS VALUE
INTERNATIONAL STUDENTS.
I OUR OUR HI I I UNDERSTAND YOUR
YOUR RATIONALE IN LOGIC DOES NOT
IT'S NOT RATIONALE IS JUST IT'S
IT'S JUST BEING HONEST RIGHT SO.
THE UNIVERSITY FOUND VALUE
INTERNATIONAL STUDENTS WHEN THEY
COULD GO.
RECOUP MONEY FROM.
SO THERE WASN'T VALUE FOR THE
FIRST HUNDRED FIFTY YEARS.
WHEN I WAS WHEN I WAS AT
BERKELEY WHICH WAS WASN'T THAT
LONG AGO BUT WAS AWHILE AGO?
IT'S 5%.
YEAH THAT TRADITIONALLY HAVE
BEEN THE NUMBER FOR NOT JUST
INTERNATIONAL BUT OUT OF STATE
AS WELL AS THE MEMBER TING AYE I
THINK.
IT IS TRUE.
THAT THERE IS OUR ECONOMIC VALUE
I'M NOT DENYING THAT I'M SAYING
THAT'S NOT THE ONLY REASON WHY
I'M NOT DISSING THAT'S THE BY
FAR THE PRIMARY REASON.
SO I THINK WHAT YOU SAY SOUNDS
NICE RHETORICALLY.
EARLY THAT IT DOESN'T JIVE WITH
THE HISTORY OF THE UNIVERSITY.
AND IT DOESN'T JIVE THAT ALL OF
A SUDDEN ACADEMICALLY THERE WAS
THIS -- LES
PAUL THAT WENT ON THAT --
WHILE WE REALLY NEED TO BECOME
MORE INTERNATIONAL.
I I I I APPRECIATE THAT YOU
DON'T NEED TO HELP OKAY.
YOU KNOW THE WHAT WHAT WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS ON WE
HEARD A RATIONALE.
WE DON'T BUY IT.
IT SOUNDS LIKE.
GET -- IF IF
IF THE END THE AMOUNT OF MONEY.
THAT YOU COULD GET FROM
INTERNATIONAL STUDENTS WENT DOWN.
I WOULD I BELIEVE THAT YOU WOULD
NOT FIND AS MUCH VALUE FROM THE
I'LL JUST BE FRANK.
SO THE QUESTION AGAIN IS I GO
MISTER MCCARTY AND I NEGOTIATED
THAT DEAL TO CAP IT 18% IN THE
HOPE WAS REALLY.
THAT WE WOULD SEE A FLAT OF OUT
OF STATE INTERNATIONAL STUDENTS.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY IT APPEARS
THAT NOT ONLY HAS A NOT FLAT IT
CONTINUES TO RISE.
SO I THINK IT MADE THIS YEAR WE
MAY HAVE TO GO BACK AND RE
REVIEW WHETHER THAT 18% IS A
JACK NUMBER OR NOT.
SIR MOST OF OUR CAMPUSES HAVE
STAYED BELOW THAT CAPITAL BY BUS
TICKET DEALS ON RESIDENTS IS
SLOWING DEFINITELY SLOWING DOWN.
I ALSO DO WANT --
TO OFFERED THAT THE REASON THE
NON RESIDENT ENROLLMENT
INCREASED SO DRAMATICALLY WAS DE.
UNPRECEDENTED ECONOMIC CRISIS
THE STATE FACED --
BACK WHERE WE WENT BACK WHEN YOU
WERE AN UNDERGRADUATE AT UC
BERKELEY AND IT WAS RANKED THIRD
IN THE WORLD.
NOT AMONG PUBLIX BUT AMONG ALL
UNIVERSITIES THE STATE WAS
FUNDING 70% OF THE INSTRUCTIONAL
COSTS THERE.
NOW THE STATE FUNDS 40% AND
BERKELEY'S RANKING BUT FIFTEENTH.
OF WHAT ARE SOME OF THE PUBLIC'S
NO WE'RE NOT ARGUING WHETHER OR
NOT FIND IT LIKE AGAIN.
WE LOOK --
IN A PROPOSED BROWN.
IS GIVING.
AN AN ARGUMENT THAT TO ME IN
BUDGET COMMITTEE WHY THE REASON
THIS IS A CAR.
AND SO WE DON'T DISAGREE WITH
YOU.
WE TOTALLY AGREE WITH YOU IN
FACT YOU LEAD WITH WE GET ONE
POINT SOMETHING BILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE INTERNATIONAL STUDENTS
TO WASN'T HEY.
WE'RE GETTING OUR RANKINGS
HIGHER BECAUSE INTERNATIONAL
STUDENTS SHE DID SAY THAT DISH
[inaudible]
SO AGAIN.
WE NEGOTIATE THIS AGREEMENT THE
HOPE WAS THAT THERE WOULD BE A
FLATTENING OF OUT OF STATE
INTERNATIONAL STUDENTS SO THAT
CONSTITUENTS FIRM MISTER MERCER
CHEESE HIGH SCHOOL COULD.
GET THERE --
TO YOU SEE.
BECAUSE THAT GOES WITH THE SLOTS
THAT THOSE SLOTS ARE BEING TAKEN
UP.
SO IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE MAY
HAVE TO RE DISCUSS GOING IN TO
THIS YEAR BECAUSE THE HOPE WAS
THAT HE WAS GOING.
TO FLATTEN BUT THE FACT THAT IT
KEEPS GOING UP IS VERY TROUBLING.
MURATSUCHI YES THANK IF I JUST
QUICKLY FOLLOW UP ON THAT --
MADE.
OF ALONG THE SAME LINES IS --
CHAIRMAN KINGS --
GUIDE COMMENTS ME LOOKING AT THE
THE SLIDE ON PAGE.
ELEVEN I MEAN I I I KNOW WE WE
CAN SPEAK FROM --
FOR FROM OUR PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
THAT -- FROM.
201-322-22018 WELL THAT'S THE
FOR NINETEEN BUDGETS --
WE HAVE INCREASED --
STATE GENERAL FUNDING FOR A OF
FOR THE UC'S AND YET THE
PERCENTAGE OF THE NON RESIDENTS
COULDN'T HAVE CONTINUED TO GROW.
SO THAT.
SEEMS TO UNDERMINE YOUR ARGUMENT
LIKE THE ARGUMENT THAT'S THAT'S
THAT WE HEAR MOST --
OFTEN THAT.
THAT YOU'RE HAVING TO ADMIT MORE
NON RESIDENT STUDENTS BECAUSE
THE STATE --
IS IS IS IS --
IN THE STATE CONTRIBUTION TO
YOUR CORE FUNDS ARE DECLINING.
COULD YOU RESPOND TO THAT.
DURING DURING THE BUDGET CRISIS --
AND I I TALK ABOUT FOR TWENTY
THIRTEEN ON YES WE LOST SO MUCH
MONEY THAT WE'VE BEEN BUT ALSO
WHEN WE HAD TO LAY OFF A LOT OF
PEOPLE AND NOW WE'RE SER
CATCHING UP AND IS FUNDS ARE
REQUIRED FOR THAT.
AND AND AND AND OUR TOTAL
ENROLLMENT KEEPS GROWING SO THE
NUMBERS THE HEAD COUNT OF
RESIDENTS HAS BEEN AND THE F. T.
OF RESIDENTS HAS BEEN GROWING
DURING THAT TIME.
SO WE ARE LEADING IN. FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
YEAH YOU KNOW I I I I I KNOW
THAT'S THE THE THE ARGUMENT THAT
THAT WE THAT THE ALWAYS MAKE.
REGISTER AYE AYE AYE BUT
SPEAKING FOR MYSELF PERSONALLY I
I HAVE A HARD TIME TRYING.
TO KEEP TRACK I FEEL LIKE YOU
KNOW THIS IS.
YOU KNOW THERE THERE ARE THERE
ARE SO MANY MOVING PIECES HERE
THAT -- THAT --
YOU KNOW WERE E. A. B. WE ALWAYS
COME BACK TO THAT ARGUMENT THAT
THAT OF THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA MAKES THAT.
THAT YOU'RE HAVING TO ADMIT MORE
OUT OF STATES TO BEING YOU
ENOUGH MONEY AND SO THEREFORE
IT'S SOMEHOW IT'S OUR FAULT.
YOU KNOW --
YOU KNOW WITH IT Y. WE'RE NOT
ADMITTING --
TO MORE MORE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS --
YOU KNOW I I APPRECIATE TO THE
PROVOST'S ARGUMENT ABOUT THE OF
THE VALUE OF DIVERSITY IN THE
VALUE OF OUT OF STATE STUDENTS
IN THE VALUE OF OF OF
INTERNATIONAL STUDENTS.
BUT BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS WE
YOU KNOW ALL OF US HERE ARE
ELECTED BY.
THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND AND AND AND I YOU
KNOW I I THINK WE'VE TRIED TO
MAKE IT AS CLEAR AS WE POSSIBLY
CAN.
THAT YOU KNOW [inaudible]
I I YOU KNOW IT I I BELIEVE ALL
OF US HERE.
YOU KNOW.
ICE MORE VALUE ON CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTSTHAN WE DO ON THE
BENEFITS OF DIVERSITY OF OUT OF
STATE IN INTERNATIONAL STUDENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU.
OKAY FOLLOW UP FOR MR TING AND
THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMóN AND
THEY WANT TO GET TO THE NEXT
ISSUE ITEMS SO WHAT FUNDING
LEVEL WOULD.
WHAT FUNDING LEVEL WHAT IT TAKES?
TO ON FLATTEN NON RESIDENT
STUDENT ENROLLMENT --
I'VE NEVER SEEN THAT ONE I'LL
HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT
BECAUSE WILL HAVE TO ACCOUNT FOR
FUTURE YEAR INFLATION SET LOOK
IN THE INTERJECT LAST YEAR IN
OUR FINAL BUDGET WE PUT LANGUAGE
IN THE BUDGET.
ASKING US TO GO DOWN 210%.
WHICH WOULD.
BE I AM OPTIMISTIC BUT ONE THAT
WE THINK WE WOULD EMBRACE AND I
THINK IN THAT WE ASK FOR AN
APRIL ONE REPORT FROM THE UC TO
US AND SO IS HIGHER THAN THAT
IT IS NOW OKAY ARE COMING IN THE
LAST STAGES OF REVIEW I BELIEVE
SO.
SOCIAL WHAT VERY WIDE MY CONCERN
REGARDING THE OUT OF STATE
EMPLOYMENT ALSO IS.
THAT THERE'S REALLY NO INCENTIVE
PUT IN PLACE FOR ANY OF THE
CAMPUSES TO REDUCE ANY OF THE
OUT OF STATE A WOMAN BECAUSE
IT'S FRANKLY ONE OF THE ONLY
DISCRETIONARY POTS OF MONEY THAT
THE CHANCELLOR HAS AT THEIR
CAMPUS.
IF I WITH PARTICULAR CHANCELLOR.
DISCRETIONARY MONEY AS WE ALL
KNOW IS INVALUABLE.
SO I WOULD BE CURIOUS AS TO WHAT
POLICIES THE REGENTS OR THE
OFFICE PRESENT ARE PUT IN PLACE
TO CREATE --
OF INCENTIVES TO MOVE TOWARD IN
STATE AND WALNUT OR
DISINCENTIVES.
TO CONTINUE TO BE RELIANT ON OUT
OF STATE AND ROMAN.
JUST A LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND
FOR THAT --
CURRENTLY THE WAY THE STATE
FUNDS GET DISTRIBUTED IT IS AN
EQUAL AMOUNT FOR EACH CAMPUS
REGARDLESS OF COST OF LIVING OR
ANYTHING ON THOSE.
THAT THEY GET PER STUDENT IN
STATE FUNDING THAT CAME ABOUT AS
A RESULT OF I BELIEVE A TWENTY
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT STATE AUDITOR
REPORT TO CRITICIZE YOU SEE FOR
GIVING DIFFERENTIAL DOLLARS PER
STUDENT AT OUR CAMPUSES.
SO NOW THE STATE FUNDS ARE
PROVIDED ACROSS THE BOARD
EQUALLY EVERYTHING.
THE SO SO BERKELEY SAN DIEGO
UCLA THE THREE MOST DESIRABLE
CAMPUSES IT MADE THE MOST OUT OF
STATE STUDENTS.
SO THEY HAVE THE HIGHEST
INCENTIVE. TO MAINTAIN THAT
LEVEL OF ENROLLMENT.
THAT IS THAT TRUE.
THEY ALSO HAVE SOME OF THIS
HIGHEST COSTS SO A FACULTY
MEMBER --
THE FACULTY THE SOME OF THE FACT
THAT WE WANT TO LOOK REPORT
COSTS BY JUST SAYING SO.
SO THOSE ARE THE THREE MOST
DESIRABLE CAMPUSES.
THE TAKING THAT THE HIGHEST
PERCENTAGE OF OUT OF STATE
ENROLLMENT I THINK BELIEVE
22224% -- IS
SO THAT IS IN DIRECT COMPETITION
TO CALIFORNIA STUDENTS WERE
TRYING TO GET INTO THE THREE
MOST DESIRABLE.
CAMPUS AS WELL BECAUSE EACH
CAMPUS MAKES A LITTLE BIT OF
EXTRA MONEY FROM THE NON
RESIDENT THEY CAN USE THOSE
FUNDS TO ACTUALLY HIGHER
LECTURERS OR FACULTY TO TEACH
RESIDENTS STUDENTS AND IF WE
LOST THAT ADDITIONAL REVENUE.
WE WOULD ACTUALLY HAVE TO REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF COURSES AND
SERVICES PROVIDED THE RESIDENT
STUDENTS SO IT'S A BIT OF A
TANGLED ISSUE.
IN THAT IT'S NOT JUST A MATTER
OF THERE'S A PERSON SITTING IN A
CHAIR BUT THAT PERSON IS
ACTUALLY FINANCING DEAL ABILITY
I DON'T.
COMPLICATED ISSUE AS YOU MAKE A
SOUND I THINK IT REALLY COMES
DOWN.
TO YOU KNOW AYE CHANCELLOR NEEDS
TO BALANCE THEIR BUDGET AND THIS
IS THIS IS THE WAY THEY BALLOTS
I THINK THAT'S WHAT IT COMES
DOWN TO SO I THINK A BALANCE IT.
ANOTHER WAY THAT MAYBE THEY
WOULD CONSIDER AT THAT THIS OUR
OUR UNIVERSITIES HAVE VERY.
VERY FEW LEVERS FOR FUNDING
GREAT EXAMPLE YEAH.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER LIMA
THANK YOU I I APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION AND I THINK THAT THIS
IS ACTUALLY HIGHLIGHTING ONE OF
THE GREATER COMPLEXITIES --
OF THIS I MEAN IN THIS IN THIS
LAST I THINK TWENTY MINUTES OF
DISCUSSION --
BETWEEN --
THE MEMBERS AND YOU SEE
REPRESENTATIVES.
YOU KNOW.
I I'VE HEARD THAT TO SOME EXTENT
SOME OF THE OBJECTIVES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAD WERE MET --
WHICH WAS TO INCREASE TO ADD IS
THAT IN STATE --
STUDENT ENROLLMENT THAT THAT'S
AN OBJECTIVE THAT HAS BEEN MET
THAT IS A PRIORITY TO US --
I KNOW THAT ONE OF THE
OBJECTIVES WE'VE HAD --
HAS ALSO BEEN.
TO KEEP AND MAINTAIN THE COST OF
TUITION FROM GOING UP AND THAT
HAS BEEN MET --
AND YOU KNOW I I STRUGGLE WITH
WHAT THE RIGHT IS.
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK THAT THERE
IS ANY AS AS AN ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SUIT SHE SAID THERE THERE IS ANY
DEBATE ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE THAT
LEGISLATORS PLACE ON ALLOWING.
ACCESS. TO ONE OF OUR PRIME
TREASURES THE UC'S FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS THAT IS
UNQUESTIONABLE I DON'T THINK
THAT THAT'S DEBATED I STRUGGLE
WITH REFLECTING ON WHAT A
DISINVESTMENT LOOKS LIKE FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS --
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
MAGIC NUMBER IS I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE BALANCE IS I MEAN THE
QUESTION WAS POSED IF WE GAVE X.
AMOUNT OF MONEY I MEAN
ESSENTIALLY.
RIGHT THEN DOES THAT.
DECREASE OR DOES THAT STOP OUT
OF STATE IN ROME IT FROM GOING
UP -- BUT
THE TRUTH IS IS THAT.
WHEN THERE IS AN OVERALL BUDGET?
I AT LEAST THE WAY THAT I SAW IT
WORK OUT IT DIDN'T SAY IT WILL
THIS IS HOW MUCH OUT OF STATE
STUDENTS ARE BRINGING IN AND
THIS IS HOW MUCH STAYS FOR OUT
OF STATE.
THIS IS HOW MUCH MONEY ALL COMES
IN AND HELPS EVERYONE A LOT OF
THE STUDENT SUPPORT SERVICES
DON'T MAKE.
DON'T DISTINGUISH BY WHETHER
YOU'RE AT THERE'S AN OFFICE OF
INTERNATIONAL STUDENTS BUT
OUTSIDE OF THAT IF YOU GO TO
DISABLE STUDENT SERVICES IF YOU
IDENTIFY WITH AN ETHNIC GROUP
AND YOU GO TO THAT YOU KNOW
CULTURAL CENTERS --
IF YOU GO TO CHIU DURING IF YOU
GO TO ANY OF THIS THAT SAME POT
OF MONEY IS HELPING ALL STUDENTS.
AND I STRUGGLE WITH THIS I DO --
BECAUSE I A THINK THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE AS LEGISLATORS TO
REPRESENT --
THE COMMUNITIES THAT WE SERVE
AND WE'RE GOING TO BE THE
LOUDEST VOICES FOR THOSE
COMMUNITIES WRIST RESEARCH.
I ALSO CAUTION AS TO GET.
TO BE CAREFUL ON HOW MUCH WE
WANT TO OPEN UP.
THE CONVERSATION ABOUT THE VALUE
OF DIVERSITY BECAUSE AS SOMEONE
WHO HAS HELP FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS --
LOW INCOME STUDENTS STUDENTS
FROM ETHNICALLY UNDER
REPRESENTED BACKGROUNDS I CAN
TELL YOU THAT OUR SAME COMMENT
THAT COME OUT OF OUR MOUTH FOR
INTERNATIONAL STUDENTS ARE THE
SAME COMMENTS THAT WILL BE USED.
BY SOMETIMES OUR CONSTITUENTS TO
MAKE THE CASE AGAINST FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS STUDENTS WHO
APPLY FOR AT STUDENTS WHO.
ARE.
BENEFITING FROM US.
FROM A CAL GRANDSON CERTAINLY
FOR A DREAMER STUDENTS AND WE
GOT AND IT'S CARE I MEAN I JUST
WE HAVE TO BE CAREFUL --
THAT THERE IS A VALUE TO DAY FOR
STUDENTS --
AND IT YOU KNOW I I THINK IT'S
AN IMPORTANT VALUE THAT WE HAVE
STATED OUR BUDGET HAS STATED IT
SO I HOPE THAT WE CAN FIND THE
RIGHT FORMULA --
TO INSURE THAT OUR OBJECTIVES
CONTINUE TO GET MATT AS A STATE --
BUT I CERTAINLY THINK THAT
THERE'S BEEN QUESTIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN POSED BY.
STATE REPRESENTATIVES IN THIS
ROOM TODAY THAT NEED TO BE
FLESHED OUT.
WE HAVE TO GO BACK AND DELIVER
THIS MESS DELIVER THIS MESSAGE
THEN YOU KNOW YOU HERE BECAUSE
THAT IS OUR JOB TO TALK TO THE
PUBLIC TO EXPLAIN TO THEM WHAT
OUR POLICIES ARE.
AND SO IF THERE'S NOT CONFIDENCE
ON OUR PART --
WE CAN'T PROJECT THAT CONFIDENCE
TO OUR CONSTITUENTS AND IN THE
END I'VE SAID IT OVER AND OVER
THIS IS ABOUT THE FACT THAT THIS
IS AN UNBELIEVABLY VALUED
RESOURCE THAT THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
OF AND THAT I THINK IS AT THE
ROOT OF THE PROBLEM.
YES.
OKAY THANK YOU SO I'LL TRY TO
WRAP THIS UP HERE SO CLEARLY.
THIS IS THE ISSUE THAT WE WANT
TO SERVE ON THE SUBCOMMITTEE
ABOUT TALKING ABOUT YEARS
CALIFORNIA'S ACCESS FOR
CALIFORNIANS AND I'M MORE AND
MORE STUDENTS ARE.
ARE TAKING THE COURSES AND
ELIGIBLE IN APPLYING HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
APPLICATIONS IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN.
AND NOT ENOUGH FOR GETTING AND
SO IT'S SUPPLY DEMAND ONE ON ONE
AND WE'RE GOING TO FIGHT TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER DID.
SLOTS FOR CALIFORNIANS BUT THIS
THE NON RESIN ISSUE IS SOMETHING
THAT'S NOT GOING AWAY AND AND I
TOTALLY CONCUR WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER --
TEAM JUST ON THE MATHEMATICS
THAT'S THAT'S WHY WE DID THE
POLICY.
YOU KNOW I I THINK HE CAN
YOURSELF AND AND BEING DISHONEST
TO TELL US THAT.
YOU KNOW FOR A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
YEARS ACTUALLY WERE FINE WITH
MINUS 5% AND THEN ALL OF A
SUDDEN --
WHEN THAT THE BUDGET WAS REALLY
BECAUSE WE NEEDED TO TO KEEP THE
LIGHTS ON I DON'T I DON'T BLAME
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA THE
THREE POTS OF MONEY?
STUDENT FEES STATE MONEY AND NON
RESIDENT TUITION YOU CAN LOOK AT
YOUR PIE CHART THEY'RE ALL THERE
AND SO IT'S A THREE LEGGED STOOL
SO NOW IT IS PART OF THE STILL
FOR THE RIP ONE OUT.
RASPY MONEY COMING SOMEWHERE
ELSE AND SO IT'S GOING TO BE
SEATED CALIFORNIA MONEY.
FINE WHERE WE CAN TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT BUT I REALIZE WE HAVE OTHER.
ISSUES AS WELL --
STUDENT FEET REVENUE --
YOU KNOW I KNOW WEEK PATTERSON
SOMETIMES AS A COST AS WELL AS
OVER. 50% NEARLY TWO THIRDS GET
FINANCIAL AID PAY NO FEES THAT
YOU SEE WITH CAL GRANT.
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP AND AND
UNIVERSITY GRANT [inaudible]
AND WITH THAT WE DON'T HAVE AS
MUCH MONEY TO EXPAND NONRESIDENT
ROMANTIC --
SO.
IT'S CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT --
HIS IS ON OUR ON OUR MINDS GOING
FORWARD SO --
WITH THAT WE WENT --
TO HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN AND
REVISIT IT --
FOR THE VISION AND MAYBE WE CAN
EXCUSE THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
LA GO AND ASK THE UC PANEL TO
COME UP HERE.
WE'RE GOING TO IT NOW TALK ABOUT
THIS ISSUE RELATES TO THE
COLLEGE ADMISSIONS CHEATING
SCANDAL.
AND AS THE AS THE I'LL WAIT TILL
THE GROUP COMES UP.
SO I I DECIDED TO AGENDA IS THIS
WE DECIDE TO AGENDA IS THIS YOU
KNOW WE THOUGHT THAT IT WOULD BE
VERY AWKWARD TO TALK ABOUT THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA.
AND EMISSIONS WOULD NOT --
ADDRESSING BEEN IN THE ROOM AND
THAT IS THIS --
RECENT THAT NATIONAL COLLEGE
EMISSIONS CHEATING SCANDAL
ANNOUNCED LAST WEEK BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE SHOWING
THE REAL UGLY SIDE.
OF COLLEGE ADMISSIONS AND AGAIN
NOT JUST UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
TO TWO HIGH PROFILE EXAMPLE SO
FAR --
OTHERS THAT THAT IS SO CALLED
ELITE COLLEGES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND JUST A JUST A JUST --
TO SUMMARIZE WHAT OUR US
ATTORNEY SAID WHICH I THINK IS
SO POWERFUL.
HE SAID THERE CAN BE NO SEPARATE
ADMISSIONS PROCESS FOR THE
WEALTHY BUT THERE IT'S AND I
THINK THAT ADDRESSES THE ISSUE
WE TALKED ABOUT A SECOND AGO
WITH ENROLLMENT I THINK THAT'S
WHY IT'S IT'S SO MADDENING FOR
SO MANY PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE IT'S SO HARD TO GET INTO
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THERE'S SO MUCH PRESSURE TO
GET IN THERE ON THE STUDENTS ON
THE PARENTS.
AND WE SEE THIS WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL STUDENTS
DISPLACING CALIFORNIA KIDS BUT
WHEN YOU SEE.
OUT RIGHT FRAUD AND CHEATING TO
TO TAKE UP SOME OF THE SCARE
SEATS --
MAYBE IT'S TOO WE THINK IT'S
MANY MORE WERE GOING TO GET TO
THAT THAT THAT'S WAY TOO MANY.
AND THAT'S WHY THIS IS SUCH A
BIG ISSUE AND TO OUR SOCIETY IS
BASED UPON THE MERITOCRACY THAT
WE THINK ARE MISSIONS.
SYSTEM SHOULD BE FAIR AND JUST
TO THE SHOULD BE THIS FRONT DOOR.
AS THE THE NEW YORK TIMES ALLUDE
TO LAST FOR A LOT OF MONEY THAT
BY DORM AND IT'S THROUGH THESE
LEGACY ADMISSIONS BUT THIS.
A SIDE DOOR AS FAR AS
ESSENTIALLY BRIBING PEOPLE UNDER
THE TABLE IS JUST OUTRAGEOUS AND
RAISES SO MANY --
QUESTIONS WE HAVE WAY MORE
QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS BUT WE DID
WANT TO ALLOW THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA TO TO GIVE US.
AN AN UPDATE TODAY AND NOW SOME
SPECIFIC --
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS AND SO YOU
KNOW ALL OF SOME QUESTIONS AS
FAR AS HOW DOES THIS HOW DID
THIS HAPPEN.
THE THE THE THE THE AMOUNTS OF
INCIDENTS THAT WE KNOW OF SO FAR --
WHICH WE DO GOING FORWARD AS FAR
AS LEGACY ADMISSIONS THESE TAG
EMISSIONS FOR US FOR FOR
ATHLETES --
TAKING A LOOK AT THE S. A. T.
AND OTHER --
TEST ISSUES --
BUT AGAIN IT IS OUR IS OUR TWO
CAMPUSES ARE ARE MARQUEE
CAMPUSES THAT HAVE --
BLACK ICE --
SO FAR.
AND WE WANT TO HAVE A A ROBUST
DISCUSSION TODAY --
ON THIS ASSEMBLY --
HIGHER ED COMMITTEE AT AND THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ARE GONNA
HOLD ANOTHER HEARING ON THIS
BROADER LOOKING AT THE PRIVATE
SITUATIONS CSU THE COLLEGE BOARD --
SO SO WITH THAT HE WENT --
TO ALLOW THE THE UC TO GET
PRESENTATION WE'RE GONNA HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS BUT BUT THE BUT
WE WANT TO ALLOW OPENING
COMMENTS FROM A FEW PEOPLE AT
FIRST INCLUDING CHAIRMAN MEDINA.
THANK YOU --
CHAIR MCCARTY AND THANK YOU FOR
PUTTING THIS ON THE AGENDA --
IN THE IN THE PAST SIX YEARS I
DON'T KNOW THAT THERE'S AN ISSUE --
THAT IS GOT THE ATTENTION OF THE
PUBLIC A MORE THAN WHAT HAS
HAPPENED IN THE LAST WEEK.
IT WHEN I LOOK AT AT NEWSPAPERS
ACROSS THE NATION.
FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO CHRONICLE
TO THE NEW YORK TIMES --
TO THE LA TIMES.
YOU KNOW THIS IS AN ISSUE.
THAT FOR SOME REASON REALLY IS
CAPTURED THE ATTENTION OF THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC.
AND AND I THINK BECAUSE IT DEALS
WITH A COUPLE OF THINGS THAT ARE.
PRECIOUS TO THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
WHEN I WAS A SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER --
LIKE MY COLLEAGUE --
WE USED TO SAY THAT TWO THINGS
MOST PRECIOUS TO FOLKS WERE
THEIR CHILDREN.
AND THEIR MONEY.
AND THIS DEALS WITH BOTH OF THEM.
YOU KNOW THIS DEALS WITH THE
AMERICAN DREAM WITH THE AMERICAN
DREAM OF UPWARD MOBILITY.
WITH THE AMERICAN DREAM THAT
HARD WORK PAYS OFF.
SO THIS REALLY IS AN ISSUE THE
TO THAT THEY CAN --
SHAKE THE CONFIDENCE OF THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC SHAKE THE
CONFIDENCE OF THE STUDENTS THAT
I TAUGHT.
SHAKE THE CONFIDENCE OF THE
PARENTS WE REPRESENT.
THAT THAT HARD WORK WILL PAY OFF
IN THE END.
AND IT IS SOMETHING THAT I I
THINK WE WANT TO HOLD ON TO BUT
IT IS SOMETHING IT IS A TOPIC
THAT WE NEED TO LOOK AT AND WILL
HOW DID WE GET THERE.
HOW DID WE GET TO THIS POINT?
HOW DO WE GET TO THIS KIND OF
OBSERVED PLACE WERE SOME PARENT
IS WILLING TO PUT UP?
HALF A MILLION DOLLARS. TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEIR SON OR DAUGHTER
GOES TO A PARTICULAR INSTITUTION.
WHY IS THAT OF SO MUCH VALUE?
DOES THAT REALLY IS THERE REALLY
THAT MUCH OF AN ECONOMIC IMPACT
THAT IS GOING TO HAVE ON THE
FUTURE OF THEIR CHILD.
OR IS THERE SOMETHING MORE AT
WORK.
SO I I THINK IT IS A VERY BROAD
ISSUE.
THAT WE HAVE HERE IS I I THINK
IT IS ALMOST A SOCIETAL ISSUE.
AND THAT THERE ARE SOCIETAL
QUESTIONS TO BE ANSWERED.
IN IN THIS.
I I THINK AS WE MOVE FORWARD IT
IS NOT SO MUCH ABOUT.
FINDING WRONG DOING WITH A
PARTICULAR INSTITUTION.
OR A PARTICULAR SYSTEM BECAUSE
ACROSS THE NATION SO MANY
COLLEGES [inaudible]
HAVE BEEN.
I WOULD SAY SNOOKERED WERE TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF TO TALK ABOUT A
SIDE DOOR WHAT DO YOU FROM IS.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT IS CHEATING LINE FRAUD.
IT ALSO THE COLLEGES SIDE DOOR
OF YOU KNOW I HAVE ISSUE WITH
THAT.
BLATANT LINE BLATANT CHEATING OF
BUYING PAYINGFOR SOMEONE TO
TAKE YOUR YOUR COLLEGE.
ENTRANCE EXAM IN A PHOTO
SHOPPING --
ATHLETES PICTURES.
SO I I WANT TO SAY AT THE OUTSET
THAT I DON'T THINK THIS IS ABOUT
LOOKING.
FOR OF WRONGDOING ON THE PART OF
A COLLEGE OR UNIVERSITY SYSTEM.
I THINK IT IS CLEAR THAT IT IS
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN WRONGDOING WHETHER
IT'S PARENTS.
COACHES THE PROCTORS AND THAT
THOSE PEOPLE.
SHOULD AND WILL BE PROSECUTED I
KNOW THAT COLLEGES ARE MOVING
FORWARD TO LOOKING AT WHO WERE
THE STUDENTS INVOLVED.
AND IN THE CASE OF U. S. C. I
THINK STUDENTS OF ALREADY BEEN
RELEASE I THINK --
UNIVERSITIES LIKE U. S. C. OR
LOOK STUDENTS WHO BENEFITTED
FROM THIS AND IN IN THE
ADMISSIONS PROCESS AND THEY WILL
BE LOOKED AT AS WELL.
SO I JUST WANTED TO SHARE THAT
AT THE OUTSET.
AND AND WE'LL BE HAPPY HEARING
AND HAVING MORE HEARINGS ON THE
TOPIC.
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING SURE MCCARTY AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME HERE TODAY AND FOR YOUR TIME
AND ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE.
MY NAME'S ALEX BUSTAMANTE AND
I'M A SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT AND
CHIEF COMPLIANCE AND AUDIT
OFFICER FOR THE UNITE THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA.
I'M THE CHIEF UNIVERSITY
OFFICIAL RESPONSIBLE FOR
DEVELOPING AND MAINTAINING THE
UNIVERSITY'S ETHICS COMPLIANCE
IN OUR PROGRAMS.
AND I REPORT DIRECTLY TO THE
REGION'S AND FUNCTION AS AN
INDEPENDENT AUTHORITY TO REVIEW
AUDIT AND EVALUATE UNIVERSITY
COMPLIANCE WITH LAW.
REGULATIONS POLICY THAT VEHICLE
PRINCIPLES.
AS THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
GRADUATE MYSELF I WAS PERSONALLY
OFFENDED TO LEARN BUT SEVERAL
INDIVIDUALS ARE ACCUSED OF
CHEATING AND ACCEPTING BRIBES TO
GAIN.
AN UNLAWFUL ADMISSION TO SEVERAL
UNIVERSITIES INCLUDING THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
AS OUTLINED IN THE CHARGES FILED
BY THE US DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
LIKE MOST THE STUDENTS TODAY I
WORK VERY HARD FOR MY ADMISSION
TO UC BERKELEY.
WRESTLING.
I WANT TO REASSURE YOU THAT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WILL
NOT TOLERATE ANY ILLEGAL
INAPPROPRIATE OR UNETHICAL
ATTEMPTS. TO GET ADMISSION TO
THE UNIVERSITY AT THE EXPENSE OF
DESERVING APPLICANTS.
THIS TYPE OF BEHAVIOR IS
UNACCEPTABLE IT IS A DISSERVICE
TO HARD WORKING STUDENTS DESERVE
A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD.
IN THE ADMISSIONS PROCESS.
SO SHORTLY AFTER THE NEWS BROKE
PRESIDENT A PART TIME TO ASK MY
OFFICE THE OFFICE OF ETHICS
COMPLAINTS NOT SERVICES. TO
PERFORM AN IMMEDIATE INDEPENDENT
ASSESSMENT OF THESE ISSUES.
I'LL BE SUPERVISING THE
INVESTIGATIONS CURRENTLY
OCCURRING IN ENSURING THEIR
TIMELY EFFECTIVE AND
CONSISTENTLY ADDRESS THE ISSUES.
MY TEAM AND I WILL ALSO
COORDINATE WITH FEDERAL
AUTHORITIES TO ENSURE THAT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA FULLY
COOPERATES.
WITH THEIR ON GOING
INVESTIGATIONS INTO THESE
MATTERS AND TO IDENTIFY
ADDITIONAL RESPONSIBLE PARTIES
RELATED TO THESE MATTERS TO THE
EXTENT THEY EXIST.
THE PRESIDENT HAS CONTACTED THE
CHANCES TO ENSURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS PERFORMING THESE
INVESTIGATIONS AND ASSESSMENTS.
ARE UNDER THE DIRECTION OF HE
CASTS.
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE TIMELY AND
UNFETTERED ACCESS TO DOCUMENTS
FILES INDIVIDUALS NECESSARY FOR
COMPLETE A FULL INVESTIGATION.
IMPORTANTLY I'VE BEEN TASKED
WITH CONDUCTING A CRITICAL
REVIEW OF OUR ADMISSIONS
PROCEDURES.
I WILL NOT CONFINE MY ANALYSIS
TO ANALYTICS.
RATHER WEEBLY EXAMINING GENERAL
AND IT AND STRENGTHEN OUR
PRACTICES.
I'VE SPOKEN WITH MY AUDIT
DIRECTORS THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEM
AND WE WILL WE WILL BE COMMENCE
SEEN OUR ASSESSMENT SHORTLY.
IF DURING THIS PROCESS WE
IDENTIFY FRAUD WEAKNESSES IN THE
SYSTEM.
I WILL ENSURE THOSE MATTERS ARE
THOROUGHLY INVESTIGATED AND ALL
ISSUES RECOMMENDATIONS IN
CORRECTIVE ACTION BE BROUGHT
BEFORE THE PRESIDENT AND THE
REGION'S.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL THAT
WE STRENGTHEN OUR PROCESS SEES
HOLD THOSE ACCOUNTABLE FOR
CORRECTING THESE PROCEDURES.
AND TO DEMONSTRATE OUR
COMMITMENT TO FAIRNESS IN THE
ADMISSION PROCESS BY REDOUBLING
OUR VIGILANCE IN THE AREA.
THIS IS OUR FUNDAMENTAL
OBLIGATION OUR STUDENTS OUR
ALUMNI AND TO THE PUBLIC.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MCCARTY AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
IRAQ HAS HI MY NAME IS MICHAEL
BROWN AND I AM THE CHIEF
ACADEMIC OFFICER.
ARE FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND I WAS THE PAUL.
ODD TO HEAR THE NEWS THAT BROKE
LAST WEEK.
ARE WE HAVE PERSONS OF WEALTH OF
FAME.
ARE OF INFLUENCE.
OUR WHO DEVISED SCHEMES ARE TO
FRAUDULENTLY MISREPRESENTED THE
ADMISSIONS CREDENTIALS OF
APPLICANTS.
OUR WHERE THEY WERE THOSE
APPLICANTS TRULY LEARNING
DISABLED.
AT AND WORTHY OF EXTRA TIME ON
TAKING THE TESTS AND AND WHERE
THEY COOLEY ATHLETES --
OUT WAS THE TEST PERFORMANCE
REFLECTED.
IN THEIR APPLICATIONS REALLY
TRULY REFLECTIVE OF THEM AS
STUDENTS AND ONE CAN EVEN RAISE
QUESTIONS ABOUT OTHER ASPECTS OF
THE EMISSIONS CREDENTIALS
BECAUSE WE DO NOW --
THAT EA EVEN THINGS LIKE GRADES --
AND EMISSIONS RECORDS ARE CAN BE --
AT GREAT RECORDS CAN BE FAKED --
IF YOU HAVE ENOUGH MONEY ENOUGH
POWER THEIR WEALTH AND INFLUENCE
WAS USED TO BRIBE THE CALL OUT
TO COOPERATION OF OTHERS OUTSIDE
OF THE ADMISSIONS OFFICE.
ITSELF TO CREATE OUR AND I'D
LIKE YOUR CHARACTERIZATION --
AT CHAIR MEDINA --
AS THEY CALL IT YOU FOR
MYSTICALLY A SIDE DOOR BUT AS
THE DOOR BURKE --
BORN OF OF CHIEF IN THE SEAT --
OF FRAUD --
HARD TO GET ACCESS TO OP
PRECIOUS LEE RARE RESOURCE THAT
THIS STATE IS STRUGGLING HARD TO
FIND WAYS OF SUPPORT.
OUR OUR ATHLETES --
ATHLETIC COACHES AND
STANDARDIZED TESTING OFFICIALS
WERE BRIBED AS PART OF THE
SCHEME TO DECEIVE ADMISSIONS
OFFICES OF OUR TOP UNIVERSITIES.
ARE ALL AT THE EXPENSE OF
DESERVING APPLICANTS.
WHO WERE PLAYING BY THE RULES?
OUR ARMED ARE BUT THIS WAS
BENEATH THOSE FOLKS IS NOTICE --
BUT IT'S CLEARLY NOT BENEATH THE
NOTICE OF MEMBERS OF THIS BODY.
OUR THIS IS ABSOLUTELY
INTOLERABLE.
OUR AND OUR AND FOR ME AND MAYBE
FOR MANY AND I'M I'M HEARING AND
SOME OF THE COMMENTS ESPECIALLY
GOLLY -- I
THINK YOUR TERM I CHAIR ARE
MCCARTY WAS MADDENING --
THAT THE EMISSION SYSTEM IS
ALREADY CONSTRUED BY MANY AS
RIGGED TO THE ADVANTAGE OF SUCH
PEOPLE.
OUR OB THINK ABOUT JUST ALL THE
TEST PREP INTENSE COACHING --
THAT AT THAT THEY HAVE --
THE ABILITY TO PAY.
FOR THE QUALITY OF SCHOOLING OUR
MOST OF US KNOW ABOUT THE ZIP
CODE AFFECT --
THAT PEOPLE CAN ACTUALLY CHANGE
WHERE THEY LIVE TO GET ACCESS TO
BETTER SCHOOLS.
WHAT ABOUT THE WITHIN SCHOOL
TRACKING SYSTEM?
ARE AND THE ABILITY TO GET --
EVEN JUST EIGHT A. G. COURSES --
BUT BUT DIDN'T YOU COULD TALK
ABOUT GET ACCESS THE HONORS
COURSES IN AP COURSES AND SO
WORN.
OUT -- AT
AND WE KNOW WHERE THIS GOES IN
WE KNOW WHO DOESN'T GET ACCESS
TO THESE.
ARE HOW ABOUT THE ACCESS TO JUST
APPROVED A TO G. COURSE.
ARE -- ARE
OUT THE ABILITY TO EARN A HIGHER
GPA WILL WE'D KNOW --
THIS PHENOMENON OF GRADE
INFLATION IS GREATEST --
AT THE AT THE WEALTHIER SCHOOLS
ACTUALLY NOT AT THE POORER
SCHOOLS --
WE KNOW THAT THE AVAILABILITY OF
COLLEGE GOING REACHED KNOWLEDGE
IN RESOURCE --
IS ALSO TIED --
TO TO TO WEALTH AND INFLUENCE AT
THE ACADEMIC SUPPORT STUDENTS
HAVE AVAILABLE TO THEM ACCESS TO
POWERFUL A KNOWLEDGEABLE PEOPLE
FOR ADVICE INFORMATION FOR
RECOMMENDATION --
AS ONE OF THE MOST HIGHLY
REGARDED UNIVERSITIES IN THE
WORLD OUR OUR UNIVERSITY THAT IS
ALSO PUBLIC.
ARE ARE YOU SEE HAS A SPECIAL
RESPONSIBILITY. TO ENSURE A
LEVEL PLAYING FIELD --
IS IS AVAILABLE --
FOR AND SOME IN THE LEGISLATURE
MAY KNOW --
THAT THIS DEDICATION IT IS NOT
JUST THE DEDICATION FOR YOU SEE
I PERSONALLY HAVE IT AND HAVE
AYE I HOPE SOME OF YOU KNOW
DEMONSTRATE THAT THAT OVER MY
TWENTY SIX YEARS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE UNIVERSITY THE UNIVERSITY IS
PROUD.
THAT AND I AM TO THAT
APPROXIMATELY 37% OF OURS ARE OF
YOU SEE STUDENTS COME FROM LOW
INCOME FAMILIES.
ARE NO SEE ISSUE NO OUR AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITIES OUR
SCHOOL HAS BOTH A HIGHER
PERCENTAGE OF PALE ENROLLEES.
ARE AT AND A HIGHER A PALE
GRADUATION RATE THEN ARE UC
CAMPUSES.
WE HAVE NO LEGACY ADMISSIONS AT
ARE PARTICULARLY PROUD --
THAT APPROXIMATELY 42402% OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE FIRST OUR OUR OUR
FIRST GENERATION STUDENTS.
WITH RESPECT TO STUDENT ATHLETES
CAMPUS BASED REVIEWERS --
WHICH INCLUDE FACULTY EVALUATE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON ADMISSIONS
MADE BY THE ATHLETIC DEPARTMENT
BUT THEY ARE TWO MAR KNOWLEDGE
BUT WE'RE GOING TO CHECK THIS
OUT BUT TO MY KNOWLEDGE THEY
DON'T ADMIT THE STUDENTS THEY
THEY MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS.
BUT THEY GO TO A BODY AND MANY
EYES LOOK ON OUR ON ON ON THE
DECISION AND SO THE FINAL
DECISION IS DETERMINED BY THAT
BODY NOT THE ATHLETICS
DEPARTMENT.
BUT IF THERE'S SOME BREAKDOWNS
HERE WE'LL LEARN THAT.
OUR STUDENTS A MINUTE BY OUR BY
EXCEPTION TO OUR ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS MUST DEMONSTRATE A
REASONABLE POTENTIAL FOR SUCCESS
THAT THE UNIVERSITY --
THESE STUDENTS MUST SHOW THE
POTENTIAL TO EARN A UC DEGREE.
THE UNIVERSITY HAS NO SYSTEM
WITH REGION WITH A WITH WITH A
LONG NIGHT WITH ELECTED
OFFICIALS ARE OR OTHER
INFLUENTIAL --
OUT I INDIVIDUALS.
WE HAVE AN ADMISSIONS
VERIFICATION PROCESS THAT
RANDOMLY SELECT APPLICANTS ARE
TO UNDERGO A SYSTEM WIDE
VERIFICATION PROCESS OF THEIR
ADMISSIONS CREDENTIALS.
OUR PRIOR TO ADMISSION.
SO THE ETHICAL BEHAVIOR OF A FEW
INDIVIDUALS HERE.
ONLY REINFORCES IN MY VIEW I
UC'S UNWAVERING COMMITMENT TO
FAIRNESS AND EQUITY.
MANY CALIFORNIANS I BELIEVE THAT
SOCIETY IS NOT WORKING THE WAY
THAT IT SHOULD --
THAT EVERYTHING IS SLANTED IN
THE DIRECTION OF THE RICH AND
THE POWERFUL.
BOB.
CAN OPPORTUNITY PARTICULARLY
THIS PRECIOUS OPPORTUNITY ARE
YOU SEE EDUCATION BE MORE FAIRLY
DISTRIBUTING.
OUR IS SPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF
SOCIAL INEQUITY.
THE SAID IN DISMAYING
CIRCUMSTANCES --
ARE ACTUALLY MAY END UP WORKING
TO THE BENEFIT OF US ALL.
ARE AS WE CONTINUE TO EXAMINE
AND RE EXAMINE BOTH CURRENT
POLICIES AND PRACTICES BOTH
CURRENT POLICIES AND PRACTICES
IN THE CONTEXT OF THAT QUESTION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER BROWN
MISTER BUSTAMANTE INTO THAT WE
APPRECIATE THE RESPONSE AND IT
WAS IT'S A STRONG RESPONSE BOTH
TODAY AND FROM THE THE
UNIVERSITY I WILL SAY.
BECAUSE IT'S AN ASSAULT ON THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA THE
TAXPAYERS STUDENTS PARENTS WHO
ARE TRYING.
TO HUSTLE THE RIGHT WAY. TO GET
THERE --
KIDS PREPARED TO ENTER THE
NEAREST CALIFORNIA AND ITS
ASSAULT ONON ON THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA'S WE WANT TO KEEP
WORKING WITH YOU AND UNDERSTAND
WHAT HAPPENED AND IS THE EARLY
STAGES.
AND ALSO LOOK ABOUT LOOKING DO
IDEAS FOR REFORM SO I'M GONNA
START WITH A FEW QUESTIONS AND
OPEN UP TO TO MY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS --
ARDOR STANDING IS THE THE THE
INDICTMENT THAT WAS ANNOUNCED
LAST WEEK HAD.
ROUGHLY EIGHT HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS --
NAMES ABOUT THIRTY HER CELL WERE
PUBLIC A FEW HIGH PROFILE ONES
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT --
OF WHICH I TO SO FAR WE KNOW ARE
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA ONE
WITH THE UCLA WITH A SOCCER
COACH ONE AT UC BERKELEY WITH
THAT FRAUDULENT SAT SCORES.
SO FAR DO WE KNOW OF OF ANY
OTHER YOU SEE EXAMPLES BESIDES
THAT HAVE AT BERKELEY AND UCLA.
CURRENTLY NO BUT WHAT WE'VE
TRIED TO DO --
TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE FULL
VISIBILITY ON THIS ISSUE IS
WE'VE CONTACTED THE US
ATTORNEY'S OFFICES.
AND THE FEDERAL BUREAU OF
INVESTIGATION.
AND HAVE.
A INDICATED THAT WE WILL HELP IN
ANY WAY.
POSSIBLE TO FURTHER THEIR
INVESTIGATIONS BUT BE ASK IF WE
CAN GET SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ON ANYBODY ELSE.
INVOLVED WITH THE UC SYSTEM THAT
MIGHT HAVE DONE THIS.
TYPE OF CORRUPTION ACT SO THAT
WE CAN ADDRESS IT FROM OUR END
AND WE CAN USE THAT NATALIE TO
INVESTIGATE THE THE MATTER AT
HAND BUT TRY TO TIGHTEN OUR
PROCESSES UP IT.
AS WELL SO DO WE KNOW IF THE
EIGHT HUNDRED THAT CASES IN THE
IN THE U. FRAUDULENT EXAMPLES
FOR PEOPLE UTILIZING THAT
SERVICE IN OTHER WORDS.
THE FELLOW WHO FOUNDED THE FIRM
MISTER SINGER IS FROM SACRAMENTO.
AND I HAVE HEARD OF FAMILIES IN
THE LAST WEEK WHO HAVE UTILIZED
TO SERVICES AND AND THEY THEY
CLAIM THAT IT WAS THAT SAT PREP
ADVICE ON WHAT CALL JUST APPLY
FOR SO I SOON BEFORE HE ENDEAVOR
IN THIS ILLEGAL ENTERPRISE HE HE
PROBABLY WORK WITH SOME STUDENTS.
ON THE UP AND UP.
DO WE KNOW IF THAT LARGE NUMBER
EIGHT HUNDRED ARE ALL FRAUDULENT
EXAMPLES --
DIRECTOR TOTAL CASES I'M NOT
PRIVY TO THE US ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE CASE SO I WOULD BE
SPECULATING --
I AGAIN WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO GET
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION. TO
FIGURE OUT THE FULL SCOPE AND
BREADTH OF THE IMPACT OF THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA.
RIGHT NOW I HAVE NO ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION.
OKAY ON ON THE ON THE EXAMPLES
OF THE THE ATHLETES --
THAT'S THE THAT'S ONE OF THE
MOST GALLING EXAMPLES HERE AT
UCLA AND SAYS --
YOU KNOW SELAGINELLA YES THAT
YOU SEE THERE CALLED TAG ADMITS
WERE.
THE COACH CAN CAN TAG THE
STUDENT AS AN APPLICANT WHO
MAYBE HAS SUB STANDARD GPA AND
SAT SCORES BUT CAN.
THEY CAN GET --
ADMISSIONS NOT THROUGH A
SCHOLARSHIP BUT BY BEING A
PLAYER ON AN ATHLETIC TEAM --
NOT YOU SEE THERE IS ONE EXAMPLE
HEARD ABOUT WHERE THE STUDENT
EVEN KNOW THAT HE WAS ALLEGEDLY
PART OF THE TRACK TEAM AND SELL
IT IT MAKES YOU WONDER OR
STUDENTS --
ADMITTED --
TO UNIVERSITY TO PARTICIPATE THE
SWIM TEAM AND THEY DON'T KNOW
HOW TO SWIM --
SO -- YOU
MENTIONED EARLIER THIS
ADMISSIONS VERIFICATION SYSTEM
HOW IS IT POSSIBLE THAT AN
INDIVIDUAL IS ADMITTED BASED
UPON ATHLETIC PROWESS IN A
CERTAIN SPORT AND THERE WASN'T
FOLLOW UP TO MAKE SURE --
THAT'S LEGIT --
SO SO THAT'S THE FIRST HALF THE
QUESTION ALL COME BACK.
YES AT THE AT THE STAGE THAT THE
EMISSIONS FOR FOR CATION PROCESS
HAPPENS IT'S THAT THE
APPLICATION STAGE THERE ARE TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
APPLICANTS.
SO WE DON'T REVIEW EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF THEM AS A VERIFICATION
PROCESS BUT THEY ARE RANDOMLY
SELECTED --
I I A I AND NUMBER THAT WE
BELIEVE --
ALLOWS US TO TEST AND ALSO
SIGNAL SIGNAL --
THAT THAT THAT --
CREDENTIALS DO GET.
OUT AND THOSE FOLKS ARE ARE ARE --
THAT THE PARTICULAR ASPECTS OF
THEIR APPLICATIONS THAT THAT
GENERATE EITHER QUESTIONS FOR US
OR WE WANT TO DELVE FURTHER IN
WE SEND --
FOLLOW A SET OF INFORMATION THAT
THE STUDENT HAS TO RESPOND --
TO ART THROUGH THAT PROCESS --
EVERY YEAR ROUGHLY ABOUT A
HUNDRED STUDENTS DON'T GO
FURTHER NOW IT COULD BE FOR ANY
NUMBER RESERVE IT MAY BE THAT
THAT THAT THEY DECIDE THAT --
THEY CAN ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS.
WE COULD BE THAT THEY DECIDE
THAT THE THE PLACES THEY WANT TO
GO THOSE APPLICANTS OR ADMIT
APPLICANTS YEAH WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE ADMIT SO ONCE ONCE
ADMITTED.
WHAT'S THE SPOT CHECK.
GOING ON RIGHT NOW AND WHAT
SPECIFICALLY THE SPOT CHECK
THEIR STUDENTS THAT ARE ADMITTED.
FOR THESE ATHLETIC REASONS FOR
THAT SPECIAL ADMITS THE SIDE
DOOR AT ALL STUDENTS THAT ARE
ADMITTED. TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
REMEMBER THEIR THEIR THEIR THEIR
ADMITTED AROUND THE END OF THEIR
THEIR JUNIOR YEARS.
SO -- SO
THEY'RE ACTUALLY ADMITTED ON
CONDITION --
I'M MAYBE NOT EVERYBODY KNOWS
THAT BUT THEY'RE ACTUALLY
CONDITIONALLY ADMITTED THEY HAVE --
TO THEY INDICATE WHAT THEY'RE
WHAT WHAT COURSES THAT DARE TO
OUR OUT PLANNING TO TAKE IN THAT
SENIOR YEAR --
THEY THEY WHAT WHAT ACTIVITIES
THEY PLAN TO BE INVOLVED IN IN
THAT NEXT YEAR AND SO ONCE
THEY'RE IN MID AT THE CAMPUS IS
ACTUALLY REVIEW TO SEE IF THEY
DID WHAT.
THE WHAT THE WHAT --
THE STUDENTS SAID THEY WERE
GOING TO DO.
AND WHAT WERE THEIR GRADES AS
REPORTED FROM THE SCHOOL --
BECAUSE AT THAT POINT WE ACTION
NO THEIR ACTUAL TRANSCRIPTS WE
ACTUALLY KNOW THEN AT THAT POINT
WHAT COURSES THAT THEY REALLY
TAKE -- SO
THERE'S A NUMBER OF THINGS LIKE
THAT ARE BETTER FOLLOWED UP
PRIOR TO THAT STUDENT ENROLLED.
BUT WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
GRADES NOR GPA THAT'S THAT THAT
IS WHAT IT IS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
THERE ARE ALL RIDES YEAH THAT --
COACH SAYS YES THAT KIDS GOING
TO BE A STRONG A WALK ON
ATHLETES AND ADD SOME CHARACTER
AND RESOLVE TO OUR TEAM WE WANT
THEM IN.
THE UNIVERSITY ON OUR TEAM EVEN
THOUGH THEIR GRADES AREN'T UP TO
PAR WHAT ARE WE DOING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ADMISSIONS OFFICER.
DOESN'T JUST SAY OKAY COACH WILL
GIVE YOU ONE AND THAT WE VERIFY
THAT THESE INDIVIDUALS.
ARE WHAT THEY SAY THEY ARE
THERE'S NO FRAUD AND GOING TO
FIND OUT WHAT THAT PROCESS I
MIGHT BE ABLE TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION YES THAT FROM MY PERCH.
ALL THE QUESTIONS THAT YOU VAST
FROM THE EAST THE STUDENT
ATHLETE UP.
QUOTES AROUND THAT TO DETERMINE
WHETHER AT THE PROPER PROCEDURES
ARE BEING FOLLOWED WITH WE HAVE
SEVEN I CAN IS SINCE TO VERIFY
WHETHER THESE PEOPLE ARE ON THE
UP AND UP.
WHETHER THERE'S ENOUGH CHECKS
AND BALANCES IN THE SYSTEM TO
ASSURE THAT WE HAVE MULTIPLE ICE
ON THESE.
THESE ARE ALL THINGS THAT MY
AUDIT WILL BE LOOKING INTO WE'LL
BE LOOKING AT THE STUDENT
ATHLETE SITUATION LOOK AT THE
ATHLETIC DEPARTMENT.
WE'RE GONNA BE LOOKING FOR ANY
KIND OF STRUCTURAL WEAKNESSES
ALONG WITH TRYING TO IDENTIFY
SOME OF THE SHORTCOMINGS ALONG
WITH THE INVESTIGATIONS.
WE ARE NOW INVOLVED WITH AND
HOPEFULLY GET ADDITIONAL
GUIDANCE FROM THE FEDERAL
AGENCIES BUT YOUR ISSUES ARE
GOING TO BE SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESSED.
IN THAT AUDIT AND WE'RE GOING TO
SCREW UP THIS AND SEE WHAT WE
CAN DO TO IMPROVE OUR PROCESS
THE SECTOR AND ALSO PUT
ADDITIONAL CHECKS IN PLACE. TO
ENSURE THAT WE MAKE IT VERY
DIFFICULT. FOR ANYBODY TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE SYSTEM.
AND ALSO THAT WE HAVE AUDIT
FEATURES SO THAT WE CAN COME
BACK TO THESE MATTERS FREQUENTLY
AND EXAMINE THEM TO ENSURE THAT
THEY ARE OPERATING IN A WAY.
THAT WE EXPECTED NEED THEM TO BE
OPERATING OKAY SO.
I ASSUME WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS
NOT JUST WHAT HAPPENED BUT ALSO
RECKLESS IS GOING FOR TO PREVENT
THIS FROM EVER HAPPENING
ABSOLUTELY CANCER ABSOLUTELY I
DON'T WANT TO BE REVISITING THIS
ISSUE I WANT US.
NOW THAT WE HAVE THIS BROUGHT TO
OUR ATTENTIONTHE INSIDE IN
MISSIONS AND ALSO WITH THE
ATHLETIC SIDE.
AND SEE WHERE WE CAN STRENGTHEN
THESE PROCESS SEES AND RECAPTURE
SOME OF THE FAITH WITH THE
PUBLIC THAT WE ARE DOING IT IN
FACT WHAT WE SAY WE ARE DOING.
THANK YOU AS FAR AS THAT THE
LEGACY --
ADMITS YOUR TESTIMONY SAYS THERE
ARE THERE ARE NONE --
THERE WERE UP TO THREE DECADES
AGO WITH THE REGENT'S HAD THESE --
SPECIAL ADMITS IN LEGACY ADMITS
WORK FRANKLY WAS A SPECIAL
INTEREST WEALTHY INDIVIDUALS GOT
ACCESS TO A BACK DOOR SIDE DOOR
WASN'T THE FRONT DOOR AND SO --
WHEN WE --
WENT AWAY WITH --
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION.
AND THE HOPE THAT THIS P. S. P.
ONE PROCESS AND THEN IN THE
NINETIES THAT WENT AWAY BUT
THERE STILL ARE THE SPECIAL
ADMITS --
BESIDES THESE ATHLETIC SPECIAL
ADMITS ARE OTHER OTHER TYPE OF
SPECIAL ADMITS WITHIN THE UC AND
AND AND WHAT WHAT WHAT'S THE
NUMBER WE THINK --
YOU SEE WHY THAT THE SPECIAL
THAT TRIBUNE A BETTER POSITION
TO ANSWER THAT ONCE THE AUDITS
ARE UNDERWAY WE WILL BE LOOKING
AT ALL EXEMPTIONS WE'LL BE
LOOKING AT ALL SPECIAL ADMITS.
WILL BE EXAMINING THE PROCEDURES
ON THOSE.
AND WE WILL BE LOOKING SO WITH
THE OPERATION SIDE IN OTHER
INDIVIDUALS SAY THAT THERE ARE.
NO LEGACY MY JOB IS TO CONFIRM
THAT THERE'S NO LIKE SEAT MY JOB
IS TO LOOK INTO THOSE AREAS AND
MAKE SURE THAT.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY OTHER ISSUES
AS A VERIFICATION MATH MECHANISM
FOR THE REGION'S I CAN GIVE A
LITTLE EXTRA EFFORT INFORMATION
ON THAT --
THERE'S A SMALL NUMBER OF
STUDENTS WHO ARE EXCEPTIONALLY
GIFTED --
OUR AND WHO CAN CONTRIBUTE TO
THE CULTURAL AND SOCIAL VITALITY
TO CAMPUS --
THAT THAT ARE ADMITTED THROUGH
THAT PROCESS AND THESE MAY BE
GITED MUSICIANS AND GIFTED
PERFORMERS IN DIFFERENT FIELDS
OF PERFORMANCE OR UP OR AND OR
IN THE CASE OF STUDENT ATHLETES --
THE POLICY OF FOR WHAT IS CALLED
AT EMISSIONS BY EXCEPTION IS 6%
OF ENROLLED STUDENTS.
BOB IT HAS BEEN 2% IT IS RARELY
EVEN EXCEEDED 2% --
ARE IN ALL THE YEARS I'VE BEEN
EXOCET WITH THE UNIVERSITY AND
I'VE BEEN INVOLVED WITH
ADMISSIONS POLICY FOR FOR A LONG
TIME -- OUT
BUT BUT THESE INDIVIDUALS --
AND IN INCLUDES THAN INDIVIDUALS
WHO MIGHT BE HOME SCHOOLED THAT
DEBT THAT DON'T HAVE THIS AND
THAT DON'T PRESENT THE SAME KIND
OF CREDENTIALS AS NON HOME
SCHOOL STUDENTS OR THEY COME
FROM UNIQUELY DISADVANTAGED
BACKGROUNDS.
BUT YET CHAU POTENTIAL TO
SUCCEED AT THE UNIVERSITY --
AS ALEX SAID WE POLICY --
AND AND THAT THERE ARE ABUSES
ARE AND THAT THE THE WRITE
CHECKS AND BALANCES.
I ASSUME THAT THE REVIEW WILL
INCLUDE NOT JUST THE ATHLETIC
SPECIAL ADMITS BUT ALL THE 6%.
SPECIAL ADMIT BUT WE'RE GONNA
LOOK AT BOTH THE CAMPUS SIDE IN
ATHLETICS OKAY HAVE ANY MORE.
QUESTIONS ON THE THE INDUSTRY
AND THEN ON THE SAT OF BEFORE
OPEN UP TO MY TO MY COLLEAGUES --
YOU KNOW THIS ISSUE KINDA SHINES
LIGHT ON THIS WHOLE COTTAGE
INDUSTRY OF THESE --
COLLEGE ADMISSIONS ADVISORS AND
CONSULTANTS AS SOME ARE THAT SAT
PREP WE'VE HEARD ABOUT FOR A
LONG TIME KAPLAN AND SO FOR SOME.
ADVISE STUDENTS AND WHAT
COLLEGES ARE VIABLE TO APPLY TO
THEM SOME OBVIOUSLY WHAT WENT
WELL BEYOND SO I ASSUME --
SOME OF THESE INDIVIDUALS AND
BUSINESSES SELL THEMSELVES TO
CONSUMERS BASED UPON THEIR
RELATIONSHIP.
WITH THE UNIVERSITY'S ADMISSIONS
OFFICERS AND SO FORTH SO WHAT
TYPE OF STRUCTURE RELATIONSHIP
IS THERE WITH THESE WITH THESE
INDIVIDUALS THIS INDUSTRY AND
THE AND THE UNIVERSITY
ADMISSIONS DEPARTMENTS.
I'M AWARE OF NO STRUCTURAL
RELATIONSHIP --
BETWEEN THOSE INDUSTRIES OKAY
BUT AND THAT SECOND QUESTION IS
SHOULD THERE BE SHOULD WE HAVE
SOME TYPE OF BASIC --
REGISTRY THAT INDIVIDUALS NO YOU
KNOW WHAT THE WHAT THEY'RE
GETTING THEMSELVES INTO AS FAR
AS THIS THAT HAS A UNIVERSITY
THOUGHT ABOUT --
YOU KNOW HAVING SOME TYPE OF OF
OF OF OF THE OFFICIAL
SANCTIONING OF THE OF THESE OF
THESE -- OF
THESE BUSINESSES AND CONSULTANTS
OUT THERE.
I'M MAKING A NOTE OF THAT.
THE SUGGESTION BECAUSE I HI.
I HADN'T THOUGHT ABOUT IT AND
I'M NOT AWARE OF OTHERS WHO HAVE
I THINK THAT'S IT AS SUGGESTION
WORTH WORTH EXAMINING.
AND THEN --
THE LAST SET OF FIVE QUESTIONS
RELATED TO THE TESTING PIECE OF
THIS AND SO.
A LOT OF DEBATE OF COURSE
TONIGHT I HAVE ASKED THE
QUESTION AS WELL --
ABOUT THE SAT AND FRANKLY I WAS
SOMEWHAT.
IN THE SPIRES NOT THE RIGHT WORD
BUT IT INTRIGUED ABOUT THIS --
ALMOST TWENTY YEARS AGO WHEN ARE
YOU SEE PRESIDENT --
DICK ATKINS AND ASK THIS
QUESTION AND AND TALKED ABOUT.
THE NEED TO POTENTIALLY GET AWAY
FROM FROM THE S. A. T. AND IT
GOES BACK TO THE ENROLLMENT
DEBATE WE HAD AN HOUR AGO
TALKING ABOUT TEST SCORES AND
LGBT LOCAL CONTACTS AND ONE THE
STRONGEST INDICATORS OF SUCCESS.
OUR TEST SCORES BUT HOW YOU
DIDN'T HIGH SCHOOL ON YOUR
GRADES IN COURSES WHICH HARDER
TO CHEAT ON THOSE AND IT IS YOUR
SAT AND SPECIFICALLY HOW YOU DID
AMONGST YOUR PEERS.
WHETHER YOU WANT TO THE TOP
SCHOOL IN CALIFORNIA LOWEST
RANKING SCHOOLS SO I I'M
UNDERSTANDING IS UNIVERSE
CALIFORNIA ABOUT A YEAR AGO.
EMBARKED UPON A A STUDY IN A
PROCESS WITH THE FACULTY TO
REVIEW.
THIS AND TO POTENTIALLY LOOK AT
THE FUTURE OF THE S. C. T. S. A.
T. -- HOPING
THAT YOU COULD GIVE US AN UPDATE
ON HOW ON HOW THAT IS
PROGRESSING ANY INSIGHT TODAY.
THERE ARE THEY ARM AT MEETING
ABOUT THOUGH --
ARE MAYBE SIX TO EIGHT MONTHS
AGO AT THE PRESIDENT ASK --
THE ACADEMIC SENATE --
TO A TO UNDERTAKE A REVIEW --
OF THE OF THE USE OF EMISSIONS
TESTS -- I'M
ACTUALLY SUPPOSED TO MEET WITH
THAT GROUP BUT HI IN A IN A IN A
IN A WEEK OR TWO ARE AND GIVE
THEM MY INSIGHTS --
CHAIR MCCARTY OUT OF THE I
DIDN'T KNOW IT WAS TWENTY YEARS
AGO BUT THAT I'VE SAWN BOARDS AT
THAT TIME.
NGUYEN --
THE TESTS WERE WERE ON TO THEM
AT LEAST JUST SOME INSIGHTS FROM
THAT EXPERIENCE SO --
THEY ARE MEETING --
THEY HAVE BEEN COMPRISED OF OF
OF CYCLE PATRICIANS AND ARE
INCLUDING TESTS PROPONENTS AND
CRITICS --
THE GOAL IS TO APPROACH THIS
FROM A TRULY ACADEMIC POINT OF
VIEW I I'M LYING TO TO TO READ
TO REPORT BACK TO OUR THE
PHARMACY THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
STATE -- I
THINK THE GOAL IS TO ALLOW THAT
PROCESS TO TO TAKE WHATEVER TIME
THAT THAT THE GOAL IS TO GET IT
RIGHT.
THEN TO GET A QUICK --
THAT'S WHAT THE THE CHAIR OF THE
SENATE -- AS
IS IS PROCEEDING WITH BUT I
THINK THEY'D BE I I I EXPECT
THEM TO MOVE EXPEDITIOUSLY OKAY
AND OF COURSE THERE ARE NONE
PROS TO THE TEST WHICH UP WHICH
I'LL GET TO BUT THAT THE CONS
ARE.
MY IT IN MINOR SITTING THERE
THERE ARE FOR THAT JUMP OUT --
ONE IS THAT --
OVER THE YEARS IT'S BEEN CULTURE
ON ROWING JOGGING I THOUGHT ON
AS TO YOU KNOW --
ROWING IS TO YOU KNOW WHATEVER
IN KIDS MAY NOT KNOW THAT THAT
TYPE OF ACTIVITY IN CERTAIN
NEIGHBORHOODS AND SO THEY THEY
THEY CHANGE THAT A BIT.
THE OTHER IS OF COURSE THAT SOME
KIDS DON'T HAVE THE MONEY TO PAY
FOR THAT THAT KAPLAN TEST PREP.
AND RESEARCH SHOWS IF YOU.
SPOKE ASSIGNED --
SPENDING A TON OF MONEY YOU CAN
BECOME A BETTER TEST TAKER TO
MAKE MORE INTELLIGENT ARE MORE
LIKELY TO SUCCEED THE UC --
PROBABLY NOT --
SO THAT'S THE THOSE ARE THE TWO
AND THEN THE THE TWO RECENT ONES
ARE JUST.
YOU KNOW OFF THE CHARTS AS FAR
AS YOU KNOW FRAUDULENT AND
SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW THERE'S
NO.
NO ROOM --
FOR THE YOU KNOW THE ABILITIES
AND JUST LIKE YOU CAN ON THE
BOARD COURSE MARIJUANA IS NOW
LEGAL BUT FIVE YEARS AGO YOU
WANTED.
THE MARIJUANA YOU GO TO A DOCTOR
AND THEY HAD A BAD BACK YOU GOT
A NOTE WITHIN OUR YOU WHAT YOU
PAID THE FEE AND THERE'S DOCTOR
SHOPPING FOR THIS.
DISABILITY --
EXEMPTION TO GET MORE TIME AND
THEN WHO HAS MONEY TO DO THAT
PEOPLE RESOURCES.
AND OF COURSE YOU KNOW PAYING
FOR INDIVIDUALS TO TAKE THE TEST
FOR IS THE FOURTH ONE WHICH IS
WRONG AND A CRIME AND PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO GET --
PUNISHED AS FAR AS THE PROS OF
IT -- I KNOW
THERE ARE THERE ARE THERE ARE.
IDEAS TO TO KEEP IT GOING I KNOW --
MISTER O'DONNELL IS TALKED ABOUT
YOU KNOW BRING THAT INTO THE
PUBLIC SCHOOL SET UP SYSTEMS SO
KIDS CAN BE TAKING TESTS WENT
OUT THIS TEST AND SO.
THAT'S AN IDEA IF WE DO KEEP
THIS TEST GOING FORWARD I I
THINK THAT --
MERIT SICK --
THE WITH THE ONE FOR THE YOU SEE
IN THIS IS REALLY REPORT THIS MY
LAST QUESTION HERE.
BUT BUT I WOULD THINK THAT FOR
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA ONE OF
THE OVER ARCHING ISSUES IS A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THOUSAND
APPLICATIONS THAT'S A LOT.
IT'S A BIG STACK OF PAPER.
AND IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT YOU
KNOW THREE THINGS THAT THE GPA.
THE THE TEST SCORES AND THE YOU
KNOW THE PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
BASED UPON YOUR ESSAY --
IT IS HARD TO RANK THOSE THE SAT
SCORE IN THERE SO IT IS THAT ONE
OF THE DRIVING REASONS WHICH
KEEPS THE S. A. T. ALIVE IS JUST
THE SHEER.
VOLUME OF APPLICATIONS THE UC
GETS AND HOW IT WOULD JUST
REALLY BE A LOGISTICAL HEADACHE
TO TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO SORT
THESE APPLICATIONS WITHOUT THAT.
WELL LET ME SAY ARE BY THE WAY --
WE HAVE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND APPLICANTS THAT'S EIGHT
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY APPLICATIONS
ACTION CELL SORTING THROUGH THAT
IS A CHALLENGE --
AND THE STATE EXPECTS US TO DO
THIS IN A WAY --
ARTIST THIS IS MY UNDERSTANDING
TO DO IT THIS IN A WAY TO HAS
ACADEMIC --
AT A INTEGRITY IN VALUE TO IT
AND THAT IS AS OBJECTIVE AS
POSSIBLE --
TO ARE RECOGNIZING THAT --
THAT THE STAKES OF THOSE
DECISIONS ARE QUITE MEANINGFUL
AND THAT WE DO HAVE DATA THAT
INDICATES THAT ACCESS. TO TO THE
UNIVERSITY INCLUDING THE BEST OF
THEM.
MATTERS --
UNIVERSITY ADMISSIONS DOESN'T
MATTER AND THE INTEGRITY WITH
WHICH THAT.
IS HAPPENS MATTERS AND SO TO
HAVE AN INDEPENDENT CHECK IS ONE
OF THE ARGUMENTS --
FOR FOR USING --
THE TEST BUT YOU ALSO ARE
OBVIOUSLY QUITE KNOWLEDGEABLE
ABOUT THIS --
THERE ARE CULTURAL AND
SOCIOECONOMIC FEATURES THAT ARE
ALSO LINKED TO THOSE TESTS WE
HAVE DATA THAT INDICATES THAT
THE SCORES ON THESE TESTS --
ARE THAT THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THINGS THAT AREN'T
RELATED TO TO ACHIEVE THINGS
LIKE OUR OUR STUDENTS FAMILY --
ECONOMIC BACKGROUND THEIR
EDUCATIONAL BACKGROUND THEIR
THEIR RACE --
IS INCREASING IN TERMS OF ITS
RELATIONSHIP TO SCORES ON THAT
TEST AND I THINK THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT AS WELL.
SO THESE THINGS ARE BEING
EXAMINED --
THEY ARE GOING TO GO THROUGH --
THIS THE THE THE SCRUTINY THAT I
BELIEVE THAT THE STATE EXPECTS
THE ACADEMIC SENATE TO TO EXERT.
AND AND AND THEN WE'LL GET A
REPORT I'LL GET A REPORT AND I
EXPECT --
AND THEY EXPECT TO THAT GIVEN
GIVEN THE THAT'LL THE LIKELY
ATTENTION TO HEAR AT THAT REPORT
WILL BE WELL CIRCULATED.
OKAY AT THANK YOU FOR ANSWERING
THAT THE QUESTION SO FAR YEAH
AND IN SOME AT I KNOW WE HAVE A
LOT OF INFORMATION THAT WE DON'T
KNOW YET.
SHEET THE UNIVERSITY --
ORKING WITH THAT SAID AND
LOOKING TO CHANCES QUESTIONS
FORGET WHAT HAPPENED BUT ALSO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE GO FORWARD AND
PREVENT THIS FROM HAPPENING
AGAIN.
PROTECT THE INTEGRITY OF THE
COLLEGE ADMISSIONS PROCESS.
THANK YOU ENTERTAIN OTHER
QUESTIONS MISTER O'DONNELL.
YES THANK YOU ARE IN EFFECT.
YOUR COMMENTS ARE MAKE THE CASE
FOR THE S. A. T. TO BE PART OF A
HIGH SCHOOL EXPERIENCE.
BECAUSE OF A WERE PART OF THE
HIGH SCHOOL EXPERIENCE LIKE I'M
CONTEMPLATING.
AND ALONG BEACH UNIFIED IS DOING
HOW MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
NOW ACROSS THE STATE WOULD
INSURERS IS THAT THERE'S
OVERSIGHT.
IF IT'S CONDUCTED AT THE HIGH
SCHOOL.
THERE'S COMPLIANCE THE EQUITY
PROVISIONS ARE FOLLOWED THE ID
PEAS.
ARE FOLLOWED AND ALSO THAT TEST
PREP OCCURS BECAUSE WITH THE S.
A. T. AS OPPOSED TO SOME LIKE
THE S. BACK AS THAT WHICH IS
THAT STATE REQUIRED TESTS.
YES PACKED THE ASPECT OF MY
PEERS RATHER FLOOD TOOL WITH THE
SAT IS MORE OF AN ASSESSMENT SO
WHAT DO I MEAN BY THAT YOU GIVE
THE THE PSA.
AND THE EIGHTH NINTH AND TENTH
GRADE THAT'S THE PRETEST RIGHT.
AND WHAT YOU CAN THEN DO.
IS IDENTIFY THE ACHIEVEMENT GAPS
ATTEMPT TO CLOSE THEM OVER THAT
INTERIM PERIOD BEFORE THE FINAL
TEST.
SO AGAIN I THINK GIVING AT THE
HIGH SCHOOL WOULD BE.
A MUCH MORE APPROPRIATE PLACE
TEST CENTERS THERE'S A LACK OF
CONTROL THERE THAT KIND OF THING
WE KNOW THAT WE'RE SEEING THAT
RIGHT NOW THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS WE'RE HERE --
SO AGAIN I I APPRECIATE THAT CAN
MAKES THE CASE THAT IT BE PART
OF THE HIGH SCHOOL EXPERIENCE
NOW LATER ON MIGHT WE GO TO A
DIFFERENT TEST SOME OTHER SOME
SOMETHING ELSE PROBABLY.
BUT I DON'T KNOW THAT WE WANT TO
JUST SPACE EVERY STUDENT.
ON THEIR HIGH SCHOOL ON THEIR
HIGH SCHOOL GRADE POINT AVERAGE
I THINK IT SHOULD BE MUCH
BROADER.
THAN THAT BECAUSE STUDENT
STUDENTS COME WITH DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCES SOME HAVE TO WORK.
SOME CAN'T GET THAT FOUR POINT
SEVEN GPA RIGHT AND SOME SCHOOLS
THE WAY THEIR MODEL MIGHT NOT
ALLOW THEM. TO GET THAT FOUR
POINT SEVEN GPA SO I THINK WE WE
REALLY OUGHT.
TO THINK I KNOW WHO WERE NOT YOU
KNOW THIS IS A POLITICAL MOMENT
WHETHER THIS IS A POLICY
QUESTION.
BEFORE IS THAT I I THINK WE NEED
TO DELVE INTO MUCH MUCH MORE
THOROUGHLY. TWENTY CLEAR WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A ONE TO THREE
CASES AT THE UC.
REALLY THE PEOPLE THAT OUGHT TO
BE UP HERE TODAY ARE FROM SOME
OF OUR OTHER NOTED UNIVERSITIES
ACROSS OUR STATE ACROSS OUR
NATION.
OKAY IT IS NOT LIKE THIS IS THE
THE UC HAS BEEN THE BIG ACTOR.
IN THIS SITUATION ALTHOUGH
YOU'RE LOOKING INTO A NICE AND
YOUR YOUR AUDIT I GUESS IS YOUR
FORMAL INVESTIGATION IS THAT
TRUE.
THERE WILL BE INVESTIGATIONS
INTO THE INDIVIDUAL --
INDIVIDUALS IDENTIFIED AS WELL
AS A SERIES OF AUDITS THAT WERE
IN THOSE THOSE WILL THOSE WILL
BE YOUR INVESTIGATION YES.
THAT THAT AUDIT IS YOUR
INVESTIGATION WILL DO AGAIN
THEY'LL BE INVESTIGATIONS AS TOO
SO.
THE KNOWN INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE
BEEN INVOLVED IN.
THOSE MATTERS WILL BE
INVESTIGATED.
BUT ON TOP OF THAT.
WE'LL BE LOOKING AT THE SYSTEMS
WILL BE LOOKING AT THE CHECKS
AND BALANCES WILL BE LOOKING AT
STRUCTURALLY HOW TO IMPROVE THE
PROCESS SEES. TO ENSURE THAT WE
CAN.
RAISE OUR RAISE THE BAR ON OUR
ADMISSIONS PROCESS AND AND MAKE
STRUCTURAL IMPROVEMENTS THAT
WILL. FOR CLOSE PEOPLE FROM TO
ENTER THAT RELATE THE
POSSIBILITY OF SIDE DOORS INTO
THE UNIVERSE YES. TO TAKE YOU
YOU'RE BASICALLY WHAT YOU'RE
DOING IS YOU'RE SEEKING TO
ENSURE THE INTEGRITY THAT'S
RIGHT HAVE YOUR ADMISSIONS
PROCESS.
WHICH I THINK IS A GOOD THING
AND I KNOW EVERYBODY --
STANDS FOR THE SAME THING TO BUT
AGAIN I JUST CAN'T HIGHLIGHTED
ENOUGH THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER.
UNIVERSITIES MISTER CHAIR THAT
OUGHT TO BE SITTING UP HERE
RIGHT NOW THOSE UNIVERSITIES
MANY OF THEM PROBABLY GET CAL
GRANT DOLLARS.
RIGHT SO THAT'S MAYBE SOMETHING
WE CAN LOOK INTO A GOING FORWARD
WE WE WILL LOOK BURKE WROTE HAVE
ANOTHER JOINT HEARING BUT TODAY
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT UNIVERSE
CALIFORNIA BUDGET.
OR TIME A LOT MORE THAN THAT
HERE YEAH WE THOUGHT WE HAD
QUESTIONS ABOUT OTHER
UNIVERSITIES.
TO WHICH WE CAN ANTI WITHOUT
YOUR THEY'RE NOT HERE RIGHT SO I
JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT IT WILL
IDENTITY I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT OUGHT TO BE PROJECT
FOR THEM THAT DON'T I JUST WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT THAT.
WE NEED TO DRAG A LOT OF OTHER
PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM AND ASK THEM
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MR TING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE
COMMENTS --
APPRECIATE UC'S VERY FORCEFUL
STATEMENT ABOUT THIS REALLY A
PORT ISSUE --
YOU YOU ALL KNOW HOW IMPORTANT
THE INTEGRITY OF THE ADMISSIONS
PROCESS IS TO EVERY UNIVERSITY
IT'S IT'S THE VALUE OF THE
DEGREE.
IT IS THE VALUE OF THE
INSTITUTION FOR WHATEVER REASON
THAT PROCESS IS SOLID IN ANY
PARTICULAR WAY COMPLETE TO VALUE.
THE INSTITUTION BUT THE VALUES
THE AGREED IN VALUES THE ENTIRE.
EXPERIENCE AS THE SON OF
IMMIGRANTS YOU KNOW I WAS ALWAYS
TOLD THAT WE HAD TO WORK HARD
BUT THAT IF WE WORKED HARD WE
STUDIED HARD WE COULD WE COULD
GET IT.
AND I THINK THAT --
THIS IS SENDING THE COMPLETELY
OPPOSITE MESSAGE THAT OBVIOUSLY --
WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
VERY STRONG STATEMENT ON I IN
FACT I WANT TO COMMEND YOU SEE
IN THIS PARTICULAR INSTANCE
BECAUSE ON ONE OF THE MOST
COMMON COMPLAINTS ABOUT.
YOU SEE WHETHER IT'S BERKELEY OR
UCLA OR ANY OF THAT ANY OF THE
UNIVERSITY IS HOW.
DIFFICULT IT IS FOR DONORS TO
GET THEIR KIDS INTO THOSE
COLLEGES.
I AND I KNOW SORT OF LIKE A A
RUNNING JOKE BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT
YOU HEAR ABOUT FROM THE VARIOUS
PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS I BELIEVE
MISTER -- MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LONG BEACH IS
SORT OF REFERRING.
TO IS A REALLY APPLAUD THE
UNIVERSITY UP FOR THAT I KNOW
IT'S CHALLENGING AT TIMES WERE
WE WE JUST HAD A VERY.
LONG DISCUSSION ABOUT ENROLLMENT
AND HOW COMPETITIVE ENROLLMENT
IS AND HOW DIFFICULT IT IS TO
GET IN AND I KNOW THAT IT'S EASY.
TO LOOK AT BENDING THOSE --
THOSE RULES THAT APPLY TO THE
UNIVERSITY FOR REALLY NOT GOING
DOWN THAT PATH AND AND NOT
BENDING THOSE RULES REALLY --
STAYING BY A VERY STRINGENT --
VERY CHALLENGING ADMISSIONS
ENROLLMENT PROCESS ON MY AND MY
QUESTION IS TO GO BACK TO JUST
THE CATEGORY --
THAT THE CHAIR WAS TALKING ABOUT
WHICH IS.
WHAT HOW HOW DO YOU CALL THAT
CATEGORY WHEN I WAS IN COLLEGE
IT WAS CALLED SPECIAL ACTION?
BUT WHAT WHAT'S IT CALLED NOW IN
A MISSION BY EXCEPTION ADMISSION
BY ACCEPTING COULD CAUSE SO
COULD YOU WALK THE COMMITTEE
THROUGH HOW.
HOW THAT EXCEPTION IS IS DONE?
HOW IS IT DIFFERENT FROM THE
TRADITIONAL ENROLLMENT --
DIGNITY MISSIONS PROCESS WHERE
YOU LOOK AT THE GRADES TEST
SCORES READ THE ESSAYS AND THEN.
THERE THERE'S SOME SCORE IN THIS
MARKET SEGMENT I DID BRING
ACTUALLY DID DIRECTOR OF OF
ADMISSION WONDERFUL GO TO
DETAILS --
DOCTOR HARM ME IAN WILL BUT YOU
WANT MORE DETAIL AND SHE SHE CAN
TELL.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON OR IT'S THE
MORNING I SUPPOSE --
SO ADMISSION BY EXCEPTION IS TO
USE FOR STUDENTS WHO DON'T MEET
OUR MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS FOR
ADMISSION SO ON THE SCHOLARSHIP
SIDE SO WHETHER THEY DIDN'T TAKE
THE RIGHT SAT BECAUSE YOU KNOW
WE HAVE THE S. A. T..
ON ITS OWN AND THEN THERE'S THE
OPTIONAL ESSAY WHICH WE REQUIRE
AS PART OF THEIR CURRENT
REQUIREMENTS FOR FRESHMAN
ADMISSION --
THAT TAKING THE FIFTEEN A THREE
G. WE FIND THAT STUDENTS --
MAY NOT DEPENDING ON WHERE THEY
GO TO SCHOOL MAY NOT HAVE A FULL.
ACCESS TO ALL THE A THROUGH G.
ESPECIALLY SOMETIMES IN THE
AREAS OF THE VISUAL AND
PERFORMING ARTS REQUIREMENT THAT
WE HAVE.
STUDENTS WHO ARE HOME SCHOOLED
AS WAS MENTIONED EARLIERSO
ANYONE WHO IS --
A CAMPUS IS WANTING TO ADMIT --
BUT DOESN'T QUITE MEET EVERY SEE
CAN'T CHECK OFF EVERY BOX FOR
OUR MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS WOULD
THEN BE SUBMITTED FOR REVIEW --
TO AND WHETHER TO COMMITTEE OR
OF OR SOME OTHER REVIEW BODY
DEPENDING ON THE CAMPUS IS THEN
LOOKING TO SEE --
WHETHER THEY HAVE IN OUR WHOLE
COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW.
IT IS MORE THAN THE THREE I
MENTIONED EARLIER GPA TEST
SCORES AND THE RESPONSES TO WHAT
WE CALL THE PERSONAL INSIGHT
QUESTIONS BUT FOURTEEN CRITERIA
ACTUALLY WHETHER IT'S SPECIAL
TALENTS OUR WHETHER THEY'RE
COMING FROM A RURAL AREA A PLACE
WHERE -- WE
ARE TRYING.
TO BRING MORE STUDENTS IN FROM
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OR A NUMBER
OF OTHER FACTORS THAT ARE
CONSIDERED IN ADMISSIONS IF THEY
MEET ALL OF THOSE AND THE CAMPUS
DOESN'T WANT TO OFFER.
A PLACE ON THE CAMPUS THEN THAT
STUDENT WOULD BE LABELED OR
PROVIDED ADMISSION BY EXCEPTION
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T MEET THAT
MINIMUM CRITERIA.
SO SO SO SOUNDS LIKE SOME OF THE
MAJOR CATEGORIES THAT WOULD
WOULD QUALIFY FOR ADMISSIONS BY
EXCEPTION OUR STUDENTS WHO ARE
NOT TRADITIONALLY YOU SEE
ELIGIBLE.
THAT SUCH SUITS ARE NOT
TRADITIONALLY USED ELIGIBLE WHO
MAYBE ATHLETES MAY BE HOME
SCHOOLED.
ME REPRESENTS AND GEOGRAPHIC
DIVERSITY HAS BEEN A MONTH MUCH
OF THAT.
CONCENTRATION MISSIONS HAPPENS
IN THE URBAN OR THOUGHT OR THAT
MORE COASTAL PART OF THE STATE.
SO IS THAT CORRECT IS THAT FAIR
I DO DONORS OR ALUMNI ARE AS AS
AT A CATEGORY WITHIN THAT
ADMISSIONS BY EXCEPTION.
NO IT IS NOT WE HAVE.
TO SO THE HEAD OF THE ALUMNI
ASSOCIATIONS CAN'T.
CAN'T CALL YOU OR CALL THE
DIFFERENT UNIVERSITIES AND SAY
HEY WE YOU KNOW WE HAVE THESE
FABULOUS.
BOOSTERS AND ALUMNI IN THE
SYSTEM THIS IS THAT THIS IS
SOMEONE THAT WE NEED YOU TO
ADMIT BY EXCEPTION.
ALL THEY CAN DO THAT BUT WE
WOULD NOT ADMIT ANYONE IF THEY
DONATED BUILDING OR WHAT IF THEY
YOU KNOW AND OUR CHAIR. TO MY
KNOWLEDGE THAT DOESN'T OCCUR.
IN -- HOW
CONFIDENT ARE YOU THAT THIS
ADMISSIONS THAT YOUR POLICIES AT
THE?
LEVEL IS BEING IMPLEMENTED AT
EACH OF THE TEN CAMPUS.
HOW DO HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU
WISH TO ASSURE THAT IS CURRENT
YEAH AT THIS TIME I'M FAIRLY
CONFIDENT --
AS PROPOSED BROWN HAD MENTIONED
THAT THE POLICY DOES ALLOW FOR
UP 26% OF THE ENROLLED CLASS AND
OUR CAMPUSES ARE SHOWING THAT
THEY ARE ACTUALLY ADMITTING IN
ROLLING FAR LESS THAN --
THAT CLOSER 2122% DEPENDING ON
THE CAMPUS AND THE AUDIT THAT
WILL BE UNDERGONE WALSH.
HOPEFULLY --
WHY IS IT WHY IS IT SO LOW I
MEAN YOU YOU THAT THIS IS A KID
THIS IS AN AREA WHERE THE
CAMPUSES HAVE --
SURMOUNT DISCRETION WHY IS IT
ONLY 2% YOU THINK VERSUS SIX
BECAUSE THE DEMAND FOR THE
STUDENTS WHO ARE ACTUALLY
ELIGIBLE IS SO HIGH.
SO SO YOU COULD BASICALLY FILL
UP YOUR ENTIRE CLASS WITH --
ALL YOU SEE ELIGIBLE STUDENTS SO
IT'S YOU KNOW YOU REALLY HAVE TO
HAVE SOMETHING FAIRLY
EXTRAORDINARY TO BE ADMITTED BY
EXCEPTION ACT.
THAT'S CORRECT OKAY SO --
GOING TO CALL BACK TO MISTER
BUSTAMANTE IN TERMS OF YOUR
AUDIT CAN YOU CAN JUST KIND OF
THE GIVE US THE THE SCOPE HOW
HOW BROAD THAT ON IT WILL TERMS
OF UNDERGRADUATE MISSIONS OR ARE
YOU ALSO INCLUDING UCSF AS PART
OF THIS.
WE'LL BE LOOKING AT ALL THE
CAMPUSES I WILL BE LOOKING AT
BOTH THE CAMPUS SIDE AS WELL AS
THE ATHLETIC SIDE TO EXAMINE
WHAT THE PROCESSES ARE.
WILL BE IS PROBABLY TO WEAR
RIGHT NOW --
DESIGNING DESIGNING THE AUDIT
AND WHAT OUR APPROACH IS GOING
TO BE.
FOR MAPPING OUT THE EXISTING
PROCESS SEASON LOOKING AT THE
POLICIES AND PROTOCOLS THE OTHER
ITEMS THAT ARE IN PLACE TO
IDENTIFY THE HIGH RISK AREAS.
CLEARLY THE EXCEPTION AREA WOULD
BE ONE THAT WE WITH A FOCUS IN
ON BUT TO THE EXTENT THAT WE
IDENTIFY ANYTHING ELSE AS WE MAP
OUT THE PROCESS SEES IT EACH OF
THE CAMPUSES.
WE WILL UNDOUBTEDLY FIND OTHER
AREAS THAT WE THINK ARE WORTHY
OF AUDIT.
AND AS THE INDEPENDENT A FORM.
OF FOR THE REGION'S IMAGE AND IN
THE CAPACITY TO VERIFY WHAT IS
ACTUALLY UNDERGOING.
WE WILL LOOK AT THE HERE THE
OPERATION SIDE AND HOW THEY
ACTUALLY PERFORM SOME OF THOSE
SPOT CHECKS. TO SEE IF THOSE
BEING DONE IN THE WAY AS
DESCRIBED IN INTENDED BY POLICY.
THE WILL NOT BE CONFINING OUR
ANALYSIS TO JUST THAT SO IF WE
SEE THINGS THAT COME UP.
WE WILL BE --
DRILLING DOWN ON THOSE
ACCORDINGLY --
AND THAT WOULD YOU DESPITE THOSE
WHEN WE MATH OUT THE EXISTING
PROCESS SEES IDENTIFY POTENTIAL
STRUCTURAL ISSUES FOR OTHER
ISSUES THAT --
MAY PERCENT SOME MANAGEMENT
CORRECTIVE ACTIONS.
I'M HOPEFUL THAT THAT'LL BE DONE
IN THE FIRST COUPLE MONTHSGREAT.
AND MIKE MY COLLEAGUE --
FROM LONG BEACH SORT OF ALLUDED
TO THIS BUT IF --
IF IF IT.
NHIáU YOUR INSTITUTIONS THAT
RECEIVE CAL GRANT.
WERE FORBIDDEN TO GIVE
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT --
TO DONORS AND ALUMNI THAT THAT
SOUNDS LIKE IT DOESN'T IT WOULD
NOT IMPACT THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA IS OUT OF IS THAT A
FAIR STATEMENT --
AND THEN --
JUST JUST LAST I'M JUST AGAIN
URGE IS IT SEEMS LIKE --
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF ARE
PURPOSELY VERY THOUGHTFULLY HAS
KEPT THIS CATEGORY
EXTRAORDINARILY SMALL GIVEN THE
EVEN EVEN DESPITE THE HUGE
DEMAND FOR ACCESS TO TO ALL YOUR
ELITE INSTITUTIONS.
A REALLY WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO
STAY THE COURSE APPRECIATE THE
VERY AGGRESSIVE ACTION --
I GUESS SORRY MY LAST QUESTION --
I FORGOT TO ASK EARLIER IS --
IN REGARDS TO THE THERE ARE
CURRENTLY ENROLLED FOR RECEIVED
IT TOO GREEDY --
UNDER THESE FALSE PRETENSES WHAT
IS THE ACTION THAT WILL BE TAKEN --
WE'LL WE'LL HAVE TO REVIEW THAT
ARE.
THIS IS THIS WAS SOMETHING THAT
WE ARE THINKING ABOUT --
WOULD BE ENGAGE OUR WITH THAT
WITH THE CHANCES AND THE
ACADEMIC SENATE ON THOSE ISSUES --
WE'RE WE'RE STILL KIND OF AS IN
AIDING TO THE PROPER --
WHEN WE IDENTIFY BUT WE HAVE TO
ANTICIPATE WHAT WE DO ABOUT THAT
AND I CAN TELL YOU AT LEAST
RIGHT NOW?
MOUTH ABOUT ABOUT THAT KIND OF
SITUATION SO.
SO AT SIZE A AS A FORMER
BERKELEY LET MY HATE TO EVER YOU
STANFORD AS AN EXAMPLE --
I'M I'M GONNA GO THERE TODAY
BECAUSE IN CONVERSATION --
ROLE --
IT'LL A CONVERSATION I I COME TO
UNDERSTAND THAT SOMETHING.
SIMILAR HAD JUST HAD A AND A
STANFORD --
TO STAND FOR STUDENTS AND THAT
AGAIN THE THE WORD MINUTE UNDER
FALSE PRETENSES.
ON THAT THEIR DEGREE WAS REVOKED
AND SO I THINK THAT THAT WOULD
SEEM TO BE THE APPROPRIATE
ACTION FOR ANYBODY WHO'S
COMPLETED THEIR DEGREE AND I
WOULD REALLY URGE.
THE THE UNIVERSITY TO EXPEL THE
CURRENT STUDENTS WHO ARE.
CURRENTLY IN ENROLLMENT AND AS
WELL AS TO RESCIND THE DEGREES I
THINK -- I
WOULD HOPE THAT THAT DECISION
COMES VERY SWIFTLY AND VERY
QUICKLY.
SO THAT THERE CAN BE A VERY
STRONG DISINCENTIVE BIT BECAUSE
AGAIN.
IF IF YOU CAN CHEAT THE SYSTEM
AND GET YOUR DEGREE.
NO ONE'S GONNA NO ONE'S GONNA
KNOW ON THEIR RESUME THAT
[inaudible]
THIS DEGREES.
NOT VALID OR THAT THE GREEDY --
FOR WHATEVER REASON THEIR YOU
KNOW THEIR PARENTS WERE.
SORT OF INDICATED IN THIS
SCANDAL LESS THEY THEY DO SOME
DEEPER RESEARCH I THINK THE
UNIVERSITY HAS TO TAKE SOME
EXTRAORDINARILY STRONG ACTION.
ON TO EXPEL EXPELLED THE
STUDENTS TO ROUTE YOU KNOW TAKE
BACK THOSE DEGREES BECAUSE
OTHERWISE --
WHAT'S WHAT IS THE DISINCENTIVE
FOR DOING THIS CHEATING FRAUD
DECEIT SHOULD NOT BE REWARDED
ABSOLUTE AND AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WHATEVER THAT ALL
THE CAMPUSES ARE HARMONIZED
TURNED TO HOW THEY DO.
SO SO HOUSE HOW SOON CAN WE
EXPECT SOME SORT OF ANNOUNCEMENT
REGARDING WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
WITH WITH THE STUDENTS THAT WE
DO ARE AWARE OF WELL I'M A PART
OF PART OF IT.
IT DEPENDS ON A LOT OF THESE
INVESTIGATIONS ARE TAKING PLACE
WE DO KNOW THAT THE CAMPUS IS
THEMSELVES.
INDEPENDENT OF WHAT ALEX'S.
THE CAMPUS IS THEMSELVES ARE
DOING THEIR OWN --
REFUSE -- TO
AND WE DON'T KNOW WHAT WILL BE
ON COVER --
OUR AND SO RIGHT NOW WHAT WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO DO.
AND YOUR QUESTION ACTUALLY
SUGGESTS THIS THAT WE ACTUALLY
ANTICIPATE WHAT WE MIGHT FINE.
AND THEN I AND ANY WE MAY NOT
FIND BUT IF WE DO WHAT IS THE
APPROPRIATE COURSE OF THAT BUT
YOU HAVE A THE STUDENT A
GRADUATE FROM BERKELEY THE EXACT
I BELIEVE YOU HAVE TO SEE SO YOU
DO HAVE.
THREE INDIVIDUALS I DON'T KNOW
THE NATURE OF THE WRONGDOING
ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE
INDIVIDUALS I NOTE THOSE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE BEEN IMPLICATED
I KNOW THEY ARE SUBJECT. TO TO
INVESTIGATE OF PROCESS THESE --
AND SO IT'S IT'S HARD TO ADDRESS
THOSE INDIVIDUALS BUT WHAT WE
CAN DO.
AS OUR ADDRESS LISTED
CIRCUMSTANCE OF IF IT WERE TO BE
FOUND THAT SUCH INDIVIDUALS
WHETHER IT'S THEM AS SOMEBODY --
GOT THEIR DEGREE THROUGH FROST --
INFORMATION WHAT IS OUR RESPONSE
SEP SO HOW SOON DO YOU
ANTICIPATE FINISHING THIS
INVESTIGATION REGARDING THE
THREE STUDENTS THAT HAVE BEEN IN
THE PRESS.
I WISH I COULD GIVE YOU AN
ANSWER TO THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
VARIABLES RIGHT NOW I THINK
WE'VE REACHED REACHING OUT TO
THE DEPARTMENT JUSTICE NAPPY I
TRY TO GET ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION.
SURE PROBABLY WHERE SOME OF THE
INFORMATION THAT --
IS GERMANE TO THESE ISSUES ARE
OUTSIDE OF THE UNIVERSITY'S
CONTROL TO TRYING TO GET
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION AND
TRYING.
IMPORTANTLY TO FIND IF THERE ARE
OTHER PEOPLE THAT WE SHOULD BE
FOCUSING ON IS A PRIORITY OF
MINE.
SO UNTIL I'M ABLE TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT WE'RE ABLE TO GET.
AND WE COOPERATE WITH THE THE
THE FOR PROCRASTINATION IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
I'M GOING TO BE THIS COULD BE
DIFFICULT FOR ME TO GIVE YOU
WELL IT'S A HOPE BROUGHT THE TO
HAVE THIS AT LEAST HAVE SOME
RESOLUTION THE NEXT FEW MONTHS
OR DO YOU THINK IT'S GONNA TAKE
LONGER THAN THAT.
THIS IS A PRIORITY FOR MY OFFICE
THIS IS --
I'LL BE HANDLING THE
INVESTIGATION TO SUPERVISION OF
THEM PERSONALLY SO THIS IS A
PRIORITY MY NUMBER ONE PRIORITY
SO I WANT TO GET THIS DONE AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. FOR ALL THE
REASONS THAT YOU STATED.
I ALSO WANT TO IDENTIFY IF THERE
ARE OTHER INDIVIDUALS THAT WE'D
LOOK AT FOR IT AGAIN THE REASON
SUGGESTED AS WELL SO THAT WE CAN.
GET TO THE BOTTOM THIS AND HAVE
AN APPROPRIATE RESPONSE HAVE
THAT DISINCENTIVE ISIS PEOPLE
FOR TAKING THIS TACTIC.
SO SO WE I MEAN WE HAVE A BUDGET
DEADLINE JUNE FIFTEENTH DO YOU
ANTICIPATE THAT YOU'LL BE DONE
WITH YOUR INVESTIGATION BY THEN.
I BE AGAIN RE MISTER I BE
DIFFICULT FOR ME TO GIVE AN
ANSWER BUT I'M HAPPY TO COME
BACK AND GIVE UPDATES I'D BE
HAPPY.
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ALONG
THE WAY AS WE GO AS APPROPRIATE --
BUT RIGHT NOW TO BE VERY
DIFFICULT TO GET FROM YOU A
HEART STOP AND SEE WHEN WE'RE
GOING TO BE COMPLETED THERE'S
TOO MANY VARIABLES OUTSIDE OF MY
CONTROL.
APPRECIATE JUST URGE --
IN A U. G. SECTION OF OUR PARTY
REALLY HOPE THAT GETS TREATED
TREATED AS SUCH AND THAT THESE.
YOU KNOW THREE INDIVIDUALS ARE
RIGHTLY OR WRONGLY GET GET YOU
KNOW ON OTHER EXONERATED OR
BROUGHT TO JUSTICE.
THE SECOND.
THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA GO TO
MISTER MEDINA AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LIMON AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER.
I WANT TO SAY THAT AS A PARENT
AS A TEACHER I THINK --
REGULAR HARD WORKING PEOPLE.
HAVE PERHAPS A NAIVE
[inaudible]
BELIEF.
THAT THE SYSTEM WE CAN CALL IT
THAT WILL TREAT THEM FAIRLY
THANKS.
FOR BUT WHAT WE'VE SEEN HERE
WITH PARENTS WHO HAVE --
EXCEEDINGLY MORE AMOUNT OF MONEY
[inaudible]
RESOURCES --
EVEN TIME.
ARE ABLE TO MANEUVER THE SYSTEM.
LOOK FOR THE VULNERABLE
ABILITIES OF THAT SYSTEM.
AND AND LEVERAGE THEIR POWER.
IN A WAY THAT IS COMPLETELY --
INEQUITABLE WITH THE IDEA I
THINK WHAT EVERYONE EXPECTS.
AND I THINK THE CHAIRMAN MCCARTY
THE FROM THE OUTSET WAS ABLE TO
PINPOINT ONE VULNERABILITY.
AND THAT WAS THE ONE WITH THE
SPORTS AND I THINK THAT WAS VERY
CLEAR IN THE NEWS STORIES.
THAT JUST BY SAYING YOU KNOW MY
SON MY DAUGHTER --
IS A ROLL OR IS A WATER PULL AND
THEN PROVIDE THE PICTURE --
THAT THE SOCCER COACH AT UCLA
WAS ABLE JUST BY HIMSELF --
TO ADMIT THAT STUDENT SO.
FOLKS WITH SO MUCH MONEY SO MUCH
TIME.
ABLE TO LOOK --
FOR YOU KNOW WHERE OF THOSE
POINTS WHERE THOSE POINTS WHERE
THEY CAN --
CHEAT --
ANSWER TO GAME THE SYSTEM BUT I
THINK THAT THAT SPORTS --
EXAMPLE IS WHEN THAT SHOULD BE
EASILY FIXED.
RIGHT BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE NO
ONE WAS LOOKING TO SEE A TO
FOLLOW UP --
WAS THAT --
YOUNG MAN YOUNG.
WOMAN ACTUALLY PLANE AFTER
THEY'D BEEN ACCEPTED.
EVEN SOMETIMES WITHOUT EVEN
KNOWLEDGE OF THE KIDS THEMSELVES
FOR RIDE THE THE YOUNG PERSON AT
USC WHO WAS ADMITTED IN THE
COUNSELOR ASTON --
IF THE I I UNDERSTAND YOU DO
WELL IN TRACK AND THE YOUNG MAN
EXT YOU KNOW RESPONDED NO I
DON'T RUN TRACK --
SO THAT THAT SHOULD BE EASILY
FIXED WITH MORE --
SUPERVISION --
BUT AGAIN IT GOES BACK TO A
SYSTEM THAT PERHAPS IS BROKEN
[inaudible]
OF THAT.
I I THINK ONE REDEEMING THING IS
IS -- PRO
WAS BROWN POINTED OUT THE NEWS
STORIES THAT HAVE COME OUT SINCE
THEN OF ALL THOSE HARD WORKING
KIDS.
OTHERS HARDWORKING KIDS WHO COME
FROM SCHOOLS OF LESSER MEANS.
OF WHO DON'T HAVE ALL THE
ADVANTAGES THAT THESE OTHER
FOLKS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO TO USE.
CONTINUE CONTINUE TO WORK HARD
CONTINUE TO DO WHAT YOU KNOW
WE'VE ASKED THEM TO DO.
AND HOPEFULLY MOVING FORWARD WE
CAN FIND A SYSTEM THAT IS NOT.
A SO EASILY --
GAME.
AND SO THAT THAT.
YOU KNOW MAYBE I CONTINUE IN MY
NAIVE HOPE THAT PEOPLE THAT HAVE
SO MANY RESOURCES --
WON'T HAVE SO MANY MORE
ADVANTAGES IN ACCESSING WHAT WE
SAY IS ESSENTIAL FOR SUCCESS IN
THIS COUNTRY.
AS MISTER CHANG I THINK ALLUDED
TO A COMING FROM F. EMIGRANT
PARENTS YOU KNOW THERE ARE.
IF PERHAPS MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
WHO CAME YOU KNOW WITH THE
BELIEVE THAT IN THIS COUNTRY YOU
CAN PROGRESS BE BY YOUR OWN
MERIT BY YOUR OWN HARD WORK.
I THINK IN THE LAST FEW DAYS
WE'VE HAD.
LOOKING AT THE DISCUSSION AGAIN
ABOUT AFFIRMATIVE ACTION.
AND I I WOULD SAY EVEN AT THE
POINT WHERE I WAS ADMITTED TO
COLLEGE.
GOING BACK TO THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES.
AND PEOPLE POINTING TO JOSE
MEDINA.
PERHAPS GOD AND IT UNFAIR
ADVANTAGE BECAUSE HIS NAME WAS
JOSE MEDINA.
AND THAT WE REALLY DIDN'T BELONG.
IN THAT INSTITUTION BECAUSE IT
YOUR SKIN.
WERE THAT WE WEREN'T CAPABLE OF
DOING THE WORK THE ACADEMIC WORK
WELL WE'VE SORT OF NOW TURNED IT.
UPSIDE DOWN.
YOU KNOW AND NOW WE ARE SEEING
THOSE WITH SO MUCH INFLUENCE SO
MUCH.
BEING THE FOLKS WHO ARE BEING AN
ADMITTEDLY.
WRONG ADMITTED INTO UNIVERSITIES
FOR THE WRONG REASONS.
AND MAYBE WE SHOULD LOOK BACK.
AT THOSE POLICIES THAT ALLOWED.
MORE PEOPLE FROM UNREPRESENTED
MINORITIESUNREPRESENTED
POPULATIONS TO BE THERE BECAUSE
THEY ARE THE ONES WHO CONTINUE
TO WORK HARD.
EVERY DAY DO WHAT WE'VE ASKED
THEM TO DO WITH NOT THE BENEFIT
OF SAT PREP SAYS.
SOMEONE TO HELP THEM RIGHT THERE
SA.
WITH NO BEAU TEA --
COUNSELING SERVICE BUT HAVE TO
RELY ON THEIR HIGH SCHOOL
COUNSELOR WHO LOOKS AT FOUR
THOUSAND STUDENTS.
AND HAS MAYBE TWICE. TWO TIMES
IN THE YEAR A MEETING WITH THAT
STUDENT.
AND THEY'RE NOT PAYING THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS TO GET ADVICE.
FROM YOU KNOW BECAUSE THEIR
PARENTS DON'T HAVE THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS TO PAY.
SO I HOPE THAT PERHAPS.
WE CAN USE WHAT IS HAPPENED HERE
TO RE LOOK AT THE SYSTEM THAT WE
USE TO EVALUATE OUR STUDENTS.
AND I CAN ONLY HOPE BECAUSE
WITHOUT IT.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE A LOT OF VERY --
DISSATISFIED AND YOU WILL NOT
HAVE WHITE WHY SHOULD YOU WORK
HARD IF THE ONLY WAY. TO TO MOVE
FORWARD IS BY.
DOING SOMETHING THAT IS IS NOT
RIGHT.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER SOMEONE
MEMBER LIMóN THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION.
I ALSO --
REFLECT A LOT ON MY EXPERIENCE
AND PARTNERING WITH ADMISSIONS
OFFICE AND I WANT TO ACTUALLY
START OFF BY THINKING EVERY
SINGLE ADMISSIONS OFFICER OUT
THERE.
BECAUSE WHAT IS NOT ALSO BEING
INCLUDING THIS CONVERSATION IS
HOW MANY DISCREPANCIES THEY DO
CATCH AHEAD OF THE GAME --
ONE OF MY DEAREST FRIENDS WERE
AND I KNOW THE COUNTLESS HOURS
THEY SPEND REVIEWING THOSE
APPLICATIONS TO TRY TO CATCH IN
DISCREPANCIES THINGS THAT DON'T
MATCH WITH.
TRANSCRIPTS WITH RECORDS AND TO
ENSURE THAT THE PROCESS
MAINTAINS ITS INTEGRITY I THINK --
AS I'VE HEARD DESCRIBED THAT
THERE IS --
MULTIPLE PROCESSES FOR
ADMISSIONS.
MY CONCERN IS NOT SO MUCH AT
WITH THE EXCEPTIONAL EGGMAN
MISSIONS TO EXCEPTION BECAUSE
YOU'RE STILL REQUIRED TO BE
TRUTHFUL.
IN THAT PROCESS --
AND CERTAINLY THERE ARE PEOPLE
WHO GO TO SCHOOL WITHOUT GREAT I
MEAN THAT'S JUST THE REALITY OF
OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM AND THE
CHOICE THAT'S OUT THERE --
SO I I HOPE THAT TO ADD.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO EXPLORE I DO
WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE THAT OF THE
LIMITED INFORMATION WE KNOW SAYS
FAR -- IT IS
NOT OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEMS --
THAT RAISE THE GREATEST CONCERN
AT THE MOMENT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT IS OUR PRIVATE
SCHOOL SYSTEMS --
AND I A I WELCOME THE
CONVERSATION IN THE HEARINGS
THAT WILL COME FORWARD.
AND THERE'S ALSO A GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS.
IN OUR STATE THAT HAVE WORKED
REALLY HARD TO MAINTAIN THE
INTEGRITY IN ADDITION --
TO THE ADMISSIONS OFFICERS OF
EVERY SINGLE CAMPUS AND THOSE
ARE OUR STUDENTS.
I CAME FROM STUDENT IN THE
THAT'S WHERE I GOT MY FEET WET
WITH ORGANIZING.
AND TO THINK OF EVERY PERSON OUT
THERE THAT BENEFITTED FROM FREE
VOLUNTEER SERVICES ON HOW TO
BEAT THE BEEF UP.
AN APPLICATION WHERE TO GET
SCHOLARSHIPS FOR OR WAIVERS OF
SORTS FOR THE SAT AND ACT EASE
WHO VOLUNTEERED TO READ
ADMISSIONS ESSAYS AND EDIT THEM
TO PROVIDE FEEDBACK.
I THINK IS ANOTHER EQUATION TO
THE STORY AND IT'S BASED ON ONE
OF I BELIEVE OUR STATE IN
COUNTRIES FUNDAMENTAL VALUES
THAT EVERYONE HAS AN EQUAL SHOT
AND WILL HAVE EQUAL ACCESS TO IT.
SO I HOPE THAT.
WE WILL MAINTAIN THOSE IT SOUNDS
FROM EVERYTHING THAT'S BEEN SAID
THAT WE WILL I THINK YOU DO THE
UC FOR NOT BEING SCARED TO
ADDRESS IT FOR BEING THE FIRST
TO BE UP FRONT --
WE KNOW IN THE STATE LEGISLATURE
THAT -- WHEN
ONE PERSON VIOLATES A POLICY OR
A LIGHT IS NOT REPRESENTATIVE OF
THE ENTIRE LEGISLATURE --
AND I THINK THAT THAT'S THE SAME --
FOR THE UC --
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO ANY
OUTCOMES THAT.
THE REPORT HAS SIMPLY TO LEARN.
TO LEARN IF THERE'S FLAWS THAT
CAN BE ADDRESS REALLY BE A ONE
PERSON DID SOMETHING WRONG
SITUATION BUT IT WOULD BE GOOD
TO KNOW THAT AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GALLAGHER.
YES -- I AND
I THINK THISTEAM HAS BEEN HIT A
LOT BUT YOU KNOW WHAT'S REALLY
AT RISK HERE IS YOU KNOW.
WE CAN'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT THE
FACT THAT SOME PEOPLE HAVE MORE
RESOURCES INTO THIS THAT THAT
THE WEALTHY YOU KNOW.
HAVE ACCESS TO YOU KNOW MORE
RESOURCE OPPORTUNITIES MAYBE OF
HIRING SOMEONE TO HELP THEM.
HE GET INTO SCHOOL THAT SOME
DISTRICTS ARE WEALTHIER SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE WEALTHIER THAN
OTHERS --
BUT WHAT'S AT RISK HERE IS IT AT
THE UC ADMISSIONS LEVEL IT
SHOULD ALWAYS BE ABOUT
MERITOCRACY YOU KNOW THAT NO
MATTER WHERE YOU CAME FROM.
NO MATTER WHAT.
YOU KNOW DISADVANTAGES YOU MIGHT
HAVE YOU'VE GOT A SHOT. TO GET
INTO THE SYSTEM YOU KNOW SOMEONE
LIKE MYSELF WHO CAME FROM A VERY
RURAL AREA WHO DIDN'T COME FROM
A WEALTHY SCHOOL DISTRICT.
HERE WHO IS A SECOND GENERATION --
YOU KNOW CALL JOB CAN'T BUT
COULD MAKE THAT.
YOU KNOW AND GET INTO ONE OF THE
TOP SCHOOLS OF AND I KNOW THAT'S
THE CASE FOR SO MANY OF MY
FELLOW STUDENTS WHO WENT THROUGH
THERE THAT THAT OPPORTUNITY WAS
THERE.
AND THIS IS UNDERMINED AS MY
COLLEAGUE JOSE MEDINA JUST
POINTED OUT --
WHEN IT LOOKS LIKE?
THAT MONEY COULD HAVE PLAYED THE
FACTOR THAT WEALTH ACTUALLY DID
IMPACT.
OF THAT DECISION AT THE
ADMISSIONS LEVEL.
YOU KNOW --
AND SO.
YOU KNOW WHAT I WOULD SAY IS YOU
KNOW I'VE I'VE WHAT I'VE HEARD A
LOT OF IS NOT TO MY KNOWLEDGE OR
NOT TO MY KNOWLEDGE OR WE'RE NOT
AWARE OF ANY OF THAT HAPPENING
BUT WHAT I WANT TO KNOW IS WHAT
PROCEDURES DO YOU HAVE IN PLACE.
SO WHEN YOU SAY WE DON'T KNOW
THAT A DONOR.
A DONATION TO THE UNIVERSITY DID
AFFECTED IMPACT DECISION.
WHAT PROCEDURE DO YOU HAVE IN
PLACE FOR EXAMPLE TO TRACK A
DONATION?
LET'S MADE FROM ALUMNI OR FROM
THE FROM A FAMILY DONOR AND TO
MAKE SURE THAT'S NOT INFLUENCE
SCENE.
THE ADMISSION.
OF MAYBE SOMEONE THAT'S RELATED
TO THEM OR SOMEONE THAT IS THEIR
SON OR DAUGHTER.
WHAT WHAT WHAT PROCEDURES DO WE
HAVE IN PLACE TO MAKE SURE THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN?
ARE ACTUALLY ARE.
I I WILL BE DEFERRED TO MY MY
COLLEAGUE WHO RUNS A MISSION BUT
I DO WANT TO SAY I HAVEN'T
CHAIRED --
THE LOCAL CAMPUS THE MISSION IT
USEDTO BE AN ONGOING
FRUSTRATION THAT --
THAT THAT FOLKS OF BEINGS COULD
NOT GET.
COULD NOT PENETRATE.
REVISIONS OFFICE AND BE ABLE TO
TALK TO ADMISSIONS PERSONNEL
THAT MAKE ADMISSIONS DECISIONS
WE ACTUALLY TRY TO PROTECT THAT
PROCESS.
FROM EXTERNAL OF FORCES --
AND AND AND AND THE PRESSURES OF
EMIGRATE BECAUSE ACCESS TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IS SO
PRECIOUS BUT IT'S ALSO VERY
PURCHASE THAT THAT PROCESS BE
VERY WELL PROTECTED.
SO THAT EVERYBODY HASFAITH IN
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE PROCEDURES
THAT'S HOW AND BECAUSE WE CAN
ALL SAY --
IT DOESN'T HAPPEN AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THIS IS PRECIOUS AND
ALL THAT BUT WHAT DO YOU HAVE IN
PLACE TO MAKE SURE.
IT DOESN'T HAPPEN THAT'S WHAT I
WANT TO NOW.
ANSWER WE THAT IS ONE OF THINGS
AND I'LL BE RESPONSIBLE LOOKING
AT IS EXAMINING THE PROCEDURES.
FOR OF MANY OF MORE WHAT DO YOU
HAVE TODAY THOUGH I MEAN.
I KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO EXAMINE
IT BUT YOU SHOULD BE A THIS IS
WE HAVE FACULTY THAT ACTUALLY
REVIEW.
THE ADMISSIONS PROCESSES AND HOW
THEIR CONDUCT --
THAT'S ONGOING THOSE COMMITTEES
MEET.
REGULARLY --
WE HAVE A PROCESS WHERE --
TO ASK ME I WANT TO SAY THAT WE
WANT THE IF I DON'T WANT WE
DON'T WANT TO PREJUDICE THE
INVESTIGATION --
BUT I WANT TO SAY --
THAT OUT WE MAKE SURE THAT FOR
MOST OF OUR PROCESSES AND ALL
THE PRICES THAT I KNOW ABOUT AND
I HAVE BEEN KNEE DEEP IN
ADMISSIONS.
NO INDIVIDUAL NO SINGLE
INDIVIDUAL IS ABLE TO PULL THE
TRIGGER ON THE DECISION THAT
GOES THROUGH VETTING INTERNAL TO
THE TO THE ODD TO THE ADMISSIONS
OFFICE --
AND THAT PERSON IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR THAT I COULD TELL YOU THAT
I'VE TALKED TO THE INDIVIDUAL
CHANCELLOR'S WHO ACTUALLY BY
POLICY HAVE A ROLE WITH RESPECT
IT MATCHES BY EXCEPTION. TO A
PERSON THEY SAID WE DON'T
ACTUALLY REACHED.
HI HAD COME OUT YOU ABOUT --
BUT WE WANT THE PROCESS TO
REVEAL BOTH --
WHERE IT'S WORKING WELL WHERE
THEY MIGHT BE VULNERABILITIES
AND WHERE IT MAY NOT BE WORKING
WELL WE DON'T WANT TO PREACH THE --
PRESUPPOSE THAT WE DON'T FIND
SOME WARTS AND FLAWS AND WE WANT
TO BE TRANSPARENT ABOUT BACK.
TO RIGHT.
SO THOSE ARE SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT I CAN TELL YOU BUT I CAN
TELL YOU SYSTEM WIDE --
THE ADMISSIONS DIRECTORS AND THE
THE FACULTY WHO CHAIR THOSE LOW
CAMPUSES COMMITTEES MEET
REGULARLY TO REVIEW --
POLICIES AND POLICY COMPLIANCE --
AND THEY HAVE TO GIVE ACCOUNT
NOT ONLY TO THE PRESIDENT BUT
ULTIMATELY TO THE BOARD OF
REGENTS AS WELL --
FOR THE INTEGRITY OF OUR PROCESS
IS SO WE ALL HAVE A STATE THAT
THIS IS RUN WELL.
GOOD YOU WERE GONNA SO SO I JUST
WANTED TO POINT OUT THAT WHAT WE
DO HAVE PROCEDURES AND PROCESSES
FOR STUDENTS WITH SPECIAL TALENT
WHETHER IT BE ATHLETICS OR IN
THE VISUAL PERFORMING ARTS AREA
THEATERS AND SUCH --
THERE'S A PROCESS FOR FACULTY OR
IN THIS AT FOR ATHLETICS COACHES
TO MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
ADMISSIONS FOR THE STUDENTS
THERE IS NO PROCESS FOR THE
ALUMNI OFFICE OR DEVELOPMENT
OFFICE TO MAKE ANY SORT OF
RECOMMENDATION.
OKAY ABOUT ONE LET'S GO TO THAT
ON SPORTS I MEAN IS THERE ANY
PROCESS THAT ACTUALLY CHECKS.
WE'RE SAYING HEY THIS IS A
PERSON.
YOU KNOW THAT'S AN ATHLETE IS
GONNA ADD DOES ANYBODY CHECK TO
ACTUALLY SEE IF THAT PERSON'S
ACTUALLY PLAYING THE SPORT AT
THE HIGH SCHOOL --
THAT THEY'RE THEY'RE COMING FROM.
WELL I THINK THAT THAT'S PART OF
THE INVESTIGATION THAT ALEX WILL
BE UNDERTAKING BUT THE
ADMISSIONS OFFICERS RELATE RELY
ON THE RECOMMENDATION OF THE
EXPERTS.
WHETHER IT'S FOR US AS SOON AS
CASE THE CODE.
RIGHT OKAY WELL THAT'S A PROBLEM.
THAT'S A PROBLEM IT MAY BE.
WELL I MEAN THAT'S NOT I MEAN I
KNOW YOU'RE GONNA DO AN
INVESTIGATION WE ALL LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT BUT AT THE SAME
TOKEN.
YOU'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS
STUFF RIGHT SO YOU SHOULD BE
ABLE TO TELL ME WHAT YOU DO DO.
RIGHT NOW TODAY AND THAT'S WHAT
I'M ASKING ABOUT IS IF WE JUST
RELYING ON THE CODE SAYING YEAH
THIS PERSON'S OKAY.
THAT'S THAT'S A PROBLEM BECAUSE
THEY COULD BE GETTING.
POTENTIALLY THEY COULD BEGIN A
BRIBE AND AND MAYBE THIS IS
SOMEONE WHO'S NEVER EVEN PLAYED
LACROSSE.
OR WHATEVER IT IS IT'S IN SO HOW
DO WE HAVE SOMETHING IN PLACE IT
SAYS OKAY YOU'RE SAYING THIS
PERSON.
IS AN EXCEPTIONAL ATHLETE OR
MAYBE THEY'RE AN EXCEPTIONAL
VIOLINIST.
WE HAVE ANYTHING THAT GOES
ACROSS CHECKS THAT TO SAY OKAY
THEY'RE ACTUALLY.
DOING THIS AT THE SCHOOLS ARE
COMING FROM --
THERE IN ROLLED SOME IN SOME
SORT OF YOUR VIOLINIST ACADEMY
OR YOU HAVE BEEN A PART OF A
LOCAL --
SYMPHONY IS THERE ANY CROSS
CHECKING THAT GOES ON THERE'S A
COUPLE THINGS.
EIGHT I THINK IT'S PROBABLY
IMPORTANT TO NOTE HERE THAT SOME
OF THOSE ITEMS AS THIS THIS
PANEL WAS POINTED OUT.
BECAUSE OF WELL HEELED
INDIVIDUALS AND PEOPLE CRAFTING
PROCESS YOU HAD THE FAKE
DOCUMENTATION.
YOU HAD THE FAKE.
OR FRAUDULENT BOARD RESULTS YOU
HAD THE MONEY GOING THROUGH
CHARITABLE INSTITUTIONS.
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO CHECK
BECAUSE UR OUTSIDE I DON'T HAVE
SUBPOENA POWER.
AND I'M NOT ABLE TO GO INTO A
BANK ACCOUNT CATION IS PROVIDED
BY A SCHOOL THAT'S FRAUDULENT ON
THERE AND AND REYES BEYOND THAT
TO LOOK AND SEE IF IT'S UNTRUE
SO I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
LAYERS TO THIS.
THE NEED TO BE EXAMINED I THINK
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY BUT YOU
CAN CHECK OF SOMEONE'S ACTUALLY
A SOCCER PLAYER READ IT IS
ABSOLUTELY TRUE I THINK WE
SHOULD DO YOU DO THAT.
WE DO HAVE. TO BE CLEAR PEOPLE
CAN COME INTO A PROGRAM DECIDE
NOT TO PLAY.
AT ALL DAY ONE THERE'S NOTHING
SURE WE CAN BUILD BUT WE KNOW IF
THEY ACTUALLY DID PLAY BEFORE
THEY GOT THERE RIGHT WE SHOULD
BE ABLE TO HOLD THOSE WILL BE.
LETTERS AND INFORMATION PROVIDED
FROM THE SCHOOL.
SO IF THE SCHOOL IS NOT ACCURATE
OR IF THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE
CRACKED IN THE PROCESS.
AND YOU SEND FOR VERIFICATION
VERIFICATION COMES BACK.
THAT'S GOING TO BE VERY
DIFFICULT FOR DO WE DO THAT. TO
VERIFY WITH THE SCHOOL BUT WE
RELY ON THE EXPERT BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT I HEARD FIRST
THERE'S AN AUDIT PROCESS.
THAT THE ADMISSIONS THEY WILL DO
A A REVIEW AND SAMPLING OF THE
PROCESSOR IDENTIFY IF THERE ARE
ISSUES.
RIGHT SO THEN YOU GET MY OFFICE
WHICH IS ONE STEP REMOVED I'M
THE INDEPENDENT AUTHORITY I WILL
LOOK AT SOME OF THOSE.
AND EXAMINE IF THOSE WERE
ADEQUATE IF WE SHOULD BE
TWEAKING THEM IF THERE'S OTHER
THINGS.
THAT WE NEED TO BE DOING BUT THE
CRUX OF THIS CASE TO FIND
INFORMATION AT THAT ADMISSIONS
PROCESS SEES REALIZE SO A FAKE
SAT.
WE CAN DRILL ALL WE WANT THAT'S
CONTRARY DIFFICULT I AGREE I'M
I'M MORE TALKING ABOUT THINGS
THAT YOU CAN.
AND THAT'S WHAT INDEPENDENT
ROBERT AND I THINK IT'S VERY
FELL POINT THAT WE NEED TO
CONTROL WHAT WE CAN'T CONTROL
AND EXAMINE --
THE THE INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE
TO THE EXTENT POSSIBLE SO THAT
WE CAN FERRET OUT THESE ISSUES
ONCE AND THEN IT JUST SO I
UNDERSTAND YOUR ROLE A LITTLE
BIT LIKE.
WANT TO LOOK INTO THESE THINGS
IF YOU FIND THAT AN EMPLOYEE IS
ACTED WRONGFULLY OR HAS VIOLATED
ETHICAL RULES.
THEN ARE YOU VIEW YOUR OFFICE
PROCEEDS WITH DISCIPLINE AGAINST
THOSE INDIVIDUALS NO SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF WE BOUGHT IT AND WE
IDENTIFY ISSUES WHATEVER THOSE
ISSUES MAY BE.
QUITE WE WILL MAKE REFERRALS TO
THE APPROPRIATE TO INDIVIDUALS
WITHIN THE UNIVERSITY AND I WILL
NOTIFY THE PRESIDENT.
AND ALSO THE REGIONS OF THE
ITEMS THAT WE FOUND IF WE FIND
STRUCTURAL PROBLEMS.
WE WILL DO WHAT'S CALLED
MANAGEMENT CORRECTIVE ACTIONS WE
WILL TELL THE INDIVIDUAL --
CAMPUS FOR A HOLES THE SYSTEM
WHAT WE RECOMMEND NEEDS TO BE
DONE IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THE
SHORTCOMINGS WE'VE IDENTIFIED.
AND THEN WE WILL IF THEY'RE
ADOPTED BY THE REGENTS.
WE WILL THEN FOLLOW THEM TO
GROUND TO ENSURE THAT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY BEING IMPLEMENTED.
AND THEN WE WILL VERIFY
INDEPENDENTLY THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN IDENTIFIED.
IMPLEMENTED SO YOU'VE BEEN
TASKED BY THE PRESS AND THE
REGION YES.
AND BUT I BELIEVE THE COMMENT
WAS THE SWIFT DISCIPLINARY
ACTION.
IS THAT CORRECT OR NO.
ARE YOU JUST COME BACK WITH A
RECOMMENDATION IF YOU FIND
WRONGDOING YOU'RE GONNA REPORT
AND THEN THEY'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE DISCIPLINARY ACTION ON THE
FACT FINDING AN AUDIT FUNCTIONS.
SO WE ARE TO LOOK THE ITEMS IN
PROVIDE AT THE PRESIDENT AND THE
REGION'S WITH AN ON FOREST VIEW
OF WHAT WE HAVE LOOKED AT AND
THEN MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS WE
THINK ARE APPROPRIATE.
OKAY CAN WE GET A COPY OF THAT
REPORT AS WELL WHAT IT WHEREVER
YOU REPORT IS THIS COMMITTEE
SHOULD SEE THAT AS WELL.
NOT JUST THE REGIONS IN THE
PRESIDENT BECAUSE WE WANT TO
KNOW THAT ACTION IS BEING TAKEN
ON WHATEVER IT IS THAT YOU FIND.
CAN WE GET A COPY OF THAT REPORT
ONE IS COMPLETE.
THAT'S A DECISION THAT WILL HAVE
TO REFER TO MY SUPERIORS OKAY.
FROM THIS FROM THIS COMMITTEE
MEMBER I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT.
I WANTED THAT THAT MY COLLEAGUES.
ALSO WOULD LIKE TO SO MAYBE MAKE
THAT WILL THIS MAKE THAT A
FORMAL REQUEST.
SURE OKAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE QUESTIONS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MARTUCCI THANK
YOU VERY MUCH --
MISTER GALLAGHER ASKED A LOT OF
THE QUESTIONS I WAS PLANNING TO
ASK BUT JUST FOR CLARIFICATION.
IT IS.
AND I APOLOGIZE IF I MIGHT HAVE
MISSED THIS BUT DID YOU SAY THAT
SOMEONE SAY THAT.
TO THE THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
ADMISSIONS BY EXCEPTIONS OR ARE
AROUND 2% --
AT THE CAMPUS LEVEL.
SYSTEM WIDE SYSTEM WHY SYSTEM
WHERE OKAY THERE UNDER 2% UNDER
2% ARE A DIFFERENT 212% PER YEAR.
OKAY AND AND ALSO THE A JUST
FOCUSING ON ONE OF THE EXAMPLES
THAT I READ I BELIEVE THERE IS A
UCLA WOMEN'S SOCCER COACH --
THAT -- AND
IT AT LEAST ACCORDING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE THE
INDICTMENT IS THAT CORRECT.
I DON'T KNOW.
I A I THINK IT'S AN AND THE DEAD
THE NEWS --
I DON'T HAVE ANY INFORMATION
OKAY OKAY --
SO IF IF WE WERE TO AT TO SAY
THAT THERE WAS A UCLA WOMEN'S
SOCCER COACH.
INVOLVED HERE.
IF.
IF THE STUDENT WERE TO BE
ADMITTED WITH THAT WITH THAT
STUDENT BE A A ATHLETIC
SCHOLARSHIP RECIPIENT OR NOT
NECESSARILY SO.
IT TO THE FALL UNDER THE HOOD.
IT COULD BE BUT NOT NECESSARILY
BUT NOT NECESSARY OKAY MY
LIMITED VIEWS BASED UPON WHAT
THE INDICTMENT INDICATED THAT
THESE WERE NON SCHOLARSHIP.
ATHLETES NOT SCULPTURE WALK ONS
OKAY WERE BROUGHT IN AND THEN.
DID NOT PLAY AT ALL --
PLAY FOR SOME LIMITED PORTION
THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING FROM THE
INDICTMENT AND WHAT'S BEEN
SPELLED OUT.
SO I HAVE NO FURTHER INFORMATION
ON THAT.
ARE -- AT
THEIR LIKE QUOTAS OF YOU KNOW
THE QUOTAS OR SET ASIDES --
FOR SPECIAL ADMITS --
BY SPORT.
I NEED CAMPUS.
AND I'VE NEVER HEARD IN ALL MY
YEARS OF ANY PARTICULAR QUOTAS --
SET ASIDE BY SPORT --
EIGHT IT IS RECOGNIZE THAT ALL
TEAMS WANT TO FIELD TEAMS AND
AND MAKE THEIR CASE FOR THE
STUDENTS THAT THEY WANT TO ADMIT --
WE DON'T EVEN HAVE QUOTAS PER SE
FOR MAJOR STATE THEY MAY BE
CAPPED --
BECAUSE OF JUST PEER CAPACITY
LOTUS F. FOR FOR ANY ASPECT TO
IT TO MY KNOWLEDGE OF THE OF THE
UNIVERSE.
SO TO AND IT WAS --
IN A KNOWLEDGE THERE THERE ARE
NO SUCH A QUOTAS OR SET ASIDES --
FOR FOR THE DARK SO IT'S OF NO.
AND SO.
A. AS A GENERAL ADMISSIONS
POLICY.
IS THE POLICY JUSTIFICATION.
FOR MAKING ADMISSIONS BY
EXCEPTIONS.
FOR A NON AT ATHLETIC SCHOLAR
WILL NOT NON SCHOLARSHIP
ATHLETES --%
THE THE THE THE GENERAL
DIVERSITY ARGUMENT THAT THAT
THEY CONTRIBUTE SOME.
SOME -- THEY
CONTRIBUTE TO THE DIVERSITY OF
THE STUDENT BODY IS AT THE BASIC.
IN CERTAIN WAYS SO FOR EXAMPLE
MUSICIANS ARE ARE FOLKS IN A
PERFORMING ARTS ARE FOLKS WHO
WERE HOME SCHOOLED --
THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF ARE FOLKS
WHO HAVE VERY UNIQUE INDUSTRY
WERE AREA WHERE CERTAIN KINDS OF
THINGS WEREN'T AVAILABLE TO THEM --
OUT -- BUT
YET YES.
ALL OF THE INDICATORS INDICATE
THAT THAT'S TO WOULD ACTUALLY
THRIVE AT THE UNIVERSITY THOSE
KIND OF THINGS.
OKAY I I GUESS I IF YOU JUST
WANT -- TO
AND MY QUESTIONS WITH WITH THE
THOUGHT THAT --
YOU KNOW I I HEARD MS LI MONA I
KNOW SHE HAS EXPERIENCE HAVING
WORKED AT THE UC SANTA BARBARA --
AND AND AND SHE KNOWS PEOPLE
THAT -- ARE
FAMILIAR WITH THE AREA THE
OPERATION THERE BUT YOU KNOW ON
THE ONE HAND I HEAR THIS VERY
THOROUGH.
VETTING OF APPLICATIONS WITH A
WITH A C. THEY THEY THEY LOOK
FOR FOR DISCREPANCIES --
TO TO TO MAKE SURE THAT --
THAT --
PEOPLE ARE REPRESENTED
THEMSELVES TO BE WHO THEY ARE IN
FACT WITH THEY ARE.
BUT ON THE OTHER HAND.
WE SEEM TO HAVE [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
A SYSTEM THAT AT LEAST ALLOWED --
IT TO STUDENTS IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING.
THAT.
WERE ALLOWED WITHOUT.
A SIMILAR TYPE OF VETTING --
AT LEAST INADEQUATE VETTING AND
SO -- BY --
YOU GUYS THEY SHARE THE MY MY
COLLEAGUES CALLS THAT THE THAT
THAT WE HAVE A A THOROUGH
EVALUATION ESPECIALLY OF OF
THESE --
ATHLETIC RECOMMENDATIONS --
THAT SEEM.
TO A PATTERN --
PERHAPS NOT AS MUCH AT THE
UNIVERSE CALIFORNIA BUT WAIT
WITH THIS DISC SCANDAL OVERALL.
THANK A REMEMBER MERCHANTS CITY
AYE AYE HI.
THE THIS SHOWS UP YOU CAN BE
NINETY NINE POINT 5% RIGHT AND
ONE LITTLE PROBLEM SURE --
AT DISH ARE REALLY PUSH THE
INTEGRITY OF YOUR INSTITUTION
ADDRESS THAT WE TAKE THAT VERY
SERIOUSLY SO --
OUR OUR HI NO NO SYSTEM IS
INCORRUPTIBLE NO HUMAN BEING I
GUESS THERE ARE ARE HUMAN BEINGS
OR OUR FLAWED.
BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IF
WE'RE GOING TO USE THIS SITE HAS
AN OPPORTUNITY. TO REALLY MAKE
SURE THAT TO THE BEST OF OUR
KNOWLEDGE TO DAY --
THAT WE HAVE THE RIGHT PROCESS
IS IN PLACE TO TO RE --
TO TO BRING BACK THE KIND OF
CONFIDENCE THAT THAT I THINK A
YOU AND OTHER MEMBERS OF THIS
BODY CARE.
REGARDING THE UNIVERSITY CAP.
THANK YOU.
Q. AND JUST TO KIND OF WRAP THIS
UP HERE --
YOU KNOW THIS IS A LEARNING
MOMENT FOR US IN THIS IS THAT OF
COURSE --
INSTITUTION OF HIGHER LEARNING --
WITH WITH THE UC AND WE'RE STILL
PUBLIC ONE SO FAR OUT OF THE
EIGHT HUNDRED IN THE INDICTMENT
ONLY THIRTY OR SO WE'RE NAMES --
THE HANDFUL IN CALIFORNIA COURSE --
WELL MORE THAN --
TO TO WORK FOR A PRIVATE
UNIVERSITIES AND SO THAT'S OF OF
CAN GREAT CONCERN AT THAT AS
WELL -- BUT
WE WANT TO YOU KNOW WORK WITH
WITH THE UNIVERSITY BECAUSE
AGAIN YOU WERE DUPED YOU KNOW
THIS IS THIS IS.
A BLACK GUY ON THE SYSTEM BUT
IT'S INDIVIDUALS THAT THAT
BECAUSE THAT AND SO WE'RE NOT AT
THIS POINT.
AT ALL POINTING FINGERS TO ADD
TO THE SYSTEM AND I KNOW YOU
WANT TO GET TO THE BOTTOM AT OF
THIS JUST LIKE.
HOW WE DO BUT WE WE SPENT TWO
HOURS HERE TODAY BECAUSE THIS
RAISES SOME BIGGER QUESTIONS?
YOU KNOW WHAT DO WE DO ABOUT HOW
DO WE REASSURE THE PUBLIC THAT
THE SYSTEM IS NOT TOTALLY
WRECKED.
AND WHAT WHAT WHAT SHOULD WE DO
ABOUT OUR APPLICATION SYSTEM
GOING FORWARD TO THE COVETED UC
SYSTEM.
ABOUT OUR SERRA NICE TESTING --
ABOUT MAKING SURE WE HAVE CHECKS
AND BALANCES IN THE APPLICATION
PROCESS AND SO --
YOU KNOW WE WERE COUNTING ON YOU
AND WE MAY HAVE OUR OWN PUSHED
US ALONG ISN'T AS AN ONGOING
DISCUSSION WE THOUGHT.
IT WARNING HAVING A DEEP DIVE
TODAY ABOUT THIS TOPIC SO --
THANK YOU AND WE WILL RULES WE
WILL STAY ENGAGED.
YES AND WITH THAT WANT TO MAKE
AN ANNOUNCEMENT THAT I KNOW SOME
PEOPLE CAME HERE TO TESTIFY WE
RUN OF VALUE PUBLIC TESTIMONY.
BUT WE'RE NOT GOING TO CONTINUE
WITH THE REST OF THE AGENDA
TODAY -- SO
THOSE WOULD THERE'S THEY'RE ALL
INFORMATIONAL ITEMS ESSENTIALLY
NO ACTION ITEMS.
BUT I KNOW SOME PEOPLE TRAVEL
TODAY AND SO THEY WANT --
TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY --
TO CHER --
YOUR COMMENTARY WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND SELL --
I KNOW SO MY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
HAVE TO GO AND I'M I THINK A
LITTLE BIT TOO BUT I WILL
CERTAINLY ENTERTAIN A PUBLIC
COMMENT TO ALLOW --
YOU ALL TO TO SAY A FEW WORDS
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YES.
YEAH I THREE THAT YOU CAN SIT
DOWN RIGHT THERE BUT EVERYONE
ELSE CAROLINA PER YEAR.
SO TRY TO KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO
ONE MINUTE SIR THANK YOU
[inaudible]
HI.
GOOD MORNING STEAMED ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MY NAME IS HECTOR
RODRIGUEZ SAID I'M A TENURED
UNIVERSITY PROFESSOR HERE IN THE
STATE.
I TEACH HEALTH CARE POLICY AND
MANAGEMENT AT AND FOCUS ON THE
CARE OF VULNERABLE PATIENTS IN
OUR STATE AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY --
I AM AN ELECTED MEMBER OF THE
NATIONAL ACADEMY OF MEDICINE.
BUT I'M ALSO THE SON OF MEXICAN
IMMIGRANTS START GRADUATE.
AND THE PRODUCT OF THE PUBLIC
EDUCATION SYSTEM FROM HIGH
SCHOOL HERE IN HAYWARD. TO MY
UNDERGRADUATE IN UC SAN DIEGO
TWO MASTERS AT UC BERKELEY AND
SINCE.
FINISHING MY PHD AT HARVARD
UNIVERSITY I'VE BEEN WORKING IN
THE PUBLIC --
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM HERE IN THE
STATE --
BECAUSE I AM DEDICATED TO GIVING
BACK.
I'M HERE TO ASK YOU TO SUPPORT
AND FUND A CRITICAL PROGRAM FOR
THE UNIVERSE FOR CALIFORNIA
FACULTY.
THE CALIFORNIA PROGRAM AND
ACCESS TO CARE.
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN C.
PACK HAS GRANTED MORE THAN SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT UC
AND CSU FACULTY. TO IMPROVE
ACCESS TO CARE IN THE STATE HAS
SPONSORED NUMEROUS HAVE EVIDENCE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
DISSEMINATE XIN EFFORTS THE
POLICY MAKERS.
SEE PACKS PRIORITY AREAS INCLUDE
ENSURING ACCESS TO CARE FOR
IMMIGRANTS CHARTING A PATHWAY TO
UNIVERSAL COVERAGE IN THE STATE.
AND ADDRESSING SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH THROUGH
CROSS SECTOR COLLABORATION.
SO YOU SEE LEVERAGES THE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN EXTERNAL
FUNDING THAT WE AS PROFESSORS
GET -- TO
DISSEMINATE TO YOU ALL IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADVOCATES AND
POLICYMAKERS --
EASY TO DIGEST WAYS OF USING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU I'VE WE HAVE
THE PRESENTATION AND MEMBER
FAMILIAR WITH THE PROGRAM AND
AND THANK YOU FOR THE WORK AND
LOCAL KEEP TALKING TO YOU.
THANK YOU ONE MINUTE PLEASE.
YOU'RE ON THE TOPIC YOU GOTTA GO.
SO I AM ALSO YEARS REPRESENTED
OF THE PACK MY NAME IS ERICA
BROWN ON THE FOURTH YOUR
DOCTORAL STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY
I JUST WANTED TO ASK THE
COMMITTEE --
AS A HUMBLE REQUEST TO CONSIDER
THE FUNDING AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SUPPORT EQUITY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
TO SUPPORT AND REPRESENTATIVES
OF COLOR WHO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO ENGAGE.
POLICY STAKEHOLDERS I TOO AM A
PRODUCT OF OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEM BUT I'M ALSO PROUD
GRADUATE OF BERKLEY CENTER
GRADUATE PROGRAM --
UCLA'S MASTERS IN PUBLIC HEALTH
AND AS A DOCTORAL STUDENT
BERKELEY EVERY TIME I'VE
PROGRESS MY EDUCATION I'VE
ENCOUNTERED FEWER STUDENTS OF
COLOR AND MORE BARRIERS.
SO I WANTED TO SHARE WITH YOU AS
MY PUBLIC COMMENT THE INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY THAT SEE PACKAGE
PROVIDED IN TERMS OF FUNDING MY
EDUCATION HELP ME NAVIGATE THE
POLITICS OF OBTAINING A DOCTORAL
DEGREE AND MOST IMPORTANTLY HELP
ME WITH MY PROFESSIONAL
ENDEAVORS --
I THINK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
AND YOUR FOR FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THAT WAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
CHAIR MCCARTY AND AS STEAMED.
COMMITTEE OF MY NAME IS AMY
HEINZ LIKE AND I AM THE
LEGISLATIVE AND POLITICAL
DIRECTOR OF THE UNIVERSITY
PROFESSIONAL AND TECHNICAL
EMPLOYEES CW A LOCAL.
NINETY ONE NINETEEN I'M HERE TO
ADDRESS ISSUE NUMBER THREE IN
THE AGENDA OPERATIONAL COSTS --
I I FEEL VERY STRONGLY ABOUT THE
ONE HUNDRED AND NINETEEN POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS AN ON
GOING GENERAL FUND FOR SUPPORT
FOR YOU SEE OPERATIONAL COST
INCREASES.
IS VERY SANITIZED DISCUSSION
GIVEN THE FACT THAT FORTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE WILL BE ON
STRIKE TOMORROW.
SO FIFTEEN THOUSAND UP THE CW A
MEMBERS AND TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
I ASKED ME LOCAL THIRTY TWO
NINETY NINE MEMBERS WILL BE ON
STRIKE.
THIS DOCUMENT BARELY DISCUSSES A
PATHWAY FORWARD TO SETTLE WITH
FORTY THOUSAND WORKERS WHO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES THAT ARE SO
HERALDED ABOUT THE UC
INSTITUTION WE ARE STRIKING FOR
STUDENTS PATIENTS ANDOUR
FAMILIES --
IT DOES HAVE A BRIEF MENTION ON
PAGE ELEVEN OF ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
FACULTY AND STAFF BUT THE UC
NEVER MENTIONS WHETHER THEY'RE
EVEN ASKING FOR THAT MONEY THEY
JUST MENTION THAT THEY DON'T
THINK THAT THEY HAD A IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET --
LAST YEAR'S LAST YEAR BUT UP
THESE BUDGET ASKS WAS ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION FROM
PROPOSITION TWO MONEY TO THE
UNFUNDED LIABILITY OF THE
DEFINED BENEFIT PENSION AND THE
UC WOULD NOT JOIN US IN ASKING
FOR THOSE FUNDS. TO OUR BE
WILDER MEANT.
A COMMUNITY COLLEGES MEET WITH
THEIR EMPLOYER GROUPS EVERY JULY
TO COLLABORATE ON PUBLIC BUDGET
ASKS AND THIS IS SINCE TWENTY
SIXTEEN I'VE BEEN THE
LEGISLATIVE AND POLITICAL
DIRECTOR FOR THIS UNION.
AND I DON'T KNOW WHERE THE
RELATIONSHIP IS IT SEEMS LIKE WE
COULD COLLABORATE AND THAT THE
RELATIONSHIP IS COMPLETELY
ABSENT AND THIS IS OUR THIRD
STRIKE FOR ONE CONTRACT WE
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO GO FOR ON
THREE STRIKES FOR ONE CONTRACT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ARMENIANS ELING
HARO I AM THE FIRST YEAR PHD
STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY AND I'M
HERE WITH THE SEAT BUT SEE PACK --
I JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT MY
EXPERIENCES AS A FIRST
GENERATION LATINA --
DACA RECIPIENTS AT UC BERKELEY
IN THE SUPPORT THAT C. PACK HAS
PROVIDED FOR ME BOTH
PROFESSIONALLY AND ACADEMICALLY --
TO PACK FUNDING IS CRITICAL TO
ENGAGEMENT AND RELATIONSHIP
BUILDING FOR OPPORTUNITIES. FOR
FACULTY UNDERREPRESENTED
STUDENTS OF COLOR.
AND POLICY STAKEHOLDERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA --
ON A PERSONAL NOTE I WOULD LIKE
TO REFERENCE.
I'M C. PACK HAS BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN MY ABILITY TO
ATTEND UC BERKELEY CELL POLICY
PHD PROGRAM AS THE FIRST DOCTOR
STUDENT.
I'M WITH THE PACK FINANCE A SHIP
FINANCIAL SUPPORT AND PAPERS
MENTORSHIP.
I'M THEY HAVE BEEN CRITICAL IN
MY SUCCESS IS THE FIRST
GENERATION THAT THE NOT
IMMIGRANT AND A DOCTORAL PROGRAM
AND I WOULD LIKE TO I THINK YOU
FOR CONSIDERING FUNDING FOR C.
PACK.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
VICTORIA DOMINGUEZ WITH ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE IN
THE COLLEGE FOR ALL COALITION
I'M HERE TO ASK FOR SUPPORT WHEN
IT --
REINVESTMENT FOR THE COLLEGE
READING THIS BLOCK GRANT THIS
WAS A TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
FEE TO TOP INVESTMENT FOR HIGH
SCHOOLS WITH 7275% MORE --
STUDENT POPULATION FOR LOW
INCOME FOSTER YOUTH OR ENGLISH
LEARNER BUT AT THE UC LOW LEVEL
OF THE TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT TO SUPPORT THE OUT
REACH -- OF
THE STUDENTS AT THESE HIGH
SCHOOLS BUT ALSO THE RETENTION
THROUGH THE THE THEIR ACT --
ACADEMIC CAREER AT THE UC LEVEL
AND AN ADDITIONAL TWO THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED IN ROMAN SLOT WHICH
WE SAW REALLY SUPPORT STUDENTS
OF COLOR WE ENTERED THE SYSTEM
SO WE REALLY OR ASK FOR THE
SUPPORT OF THOSE THREE
INVESTMENT DOLLARS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
GABRIEL GARCIA AND I'M A THIRTY
YEAR UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT UC
BERKELEY I'M A FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE STUDENT AN UNDERGRADUATE
RESEARCH FELLOW WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM AND ACCESS TO
CARE.
I WORK ALONGSIDE ERICA LANE OR
TO FACILITATE SEE PACKED
PROGRAMS AS THE PARK OFFERS
MODEL PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT
STUDENTS LIKE THE DOCTORAL
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM THE
UNDERGRADUATE FELLOW PROGRAM.
AND THEN UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS
CALLERS A PROGRAM --
AND AT I HOPE THAT.
THROUGH THIS TESTIMONY --
YOU GUYS RE --
SEE PARK SCOTIA PROGRAMS PURPOSE
IS TO DIVERSIFY THE HEALTH AND
PUBLIC POLICY PROFESSION BY
BRINGING TOGETHER DIVERSE
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS ACROSS
THE UC SYSTEM WITH THE COMMON
GOAL OF IMPROVING HEALTH.
AND HEALTHCARE IN CALIFORNIA AND
THROUGH THE SEA PARKS CULTURE
PROGRAM STUDENTS INTRODUCED TO
HELP POLICY PROFESSIONALS AND
EXPERTS I HAD THE LUXURY OF
BEING A STUDENTS COLLEGE NOT
ONLY UNDERGRADUATE POLYBUS
STUDENTS SCHOLARSHIP RECIPIENT.
NATO REALLY ENJOYED THE
EXPERIENCE THAT I HAD AND I
THOROUGHLY ENJOYED CREATING A
NETWORK OF INDIVIDUALS --
UP FROM ACROSS THE UC SYSTEM
THERE ARE ALL KIND OF COMING
TOGETHER TO CREATE MORE I COULD
ONE MORE A BETTER HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA.
AND APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT AND
YOUR GUIDANCE AND IN THE
LISTENING TO THE TESTIMONY TODAY
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO GM JAKE
RUNNER WITH THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY --
APPRECIATE YOUR CONTINUED FOCUS
AROUND THE NEED --
TO ENROLL MORE OF OUR CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA THAT'S ONE OF OUR
BUDGET PRIORITIES THIS YEAR AT
THE CAMPAIGN --
WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE CONTINUED
FOCUS ON MAKING SURE THAT THAT
AGREEMENT AROUND THE CAMPUS
BASED CAPS ON NON RESIDENT
ENROLLEES CONTINUE TO A LOT FOR
ACCESS FOR CALIFORNIA HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATES --
WE ALSO ARE MEMBERS OF THE COURT
FOR ALL COALITION AND HOPE THAT
YOU WILL CONSIDER REINVESTMENT
IN THE CALL TRADING THIS BLOCK
GRANT ON AN ONGOING BASIS SO
THAT ARE UC CAMPUSES CAN REALLY
WORK IN PARTNERSHIP SUSTAINABLY.
WITH THEIR CAKE TO TWELVE
PARTNER SERVING OUR NEEDIEST
STUDENTS AND THEN FINALLY WE
ALSO FACILITATE THE CALIFORNIA
UNDOCUMENTEDHIGHER EDUCATION
COALITION WHERE ONE OF OUR
PRIORITIES THIS YEAR'S TO
CONTINUE THE INVESTMENT IN THE
LEGAL SERVICES FUNDING.
THAT HAS BEEN SO --
IMPACTFUL FOR ARGUES THE
STUDENTS FACULTY AND STAFF AND
THEIR FAMILIES AS WELL REALLY IN
A TIME OF GREAT UNCERTAINTY --
WITH THEIR LEGAL STATUS WITH THE
CHALLENGES BEEN PREPARE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
MY NAME IS AMIR RIGHT AND THIRTY
YEAR UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT AT UC
BERKELEY --
MISTER CHAIR JUST WANT TO REALLY
QUICKLY THANK YOU BECAUSE THE
LAST TIME I WAS HERE --
YES THE ASK ME SOME QUESTIONS
AND WE HAD A SHORT CONVERSATION
AROUND CAL FRESH SO I APPRECIATE.
YOUR QUESTIONS AROUND THAT AND
TODAY I'M HERE TO SPEAK TO YOU
ALL ABOUT FINDING THE UC AND
JUST YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT --
AND BUDGET.
PROPOSALS FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA --
AGAIN I COME FROM UC BERKELEY A
CAMPUS WHERE THERE ARE ONE POINT
8% BLACK STUDENTS LIKE I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATIONS AND THE ASSOCIATED
STUDENTS THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA.
IN THOSE ARE IN MY ROLE AT THE
ACC ARABS IN THE BLACK COMMUNITY
AND WE REALLY ARE FEW AND FAR
BETWEEN ON CAMPUS AND IN A POST
PROPOSITION TWO OH NINE WORLD
WHERE THERE'S SO FEW STUDENTS OF
COLOR ON OUR STUDENTS OF COLOR.
ON A UC CAMPUSES I REALLY
BELIEVE THAT THE FUNDING OF OUR
RECRUITMENT RETENTION CENTERS
ACTUALLY IS A WONDERFUL WAY TO
GO ABOUT GETTING THE STUDENTS ON
OUR CAMPUSES BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT THERE'S ONLY SO MUCH THE
INSTITUTION CAN DO. TO GET THE
STUDENTS COME TO OUR CAMPUSES SO
A LOT OF THAT BURDEN OFTENTIMES
FALLS ON THE STUDENTS.
AND THEIR JOB IS TO GO INTO
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOLS AND
AROUND THE AREA AND REALLY
RECRUIT STUDENTS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE STUDENTS WHO DO.
END UP ON OUR CAMPUSES FEEL LIKE
THEY CAN SUCCEED IN THAT THEY
FEEL SUPPORTED SO INCREASE
FUNDING FOR THOSE IS A GREAT
STEP IN THERE IN THAT DIRECTION
TO GET MORE SINCE THE COLOR ON
CAMPUS.
AND INCREASE FUNDING FOR THE UC
IN GENERAL WOULD BE EXCELLENT
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JAMIE CONNECT --
I'M A FOURTH YEAR UNDERGRADUATE
AT UCLA AND A BOARD MEMBER WITH
THE UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION I'M I
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR MAKING
TIME FOR PUBLIC COMMENT SAYING
BEING HERE --
AND I WANTED TO START OFF BY
PROVIDING SOME STUDENT INSIGHT
ON WHY IT THE SATISFACTION
SURVEYS HAVE BEEN SO GREAT THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS I'M A LOT OF
IT IS COMING FROM.
THE DIFFERENT IMPACTS WERE
SEEING FROM ENROLLMENT GROWTH --
SO FOR EXAMPLE WE'VE SYSTEM WIDE
HAD TO TURN DOUBLES AND TRIPLES
TRIPLES IN A QUIET --
I WAS LIVING IN A TEN BY TWELVE
ROOM FOR TWELVE HUNDRED FOR A
LIVING UNDER DOLLARS A MONTH
WITH TWO OTHER PEOPLE IN IT.
YOU CAN ONLY YOU CAN ONLY HAVE
TWO PEOPLE STANDING AT ONE TIME --
Và AND FOR YOUR FIRST TWO YEARS
OUR CLASSES ARE THREE FOUR
HUNDRED PEOPLE PER CLASS AND
THIS IS ASSUMING YOU CAN GET
INTO THEM EVEN WITH CLASS SIZES
BIG.
ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE IMPACTED
MAJOR I'VE NEVER HAD A QUARTER
RAKE ALL THE CLASSES THAT I NEED
IT OB AND MY PEERS FIND
THEMSELVES STUCK TAKING CLASSES
THEY DON'T NEED.
BECAUSE THEIR REQUIREMENTS A LOT
BEFORE THEIR FIRST ENROLLMENT
TIME -- IN
THIS IS FORCING STUDENTS TO TAKE
CLASSES OVER THE SUMMER.
THIS IS THE ONLY TIME WHEN THEY
CAN GET THESE REQUIRED COURSES --
SO FOR THESE REASONS I ASK THAT
INCREASES AS WELL AS EXTENSIVE
WORK HOW GRANTS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON --
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ANGIE TEN
AND I'M A STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY
AND I'M HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
THE UC AND UC ESSAY BUDGET ASKS.
BEING A STUDENT UC BERKELEY I'VE
SEEN FIRSTHAND THE STRUGGLES
THAT MANY STUDENTS MUCH ME AND
MY PEERS FACE IN TERMS OF
GETTING OUR CLASSES.
FINDING THE HOUSING THAT WE NEED
AND RECEIVING ACCESS TO THE
RESOURCES WE NEED TO HELP US
NAVIGATE THE COLLEGE EXPERIENCE
IT'S ONLY RESPONSIBLE THAT WHEN
THE CALIFORNIA AND ROLES MORE
STUDENTS AND EXPANDS ACCESS TO
HIGHER EDUCATION WE ALSO EXPAND
FUNDING.
OUR STUDENTS IS A ROBUST STATE
FUNDING THAT WILL FREEZE TUITION
LEVELS PRIORITIZE CRITICAL BASIC
NEEDS INITIATIVES AND ALSO PLACE
CARS I'M MOST OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENT POPULATIONS.
ARE LOW INCOME FIRST GENERATION
ON REPRESENTED I'M AND
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS --
DESERVES SERVICES THAT ARE
CRUCIAL TO THEIR ACADEMIC
SUCCESS ULTIMATELY PUBLIC
EDUCATION I BELIEVE IS ABOUT
ACCESS IT'S ABOUT DIVERSITY AND
IT'S ABOUT EQUITY AND I HOPE
THAT THE FINAL BUDGET REFLECTS
THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HELLO -- MY
NAME IS SARAH I'M A THIRD YEAR
STUDENT UC BERKELEY AND ON THE
PHONE YOU SEE CHAIR FOR YOU SEE
STERN ASSOCIATION I WANT TO
REITERATE.
EVERYTHING THAT'S BEEN SAID AND
WILL BE SAID BY THE OTHER YOU
SEE STUDENTS --
BUT ONCE AGAIN EVEN THOUGH I
TOUCH ON THIS LAST TIME --
I NEED TO EMPHASIZE UCS A STRONG
A POP UP OPPOSITION TO TUITION
HIKES OF ANY KIND INCLUDING NON
RESIDENT TUITION HIKES --
WHICH WOULD DEEPLY AFFECT OUR
OUT OF STATE INTERNATIONAL
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITIES --
NONRESIDENT STUDENTS CONTRIBUTE
JUST AS MUCH AS HONESTLY MUCH
MORE IN THE FORM OF MONEY --
TO OUR UNIVERSITY AND THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THEM REMAIN IN THE
STATE UPON GRADUATION FURTHER
CONTRIBUTING TO OUR ECONOMY AND
OUR COMMUNITY --
LAST WEEK THE DISCUSSION ON
RESIDENT TUITION INCREASES WAS
TABLE BECAUSE THE REGION'S DID
NOT FEEL COMFORTABLE INCREASING
TUITION FOR STUDENTS WERE
ALREADY CONTRIBUTING SO MUCH --
IN FACT STUDENTS HAVE BECOME THE
PRIMARY FINANCIAL STAKEHOLDERS
IN THE UNIVERSITY STATE
INVESTMENT HAS CONTINUED TO
DECREASE YEAR AFTER YEAR --
STUDENTS SHOULD NOT BE THE MAIN
FINANCIAL STAKEHOLDERS IN OUR
PUBLIC INSTITUTION --
WE SHOULD NOT FURTHER PLACE THE
BURDEN OF FUNDING ON FUNDING THE
YOU SEE ON STUDENTS THE
UNIVERSITY IN THE STATE NEEDS TO
FIND A MIDDLE GROUND --
THE UC WAS FOUNDED ON THE
PRINCIPLES OF ACCESSIBILITY
AFFORDABILITY BUT WITH EACH
TUITION HIKE WHETHER FOR
RESIDENTS OR FOR NON RESIDENTS
WE MOVE FURTHER AND FURTHER AWAY
FROM THESE VALUES --
SO I REALLY URGE YOU ALL TO FIND
THE YOU SEE AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT INCREASING NON
RESIDENT TUITION AND WE ALSO
DON'T NEED AND ROMAN CAP ON ON
RESIDENTS EITHER THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS --
MY NAME IS SAMANTHA CURRENTS AND
I'M A UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT
FIRST YEAR AT UC BERKELEY --
I'M A FIRST GENERATION STUDENTS
HELLO AND I COME FROM A LOW
INCOME FAMILY AND I COME FROM A
SINGLE PARENT FAMILY --
SO I REALLY URGE FOR THE TUITION
FREEZE BECAUSE IT'S ESSENTIAL
FOR STUDENTS TO BE ABLE TO GAIN
A HIGHER EDUCATION --
THE ONLY WAY I'M ABLE TO GAIN A
HIGHER EDUCATION MYSELF IS
BECAUSE OF THE UC SYSTEM IN THE
FUNDING THAT I'VE GOTTEN THROUGH
THE SYSTEM --
I ALSO HELP URGE YOU TO FOCUS ON
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE THAT
STUDENTS CAN SUCCESSFULLY
RECEIVE A VALUABLE EDUCATION
ONCETHEY ACTUALLY ARE ADMITTED
INTO THE UC EDUCATION SYSTEM.
AND ALSO --
URGE FOR THE EXPENSE OF THE
SUMMER CAL TO FINISH WITHIN FOUR
YEARS AND GET OUT AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE AND NOT ACCUMULATE MORE
FUNDS THAN THEY ALREADY HAVE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
MAKING TIME FOR PUBLIC COMMENT I
AM THE CURRENT VICE PRESIDENT
EXTERNAL AFFAIRS FOR THE
ASSOCIATES DANCE EASY SAN DIEGO
SO I ESSENTIALLY REPRESENT OUR
UNDERGRADUATE POPULATION.
LAST YEAR A HUNDRED AND FIVE
MILLION WAS GIVEN ONE TIME FUNDS
FOR ENROLLMENT GROWTH IN MY
CAMPUS UC SAN DIEGO RECEIVED
APPROXIMATELY THIRTEEN MILLION.
WITH THESE DOLLARS THEY WERE
ABLE TO HIRE TWO HUNDRED
LECTURERS AND TEACHING
ASSISTANTS TO ACCOMMODATE
ADDITIONAL ENROLLMENT GROWTH AND
WITHOUT THESE ONGOING FUNDS IT
WOULD DIRECTLY IMPACT NOT ONLY
STUDENT FACULTY RATIOS.
BUT TIME TO DEGREE COMPLETION
FOR STUDENTS LIKE ME.
LAST YEAR THIS BODY ALSO BOUGHT
OUT A TUITION AND SERVICES FEE
INCREASE AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SO IS MY HOPE THAT
THESE FUNDS ARE AN ONGOING
INVESTMENT THIS YEAR IN ORDER TO
PREVENT ANY INCREASES.
IN THE COST FOR STUDENTS TO
ATTEND OUR INSTITUTION WE'RE
ALSO VERY EXCITED TO SEE BASIC
NEEDS SERVICE SAYS BEING OF
SUPPORTED IN THE PROPOSED BUDGET
AND HOPE TO SEE IT IN THE FINAL
VERSION ON THE GOVERNOR'S DESK
IN JUNE.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
CONVERSATIONS REGARDING THE
ADMISSIONS SCANDAL TO ALSO --
CALL INTO QUESTION AT THE
COMPLETELY LEGAL WAYS IN WHICH
STUDENTS CAN BUY THEIR WAY INTO
THIS UNIVERSITY --
SO I AM A LOW INCOME STUDENTS
AND I TOOK THE SAT HOWEVER THERE
ARE A LOT OF FOLKS WHO APPLIED
ALONGSIDE ME TO THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA IN THE FALL OF TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN WHO WERE ABLE
TO SPEND THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS ON
TEST PREP SERVICES --
AND I I THINK THAT THERE'S A
GREATER CONVERSATION NEEDS TO BE
HOT OF LIKE HOW DO WE MAKE SURE
THAT THERE ARE THE SYSTEMATIC
BARRIERS BEING TAKEN DOWN.
AND HOW DO WE SUPPORT STUDENTS
WHEN THEY ENTER OUR INSTITUTION --
THERE IS A COLLEGE BLOCK GRANT
THAT I THINK IS A REALLY GREAT
ALTERNATIVE FOR THIS BODY TO
LOOK INTO THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI I THANK YOU FOR LISTENING TO
US FOR THIS PUBLIC COMMENT MY
NAME'S KAELIN KERR I'M A
GRADUATE STUDENT AT UC IRVINE
AND I WANT TO TALK ABOUT --
HI SUPPORT UC'S --
BUDGET REQUEST ESPECIALLY FOR
GRADUATES UNDERGRADUATE
COMMUNITY WITH CA SHIPS WHERE WE
PERSONALLY INTERACT WITH
STUDENTS AND REALLY HELP THEM
LEARN AS WELL AS GETTING
UNDERGRADUATES INVOLVED IN
RESEARCH OUTSIDE OF THE
CLASSROOM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
LETTING US SPEAK MY NAME IS
RACHEL ROSENZWEIG AND I AM A PHD
CANDIDATE IN MATERIALS SCIENCE
AND ENGINEERING AT UC IRVINE.
AND I SUPPORT THE BUDGET
REQUESTS TO INCREASE THE AMOUNT
OF GRADUATE STUDENTS FOR THE UC
BY CAMPUSES.
GROWING UP I DIDN'T KNOW ANY
SCIENTISTS OR ENGINEERS THAT'S A
FIELD I'M IN RIGHT NOW THE LACK
OF DIVERSITY --
SCARED ME FROM GOING INTO THE
FIELD THE DIVERSITY WITHIN THE
GRADUATE STUDENT AND FACULTY
POPULATION THAT YOU SEE IN THE
INCREASED OUR DIRECTORY OF
DIVERSITY IS WHAT ATTRACTED ME
TO TACKLE THIS FIELD.
AND TO GO INTO ENGINEERING THE
RESEARCH WE DO TACKLES
ANTIMICROBIAL RESISTANCE AND
DECREASES HOSPITAL ACQUIRED
INFECTIONS WHICH IS A HUGE ISSUE
FINANCIALLY AND WORLD HEALTH
WIDE IN THE WORLD AS WELL AS THE
U. S..
AS A FEMALE I WAS THERE'S LESS
THAN 20% OF US IN MY FIELD AND
AS A PERSON WITH A LEARNING
DISABILITY THERE'S ABOUT LESS
THAN ONE OF US IN GRADUATE
EDUCATION.
BY INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
GRADUATE STUDENTS IN THE UC
SYSTEM THAT WILL INCREASE THE
TRAJECTORY OF DIVERSITY THAT WE
SEE CAN NOT ONLY IN GRADUATE
STUDENTS BUT ALSO IN FACULTY
WHICH CAN RECRUIT NEW TALENT
THAT WOULD OTHERWISE NOT.
BE ENCOURAGED TO JOIN THESE
FIELDS THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MARK WINDOWS WITH
US YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA JUST
WANTED TO PROVIDE --
SOME BRIEF COMMENTS ON ITEM
NUMBER --
THREE S. YEAH YOU RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT ALLOCATED
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION --
OVER THREE YEARS TO SUPPORT
RESEARCH ON THE FUTURE OF WORK
AND WORKERS --
BY THE UC BERKELEY LABOR CENTER
IN A TIME WHERE THE ECONOMY IS
IN A ROBUST EXPANSION WITH
RECORD --
JOB GROWTH AND LOW UNEMPLOYMENT
THERE ARE SO FAMILY SUCH AS WEAK
WAGE GROWTH A SEVERE HOUSING
CRISIS AND INCREASE INCOME
INEQUALITY. FOR THIS REASON WE
THINK MORE DATA IS NEEDED ON HOW
CHANGES IN THE ORGANIZATION OF
WORK SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER WAGES
AND REDUCE.
WORKERS BARGAINING POWER WE
USUALLY NEED RESEARCH ON
POTENTIALLY DESTRUCTIVE CHANGES
IN THE WORKPLACE AS A RESULT OF
THE INTRODUCTION OF NEW
TECHNOLOGIES.
BASED ON ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
AND ROBOTICS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MATT BROUGHT ON
BEHALF THE TEAMSTERS --
WE REPRESENT ABOUT FIFTEEN
THOUSAND CLERICAL AND SKILLED
TRADE WORKERS THAT YOU SEE --
I WANTED IT BRIEFLY MENTIONED
YOU SEE PATH ISSUES BECAUSE
THEY'VE ARM YOU KNOW AND
NEGATIVELY IMPACT OUR MEMBERS
WE'VE HAD MISS PAYCHECKS LATE
PAYCHECKS.
IN I AN ACTOR VACATION AND SICK
TIME ACCRUE ROLES --
AND AND WE REPRESENT SORT OF THE
LOWER WAGE WORKERS THAT YOU SEE
SO -- IT'S
IT'S PUT OUR MEMBERS BETWEEN A
ROCK AND A HARD PLACE OF JUST
GOING FORWARD YEAH AS YOU
CONTINUE TO FIND YOU SEE PATH
WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY BEEN AN
EXPENSIVE PROGRAM --
WE LIKE TO SEE SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY BUILT IN --
KEEPING WORKERS IN MIND THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ELLIE MORE AND I'M
A PHD STUDENT IN A STRUCTURAL
AND EARTHQUAKE ENGINEERING AT
UCLA -- I
HAVE BEEN A PRACTICING ENGINEER
AND PLAN TO GO BACK TO PRACTICE
MY PROGRAM IN ORDER TO MAKE LOS
ANGELES A SAFER AND MORE
RESILIENT CITY.
MY AIR RESEARCH TOPIC DIRECTLY
TIES INTO THAT SEISMIC ORDINANCE
RETROFIT THAT PASSED IN LA IN.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND I
INTEND TO PROPOSE MORE --
ECONOMIC RETROFIT SOLUTIONS FOR
BUILDINGS SAVING THAT COMMUNITY
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS AND
RETROFIT --
THE UC BUDGETS REQUESTED WILL --
PROVIDE FACULTY ADVISORS FOR
RESEARCHERS LIKE ME AT A MONSTER
RESEARCH.
THE RESEARCH THAT IS GOING TO GO
BACK TO THE COMMUNITY AND MAKE
THE COMMUNITY A BETTER AND SAFER
PLACE.
IT ALSO FINDS TEACHING AND
RESEARCH ASSISTANT POSITIONS
THAT FIND OUR TUITION IT ALSO
ALLOWS ME TO TEACH AND MENTOR
OTHER UNDERGRADUATE AND GRADUATE
STUDENTS.
SO WHILE I APPRECIATE THE
ORIGINAL BUDGET THAT IS APPROVED
I SINCERELY URGE YOU TO CONSIDER --
THE EXTRA BUTTER THAT IS BEING
REQUESTED AND FULLY FUNDED THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CAROL YOUNG I'M A
PHD CANDIDATE AT UCLA AND MY
MAJOR IS IN SOCIAL WELFARE AND
PRIOR TO THIS HAVE SOCIAL WORKER
AND WORKED WITH SO MANY SUICIDAL --
CLIENTS AND THEIR FOR NOW I DO
SUICIDE PREVENTION WORK AT UCLA
AND I WAS ABLE TO BE FUNDED I
HOPE TO PAVE THE WAY FROM --
FUTURE STUDENTS TO ALSO GET
FUNDED BY THE U. C. SO I FULLY
ASKED TO SUPPORT ASK YOU ALL TO
SUPPORT THE BUDGET --
SECONDLY I AND ALSO A TEACHING
ASSISTANT AND I SEE THAT --
DIRECT IMPACTS --
WITH THE STUDENT MENTORSHIP AND
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS FOR THEM TO
GO INTO THE PUBLIC SERVICE ARENA
AND BEING ABLE TO BE A MENTOR%
AND PAVING THE WAY FOR THEM AS
WELL SO THAT WE HAVE --
FUTURE SIR SOCIAL SERVICES SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOSE ENOUGH
LOTUS MORALIS AND CURRENT
DOCTORAL STUDENT IN THE
SOCIOLOGY DEPARTMENT AT UCLA.
I CITY IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION AND
IN PARTICULAR MY PAST RESEARCH
HAS FOCUSED ON HOW SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA RECEIVED RECENTLY
ARRIVED MIGRANT STUDENTS AND
SUPPORT THEM TO ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNER PROGRAMS.
MY MORE RECENT RESEARCH TACKLES
THE ISSUE OF RETIREMENT IN OLDER
AGE FOR WORKERS IN PLACES LIKE
CALIFORNIA WHERE WE HAVE AN
ABUNDANCE OF UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS.
THAT LABOR EVERY DAY IN
AGRICULTURAL FIELDS IN
MANUFACTURING BUT AT THE END OF
THEIR WORKING LIVES HAVE NO
RETIREMENT AND SOCIAL PENSION
SUPPORT.
A WELL FUNDED YOU SEE ALLOWS
GRADUATE STUDENTS LIKE ME TO
TACKLE THESE ISSUES INTO EMERGE
INTO --
LOOKING INTO SOLUTIONS TO THE
SOCIAL PROBLEMS THAT WILL
CONTINUE. TO GET WORSE IN
ADDITION OF OFTEN DID YOU SEE
ALLOWS FIRST GENERATION AND NOT
THE NOT STUDENTS LIKE MYSELF
ENTER SOCIOLOGY AND OTHER SOCIAL
SCIENCE PROGRAMS AS WELL.
LASTLY OFFENDED YOU SEE MEANS
THAT UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS AT
PLACES LIKE UCLA AND THE OTHER
UC'S -- ARE
ABLE TO GET MENTORSHIP FROM
STUDENTS THAT LOOK LIKE THEM AS
SOMEONE WHO IS ALSO A UCLA BRUIN
ADAM.
IN MY UNDERGRADUATE DEGREE I WAS
ABLE TO BENEFIT SCHOOL SO WITH
THAT I URGE YOU ALL TO SUPPORT
THE UC BUDGET REQUEST THANK YOU.
HI -- MY
NAME IS LEAH PRO PAPADAKIS AND
I'M AT TWO YEARS AWAY FROM
GRADUATING WITH A DOCTORAL
DEGREE IN ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENCE
AND ENGINEERING AT UCLA.
AND FIRST I WANTED TO THANK YOU
GUYS FOR YOUR PAST SUPPORT OF
THE SEA BUDGET AND THEN TURN
HEARD YOU TO FULLY SUPPORT THE
YOU SEE REQUEST THIS YEAR.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT WITHOUT THE
FOR THE ONGOING SUPPORT FROM THE
YOU SEE THROUGH FELLOWSHIPS --
RESEARCH ASSISTANT TEACHING
ASSISTANT POSITIONS I WOULDN'T
BE IN GRAD SCHOOL RIGHT NOW
THERE'S NO WAY THAT MY HUSBAND
AND I COULD AFFORD OR MORTGAGE
IN.
LOS ANGELES CHILD CARE FOR BOTH
OF OUR KIDS IN TUITION ON JUST
ONE INCOME --
AND SO THE PAST SUPPORT ALLOWED
ME TO TAKE A PAUSE IN MY EIGHT
YEAR CAREER DOING COASTAL
RESTORATION WORK IN LOS ANGELES
TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL AND I HOPE
TO USE.
THE TOOLS THAT I'M LEARNING NOW
TO HELP LOCAL LIKE MY LOCAL
COMMUNITIES BETTER PREPARE FOR
CLIMATE CHANGE AND SAVE MONEY IN
THE FUTURE --
SO I URGE YOU TO FULLY FUND THE
UC REQUEST THIS YEAR AT WHICH
INCLUDES FUNDING FOR THOUSAND
MORE GRADUATE STUDENTS LIKE ME
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS AVELINE --
I'M A FIRST GENERATION IMMIGRANT
IN CALIFORNIA AND RIGHT NOW I'M
A FOURTH YEAR PHD STUDENT AT
UCSF STUDYING CANCER GENOMICS
AND SO MY RESEARCH REALLY
FOCUSES ON BRINGING THOSE TOOLS
TO THE PHYSICIANS.
THAT REALLY IMPACTS SAN
FRANCISCO ON THE BROADER
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY --
WE NEED FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO
CONTINUE DELIVERING THAT HIGH
QUALITY CARE ALSO ATTRACTING THE
BEST TALENT TO UCSF TO CONTINUE
THIS HIGH QUALITY.
RESEARCH AT THE TOP HOSPITAL IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S LIKE ME AND
SUPPORT THE UC BUDGET.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBERS FOR
LISTENING TO PUBLIC COMMENT
TODAY I'M ARIAL COSTUME IN PHD
CANDIDATE AT UCSF --
AND I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE UC
BUDGET I PERSONALLY DO RESURGENT
HEART DISEASE WHICH IS STILL THE
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH IN
CALIFORNIA AND ITS EARLY
RESEARCH LIKE MINE THAT SUPPORTS
THE UCSF MEDICAL CENTER. TO MAKE
IT THE NUMBER ONE MEDICAL CENTER
IN CALIFORNIA AND YOUR SUPPORT
OF THE BUDGET --
HELPS US MEET OUR CURRENT
STANDARD OF EXCELLENCE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON --
MY NAME IS TOM CAN SEE I'M A PHD
STUDENT AT UC DAVIS AND I'M A
TRUSTEE ON MY UNION'S BOARD YOU
A TO BE.
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY FIVE WE
REPRESENT NINETEEN THOUSAND
GRADUATE STUDENTS ECONOMIC
STUDENT WORKERS --
INCLUDING UNDERGRADUATES AT THE
UC -- I WANT
TO URGE YOU TO FUNDS THESE HIS
BUDGET REQUEST AS MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES IN THIS ROOM --
HAVE STATED --
BUT I ALSO WANT TO DRAW YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE UC PATH ISSUE --
THAT'S IMPACTING OUR WORKERS
RIGHT NOW --
UC PATH HAS BEEN A DISASTER FOR
US --
HUNDREDS OF WORKERS HAVE BEEN IF
WE'RE MISSING PAYCHECKS --
LOSS OF BENEFITS --
AND THIS IS A TOPIC THAT'S QUITE
LITERALLY VITAL FOR US --
WE ARE LOW WAGE WORKERS --
ALONG WITH MY COLLEAGUE MATT
FROM THE TEAMSTERS --
AND SO I ALSO WANT TO DRAW YOUR
TENSION TO TESTIMONY THAT MARKS
YOUNGER FROM YOU COP WAS GOING
TO GIVE TODAY --
MISTER SIAKA HAS SAID IN THE
PRESS THE NUMBER OF TIMES THAT
THEIR PROBLEMS WITH YOU SEE PATH
BUT HE IS SAID I WANT TO BE
CLEAR EVERYONE GETS PAID.
AND I WANT TO SAY TODAY CLEARLY
THAT'S NOT TRUE LAST WEEK --
WE BROUGHT --
GRIEVANCES FOR CLOSE TO TWENTY
WORKERS AT UC SANTA BARBARA SOME
OF THEM WHO HAVEN'T BEEN PAID
SINCE EARLY IN THE FALL SINCE
SEPTEMBER --
THIS BEHAVIOR BY YOU SEE IS
ILLEGAL OR IT SHOULD BE ILLEGAL
BUT IT'S CURRENTLY NOT.
WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING TAKES
THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CATHERINE NEVER
GONNA ON BEHALF OF COPYING
CALIFORNIA'S TOGETHER WE WOULD
LIKE TO BRING TO YOUR ATTENTION
THE NEED FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR FACULTY FOR BILINGUAL
TEACHER PREPARATION PROGRAMS ARE
UC.
AND CSU SYSTEMS IN OUR PRIVATE
UNIVERSITIES THERE IS A NEED TO
EXPAND EXISTING BILINGUAL
TEACHER PREPARATION PROGRAMS OR
STOP LIST NEW ONES IF WE ARE TO
BUILD THE CAPACITY OF BILINGUAL
TEACHERS FOR BILINGUAL PROGRAMS.
AND TWENTY SIXTEEN CALIFORNIA
HAD THIRTY STATE APPROVED
BILINGUAL TEACHER PREPARATION
PROGRAMS AS REFLECTED IN THE
REPORT GLOBAL CALIFORNIA TWENTY
THIRTY SPEAK LEARN LEAD
PUBLISHED BY STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TOP DUMP TRUCKS AND
INVESTING IN ADDITIONAL FACULTY
WOULD ALLOW GRAY COME BY
LITERATE BILINGUAL.
AS PROMISED BY PROPOSITION FIFTY
EIGHT THE CALIFORNIA MILEY MULTI
LINGUAL EDUCATION ACT AS WELL AS
INSURING QUALIFIED BILINGUAL
TEACHERS T. L. STUDENTS WE ASK
THAT YOU CONSIDER AB TEN TWELVE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAY AS
INTRODUCED THIS YEAR THAT SEEKS
SUCH AN INVESTMENT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON WHEN I THOUGHT OF
THIS MY GOD LEAKING KATE WITH
PUBLIC ADVOCATE.
AND WE APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION
TODAY'S THE SPECIFICALLY AND THE
FOCUS ON EQUITY AND HOW COME.
BASIC NEEDS AND THE NEEDS FOR
SPECIFICS WHEN IT COMES TO THE
EXPENDITURES IN CLOSING EQUITY
CAPTAIN ACHIEVEMENT GAPS --
WE SUPPORT THE UC'S INCLUDING
THE UC ESSAY STUDENTS AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS AROUND HOW TO BEST
ADDRESS THE BASIC NEEDS STUDENT
HUNGER HOMELESSNESS --
AND HOPE TO SEE HOW WELL THE
CURRENT PROGRAMS ARE PERFORMING --
PERHAPS MAYBE ANOTHER SURVEY OR
IT MAY BE A MORE IN DEPTH --
REPORT THANK YOU AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANKS FOR THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY WITH THAT WE ARE
ADJOURNED